foreign
welcome to Dave whatever
um we're going to take a a short break
uh Council have asked to have a few
moments to review
uh one piece of evidence before we start
so we're going to take 15 minutes and
we'll start at a quarter to ten and
again I apologize for the delay but
these things will happen so we're
starting at uh 9 45 this morning
thank you
the commission is in recess for 15
minutes
order a lot
the commission is very convenient
good morning again
I take it there's a
witness ready to go
[Music]
do so
good morning Mr commissioner yes
commission Council would like to call as
their next witness the account if you
could introduce yourself for the record
yes uh Jean Simone schernhaltz
commission Council and our next witness
is counselor Diane Deans
councilor Deans will you swear on a
religious document or do you wish to
affirm I will affirm
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out
my name is Diane Deans
d-i-a-n-e-d-e-a-n-s
do you solemnly affirm that the evidence
to be given by you to this commission
shall be the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth I do thank you
thank you ahead thanks
good morning counselor Deans good
morning
um so counselor Deans I understand that
you're a city councilor with the city of
Ottawa I am and you were chair of the
Ottawa Police Services Board during kind
of the events of February of January
February earlier this year up until
February 16th correct correct you had an
interview with commission Council on
August 16th this year I did and I'll
pull up WTS six zeros10
and this is a summary of your interview
correct correct you had an opportunity
to review that summary I have
do you have any corrections
I do not okay
and so we'll put that summary into
evidence
um counselor Deans I understand that the
the Ottawa Police Services Board which
I'll refer to as the opsb or the board
at it's a seven-member civilian
oversight body for the Ops correct that
is correct
and
um
the city appoints three counselors to
that board and one uh one resident
correct and then the province appoints
another three of those members right
and you were the chair of the board
during the relevant period I was okay
okay so I want to start by getting a
sense of what was known to the board
prior to the convoys arrival
I understand that the board was
regularly briefed by Ops leadership
um and that you personally as the chair
also had regular Communications with Ops
leadership
that's right
how often would you speak to to Chief
slowly for example
daily sometimes multiple times a day
um I understand that from your witness
summary that you were first brief on the
incoming Freedom Convoy by Chief slowly
and John Steinbeck
executive director of strategy and
Communications for Ops on January 24th
is that accurate that is accurate and
what do you recall about the information
that was relayed to you during that
briefing
um it
really it was it was the first
indication that I had that this was
happening and I hadn't been following it
in the media so it was the first time I
sort of took stock that there was this
Convoy rolling across the country
heading to the nation's capital so it
was basically we know about this we're
working with intelligence agencies to
gather information
they're coming at us and we're preparing
for them to arrive on Friday
and was there any
um information provided at that time
about kind of the the how significant
the number of trucks would be or how
long they intended to stay
I don't believe the timeline's a little
fuzzy in my head but I don't believe
that that very first briefing
um they
had that much detail they just sort of
conveyed to me that this was happening
there was a council meeting
on the 26th I had asked the mayor if we
could come to Council on brief Counsel
on it when we were getting more
information but he he said no so I
called a meeting of the board on the
26th when there was more information
shared okay and we'll we'll get to that
meeting in just a little bit
um before going to that I'd like to go
to Ops four zeros 2978.
so this is a copy of a of a briefing by
uh Deputy Ferguson that was if you
scroll down to the bottom please
uh just a little up
up up
okay so
um this is an email from Deputy Ferguson
to Kim ayat
forwarding uh information that was
provided to the board so you see here it
says below is at in the third line below
is the information we are sharing with
our board so if we can go down
over here perfect thank you
and you'll see it says the purpose of
this email is to update you on a trucker
Convoy schedule to arrive in Ottawa
beginning Friday January 28th this will
be a significant and extremely fluid
event that could go on for a prolonged
period and this again was on January
25th do you remember this
information uh being just provided to
you at that time
and um
and what was your understanding of
significant and extremely fluid event
that could go on for a prolonged period
well it's interesting because
um you know I I was starting to watch
what was happening coming across the
country I was aware that there was large
trucks I was aware that you know they
seemed to be picking up some steam as
they rolled across the country I was
aware of this unique situation where
they were
Gathering a lot of money through
GoFundMe site so
um you know I I understood that it was
coming at us quickly and that it was
different than things had
you know other we see a lot of protests
in Ottawa everyone that lives here knows
that but this one did feel different and
um you know uh
it said could go on for a prolonged
period I had discussed with Chief slowly
um that possibility and uh
whatever culture slowly saying to me
um is that he would be very surprised if
they were still here on Monday
do you remember when he would have told
you that
stay so I guess it was this day the 25th
because I had phoned him I had phoned
him several times and you know the more
I was watching this the more concerned I
was getting and uh he he said to me what
are you so worried about and I I told
him just what I told you the number of
trucks the size of those trucks the
amount of money that they have and and
he he said
that he wouldn't be surprised if they
were still here on Monday
and based on what you just said is it
fair to say that this kind of messaging
around significant and extremely fluid
event that could go on for prolonged
period
you just said there's a number of
protests in Ottawa is it fair to say
that this messaging was something
different than what you were used to
yeah I think this is different I I mean
I think that there was a recognition
that this was unique among
demonstrations I don't think we knew how
unique it was going to be in the end but
um I think there was you know
just watching the whole thing unfold as
it moved across the country was
something that we really hadn't seen
often
um we heard earlier this week from Steve
kanalakos at that in the advance of the
convoys arrival the city had received
information from a local hotel
association advising that protesters
were booking stays of 30 days
um and that that had been forwarded to
to the Ops
did the Ops ever brief ever kind of work
this information into any of the
briefings uh for the board no
so did the board have any uh any
information on this at all were they
notified no okay
okay so I'd like to pull up at OPB four
zeros one two five seven so these are
the minutes of uh that first
board meeting on January 26th this is
the public meeting
um so you call this special meeting
correct correct and during that meeting
the board was briefed by Chief slowly
and and his deputies yes
um
and I understand this meeting was called
on on short notice uh why did you feel
the need to call this meeting at this
time
um well as I said I had asked the mayor
to allow us to come to council and show
that information through the council
process and include the board members he
didn't want to do that so I I still felt
that it was important based on what I
was hearing and seeing that we provide
an update to the board and that they
have an opportunity to ask any questions
they had okay
so I like to go to page two
and if we go down at the first kind of
substantive paragraph here
it says second sentence they they being
the the Ops indicated that there was a
coordination of intelligence between
agencies and the service noted expecting
that the freedom Convoy would arrive in
Ottawa as early as Thursday and likely
to remain through Sunday
um I'd like to just look at another
quote and then get your your thoughts so
at the third paragraph
it says operational plans in place had
been informed by threat and risk
assessments the service advised that
they had been in contact the
demonstration protesters organizers
and the information suggests that it
would be a fluid event that could go on
for an extended period
the number of people involved was not
known
so uh were you able to to these these
two kind of statements seem a little bit
different in tone at was any information
provided
that would
allow you to to reconcile them
I I did speak to Chief slowly about this
and he did he didn't share the
intelligence information with me
um but he did tell me that
he did not feel that anything that they
were receiving through intelligence
channels
would lead them to believe that this was
other than a protest that would come and
go in a typical fashion
and when he advised you of this this was
not this was during a one-on-one call or
during a board meeting
during a one-on-one call okay
um
like to go to the third page
and the second paragraph on that page so
um says the service noted that their
priority was to maintain a safety of the
demonstrators their members and the
community as a whole the unpredictable
nature of an event such as this was
referenced
to what extent did the Ops brief the
board on its operational plans during
this first meeting
they they did not provide the board with
a detailed operational plan in fact we
never saw detailed operational plan
throughout until close to the very end
we were given assurances that there were
operational plans in place to address
the situation
and was here it talks about the priority
being to maintain safety of the
demonstrators their members in the
community as a whole uh
did the board inquire as to whether
there was a plan to ensure their egress
from the city at that time
to recall okay
and
at this juncture before
um before the Convoy arrived did the
board request that it be briefed with
the with the ops's operational plan
they the board was asking
about the plan I don't know that we ever
asked for a detailed briefing I know I
had had conversations with Chief slowly
about the plan and
um my impression of what he was saying
to me is that they didn't want to share
too much detail but they you know they
were providing assurance that there was
planning in place
would it be fair to say that at this
juncture the board wasn't asking to see
that
yeah I think as the protests went on the
board became more interested in a lot
more of the details of the planning
um
and In this passage that that I read the
second paragraph it sets out what the
priorities are
um to what extent did the board have an
opportunity to direct the Ops as to its
priorities with respect to this this
event
we discussed the high level priority
which was that
um you know we recognized the right of
protesters to come to our city and
protest in a peaceful way that we
recognize the volatility of this
situation
we recognized that our number one goal
is that there would be no serious injury
or loss of life to anyone
and so as chair of the board did you
feel that um the Ops or that the board
had an opportunity to provide input into
those priorities ahead of the the
convoys arrival I think we were way
aware of simpatico with the service on
what those high-level priorities were
okay
um let's go to the fifth paragraph on
this page so the one that starts with
the question
um says a question was raised regarding
actions that would be taken should a
highway or other major route be
blockaded the service explained that
there are a number of considerations
when faced with unlawful activity and
that their reaction will depend on
whether the blockades create a large
public safety risk it was further noted
that access to certain sites would be
limited and that the ops plan had been
put together to enable maximum
flexibility with layers of scalable
resources
was the board briefed on whether the
ops's plan would allow or restrict
access to the downtown core
I don't believe that that question
specifically was asked until after they
got him we started seeing what was
happening unfortunately
but you can see here what we were told
that it was you know
um
flexible layers of scalable resources
and
maximum flexibility but I don't think we
got into the details of that and I soon
after their arrival I started asking
those questions like why why do we let
them in here yeah okay and do you know
again at this juncture
were you briefed on any contingency
plans in the event that the protesters
didn't leave at the end of the weekend
um
I think that we were aware there was
possibility that they wouldn't all leave
but
listening to the chief the probability
was that they would
um
so I you know and the chief was also
telling me that we had negotiators
speaking with
um representatives of the Convoy and he
was conveying to me that they were
representative of about 70 percent of
the people that were here and that not a
hundred percent so that even when there
was discussions there was some potential
that what they were learning wasn't
necessarily always going to take place
so I think there was the sense that
things could be different than the
anticipation
um
and were you satisfied that if it didn't
go as expected and some either remained
or most remained that there was a plan
in in that event yeah they were I mean I
I think
the the level of detail I had is that
they were working with the organizers
and that
um they they believed or they were maybe
it was hopefulness I don't know but I
had the impression that they believed
that that they were going to leave
um
I understand that during this meeting
the Ops advised the board that it had a
staffing plan for for this event
um was
were any resourcing concerns
communicated at this juncture
not to the best of my recollection
and do you know whether there were any
contingency plans if
resources became overwhelmed
you know my impression is that um
there's a sense that the Ops that being
the nation's capital we have
um we've done we've seen a lot in terms
of large-scale events in this city and
generally speaking there is coordination
with you know the other policing
agencies that occupy space in the city
of Ottawa and that that kind of
thing would continue in this but in
terms of looking for Extraordinary
you know assistance at this point that
wasn't being discussed okay
I'd like to pull up opp40s1494
so this is a provincial operations
intelligence Bureau situational
awareness Bolton dated January 26th so
this is the same day as this board
meeting
um and we'll go to the third paragraph
uh on the left side there so it says uh
once in Ottawa Freedom Convoy 2022
organizers have stated an intent to
remain at Parliament Hill until the
federal government concedes to repeal
all covid-19 public health restrictions
and mandates organizers have indicated
they are planning to Stage disruptions
that may gridlock areas around
Parliament buildings and parts of Ottawa
there is no Express departure date for
when participants will disperse or the
action will end and I expect that we'll
be hearing uh
this afternoon I believe that um
that Chief slowly and some members of
the Ops referred these reports from uh
from the bureau that would contain this
kind of intelligence were you or the
board ever provided with
this kind of intelligence or even kind
of a high level uh summary of this type
of intelligence no
ah
and this the the first board meeting on
the 26th that was a public meeting
correct correct and neither you nor
Chief slowly requested that there be an
in-camera portion
um
would it be fair to say that
more information could have been
provided had there been an in-camera
portion
yeah I I think that's fair I
I didn't know about this information so
didn't know what to ask for but you know
hindsight's a great thing but in
hindsight yeah I would have liked to
have this information and would have
liked to know about it
and are you able to explain you know
the
was there some rationale to why it was
felt that there was no in-camera session
necessary at that at that time
um
in my my initial goal for that meeting
on the 26th was to Pro to share the
information that was available of course
I didn't have the benefit of knowing
what information was available
apparently so
um you know I didn't know that there was
perhaps some
intelligence information that could have
been shared I I guess I I really had the
impression from Chief slowly that
intelligence information was not to be
shared
so maybe a lesson learned there but but
I had the impression intelligence
information is kept in very close
um
proximity to the people on a need to
know basis and that it's not generally
shared
so your was your understanding that the
board went even in camera wouldn't
necessarily be entitled to this kind of
information
my impression is this information was
not going to be shared with the board
what they were receiving intelligence I
mean chief slowly was telling me things
like
um you know we're not getting any
messages from intelligence agencies that
it's other than protests we expect them
to be gone on Monday that's what the
message I was getting okay
okay and and
what led you to come to the conclusion
that the board wasn't entitled to
receive this kind of information
I'm
took Chief slowly at his word
had he requested for an in-camera
portion that day
which you've
been amenable to that of course
okay
um
so I understand from your witness
summary that it's during that that first
week that you realize that the protest
was turning into something that was a
more prolonged
um how did you reach that assessment
um
well
a lot of the protesters did leave on
Sunday night but the expectation was a
lot more of them were going to go than
actually vacated the Parliamentary
Precinct
and
um
Chief slowly was telling me that they
had negotiators they were talking to
them they were still hopeful that they
were going to clear out and I think it
was really about the Thursday that the
conversations had broken down and it
appeared that they were there were more
people coming back on that second
weekend that it really resonated with me
that you know perhaps it was a bit of
wishful thinking that they were going to
be able to get this wrapped up and gone
after that horrific first weekend
and then the thought of going through a
second weekend with more people
um you know wreaking havoc in our
neighborhoods in the downtown core was
uh was disturbing
who had told you that conversations had
had broken down slowly and that's is
that Communications between the PLT and
the protesters is that yes what you
believe he was referring yes
um so from
you had this first meeting on January 26
from January 27th through the first week
and the first weekend uh
or sorry through the first week the
board didn't meet again until the next
Saturday February 5th correct
yes I believe that's correct and
um why is that when you call the next
meeting why not earlier
so there was some conflict
um you know it was being advised by some
people that I needed to limit the number
of meetings that we were calling because
police resources were stretched thin and
every time I called a meeting it took a
whole lot of police resources off the
street and off the front line and that
they needed to prepare for that it's
time consuming Endeavor so we needed to
package up the questions that we had and
filter them through the Communications
Department of police to to try and give
as much flexibility to police to to do
their primary job which was to try and
shut down the occupation of our city so
I was trying to be respectful of that
but also I was in touch with Chief
slowly a lot I was communicating with
board members and with members of
council as they requested
but the
um
the the vice chair of our board Sandy
Smallwood who's been on the board a lot
longer than
I had and has connections across the
country one of the things that he was
doing was speaking with other
experts in the field of police
governance and talking about what we
needed to be doing as a board and Sandy
and I were talking regularly about that
because you know we're finding our way
in something I'd never been through
something like this before and it was
new to us and we were very concerned
we're cognizant of the what happened in
Toronto with the G20 very aware of the
Borden report I read the morning report
again through that process and we didn't
we wanted to make sure that we were
doing things
properly and so
um Mr Smallwood was in touch with
Professor Andy Graham at Queen's
University he was in touch with Alec
Mercury who have been the chair of the
Toronto Police Services Board he was in
touch with other experts across the
country and Sandy and I were talking
frequently about this and on the
Saturday morning we had this
conversation about
um
the depth of questioning that we as a
board were doing and I decided at that
point that I needed a lot more detail
about what the resource requirement was
because our the board is an oversight
body it has very limited roles but what
we need are our primary mandate is to
ensure adequate and effective policing
in the city of Ottawa and
I wasn't feeling comfortable that we
could we were meeting that test
and so I decided that I needed to call
an emergency board meeting on that
Saturday to put really a simple question
to the Chief and that was what do you
need what will it take to to end this
occupation of our city and that was the
purpose that was sort of the sole
purpose of that meeting to get to the
heart of the resource issue and what it
would take for us to restore peace to
our city
and we'll get to that February 5th
meeting in a little bit at who is
advising you not to
over over impose on on the police by not
calling too many meetings
um well the police
and their Communications people
um I listen to uh I listen to say our
past testimony the other day where he
noted he had also suggested to me that
um we we not call
a lot of board meetings because it was
consuming resources that were needed
elsewhere
so I'd like to go to OPB four zeros1624
so these are notes
um
from a February 1st briefing of the
board by Chief slowly and Deputy Bell
was it do you remember this briefing
vaguely there's a lot of them
um was it was it typical for the board
to receive
this kind of briefing outside of regular
board meetings
Point yes I mean we were we were kind of
we were kind of finding our way in terms
of not taking up too much time and
making sure that we were
um getting the information that we felt
we needed in the performance of our
oversight role
okay
um if we can just go down a little bit
on the first page okay the fourth bullet
down
uh says some resources have returned to
GTA but more resources retained from
peel Hamilton and OPP more specific
requests to OPP and RCMP
so whenever the my understanding is that
whenever the Ops would receive
additional resources from another police
force you were responsible for signing
the memorandums of understanding that's
correct okay
and um
how these resources that are mentioned
again this is February 1st at this stage
can you maybe just describe
the numbers and how long they were
generally staying for
yeah it varied there were a lot of
police agencies that were offering to
assist the city of Ottawa there was
Hamilton and peel I think Toronto
Cornwall
there were a lot and they were coming
and going they were freeing up resources
as they could and some of them would
stay for a week some of them would stay
for a number of days we were taking what
we could get because we were in need of
all of the help we could get at that
point
and so there were other events that
would take them back for example the
Convoy decided to go to Toronto and that
I think it was the second weekend and so
that a lot of the GTA resources that had
come to Ottawa got sucked back out of
Ottawa to to help with City of Toronto
okay and in terms of the significance of
the amount of officers can you speak to
that generally
um well we were grateful for the help
that way we're getting from those other
policing agencies
um but
um you know this was I think
the first and it was the fifth when I
had actually really drilled down with
Chief slowly in that meeting that I
called the special meeting and said we
need to know exactly what this is going
to take to end this occupation of our
city and I I need to see detail on that
like what is it who is it and you need
to lay that out and I think that was a
turning point okay
um
I'm interested here when it says more
specific requests to OPP and RCMP this
was as you mentioned
prior to that board meeting on the fifth
prior to the letter that you and the
mayor sent out to the province and the
FEDS
um so what kind of requests at this time
were being made of the opp and the RCMP
well there were I I guess that was my
issue they were more vague in that chafe
slowly and I can't exactly remember the
timeline you probably have it there but
Chief slowly had made a comment that
there may not be a policing solution I
can't recall what day he said that
um I believe it's the second but the
second I'm sure we'll have that
somewhere okay he had made that comment
and it sort of sent a ripple through the
city and the downtown core and a lot of
observers of what was happening there
because
um
it wasn't entirely understood but it was
alarming that the chief of police is
saying there may not be a policing
solution to this situation
um and I guess what
I took it to mean is that
there wasn't a policing solution locally
with Ops I mean Ops is
it it's a City Police Service it it does
community policing and emergency
response and a lot of other things and
certainly involves itself in large-scale
events because with the national capital
and we have over time but
um we hadn't seen something like this
before it was clearly different had a
different flavor it you know the whole
thing was not like anything anyone had
seen in the city before and I think it
had become clear to Chief slowly that we
did not have the resources inside Ottawa
Police nor do we have the expertise in
terms of you know setting out a real
plan on how you're going to get this
tiger by the tail
inside police we just hadn't had much
experience with this and so that's what
I took from what Chief slowly is that
we're we're gonna need a lot of help
and and that's what I took him to mean
from that
um you you mentioned needing kind of
external expertise is that something
that she slowly said to you
um
or was it just your assessment
I came to that conclusion I I can't
specifically say to you he specifically
said that to me but I I
I got there in terms of understanding
that
and maybe it was later because once the
RCMP and the opp embedded into our
Command Center and they had a joint
command structure where they brought
with them those kinds of resources
we were starting to see things coming
together
okay
um so so coming back to this briefing so
I understand it as Chief slowly is
advising you and the board that more
specific requests were being made to the
opp and the RCMP correct correct
um but you're not clear on exactly what
those resources those requests were that
were being made that I I think that
we're just saying we need help
um but I my my issue when I call that
meeting later that week on this Saturday
was but we we needed to enunciate what
that was
okay
um is it at this point that
um that the board was advised that more
resources were were necessary is this
around the time the first time the board
was advised I think so okay
okay uh if we can go to page six
near the bottom of that page
okay so
um
so just going up just a tiny bit okay uh
so there's a question asked if there was
legal Authority issued around a court
order for removal what would be the
threshold for removing trucks and people
large conglomerative people and vehicles
and then my understanding is Trish
responds indicated earlier on that we
had a number of Opp commanders involved
with previous occupation events
consistently what we are hearing an
injunction is an option on the table
everyone we have spoken to we are not
feeling that an injunction is the best
way to go clear indication that
injunction might be the worst way to go
we will keep all options on the table
and we'll be able to justify using or
not using them so do you know who made
this statement
I think it was trash Ferguson do you
remember this discussion about an
injunction at this time
um
I don't remember specifically Trish
answering this but you know I I know
there was a lot of discussion around an
injunction okay
um and there was a lie I mean
it's interesting now you put it in front
of us there was a lot going on here it
was a whirlwind for 20 days and it it's
hard to remember every single thing that
every person said in order so at least
we have notes absolutely
um and I'm I'm interested in here
there's a statement that an injunction
might be the worst way to go I'm
wondering if you have any insight into
what that meant
I phoned David White who is the city
solicitor
um
and to talk about the issue of an
injunction because it was one of the
tools that occurred to me that was in
the toolbox that could provide some help
and I had that conversation with David
and it was a bit it went a bit like this
it was like well I'm not necessarily
interested in the content of the
conversation okay yes there's solicitor
client privilege potentially here so
just tread carefully please absolutely
and just for the auto Coalition I
believe solicitor client privilege has
been waived already on a considerable
amount of the advice for Mr White to
city council we do have his memo
um wouldn't this wouldn't this be a
subject matter upon which there's
already been a social client waived uh
Mr commissioner the one memo was Legal
Information Mr White deliberately did
not Mark the document solicitor client
privilege because he didn't intend
privilege to apply so there's been no
waiver we have been very reasonable in
our redactions where Mr White was acting
as part of the city leadership team well
not officially but an important person
providing strategic or tactical advice
we've we have released that where
there's legal advice though there's been
no waiver
got into a bit of a
dispute here so we'll try and get it
organized in a proper way
so firstly what is being sought as and
are you intending to pursue this uh my
my intention was the with the question
was just to understand what was said at
this meeting my understanding is that Mr
White
is not the person answering this
question so that was my intent for for
this particular question
okay so what you're trying to understand
is what
was the result of that meeting uh was
what the meaning of you know an
injunction might be the worst way to go
which was apparently communicated in
this uh briefing what that meant what he
understood from that and not to relate
the specific statements by
the lawyer correct that fair is there
any objection of that none Mr
commissioner any problem with that I see
you're standing
to my my friends positions and I based
on what has been said I'm probably going
to go there in my own examination but I
would just like to point out this I
understand that the police service board
or police commission has their own legal
counsel
it's not Mr White
there's no solicitor-client relationship
between this witness and Mr White
and in my respectful submission as a
result there's no issue with privilege
further if it was a personal
solicitor-client relationship if the
witness would like to waive solicitor
client privilege that's her prerogative
okay sir thank you
um so I think oh sorry yes I'm sorry you
can you can remain seated probably
better for the microphones as long as I
can see you I'm happy
um I do have a concern
um in in my submission privilege if
there was privilege privilege was waived
there is considerable documentation
there are memos from Mr White there is a
witness statement from Mr White and it
may be although this witness may not go
further it may well be a subject on
which there will be cross-examination
because once you open that door you
can't close the door again and say well
I'm only going to give you this but I
won't answer that question okay I think
they're real there's a real issue around
this also with respect to the testimony
of the mayor I think who talked about
this subject I believe also so what I'd
suggest is kind Council can discuss this
it's at this point it's academic I
understand what what you're saying about
it may come up and cross so I'd suggest
counsel and and commission counsel
discuss this at the break or at the
lunch because it should be discussed
before the cross-examination
and certainly there has been a lot of
talk about legal opinions but I'm not
going to go much farther at this point
it's a question of what
what the city is going to the position
the city will take
and if that could be cleared up over the
break or the lunch that would be
appreciated okay
go ahead thank you Mr maybe maybe then
if I could just broadly answer your
question I think that the part that um
says there was a clearing indication
that an injunction might be the worst
way to go I think they were referring to
the concern if they wrote an injunction
in a way that it was denied by a court
okay thank you
um
if we can go to add the next page
near the bottom of that at page seven
there was a question here can you put
boundaries protect their right to
protest by but limit where they can go
and the answer is uh very little
um do you recall who said this during
this meeting
I think it might have been shaped slowly
and what was your understanding of the
the reason that there was very little
that could be done to limit access to
further Vehicles wanting to enter the
downtown core there there seem to be a
view that there was a charter right to
allow those vehicles uh into that area
and also um I had taken that up with the
city manager Steve kanalakis in an email
exchange I did with Mr kanolakis and he
said that there were no other places for
the vehicles to go basically so
um
that that seemed to be their view those
sort of conflicting views but the two
that I had heard at the time why the
vehicles were there thank you
um I'd like to go to documentont401120
and we'll go to the
to the the bottom of that document
to provide a context just the very
bottom
uh so moving up from there
um so
this is just to to kind of provide you
the context so my understanding is that
on February 1st christopherraro who's
the executive director of the board
correct correct uh how to call with
Lindsey gray and who's Lindsey Gray
shape at the time was the board advisor
from the solicitor General's office
and there was a call on February 1st at
and the the
about
operational decisions
uh do you work were you on this call do
you remember this I I don't believe I
was on the call okay
um if we can just go up to the top then
of the document
so um
this is an email from these solicitor
General's office advisor Lindsey gray II
at
Miss Ferraro
and it provides some citations I guess
from the Morden report
um
do you remember seeing this
um yes okay and so do you know what the
context was for Miss Ferrara reaching
out to the board advisor on this we were
the board was very cognizant of our role
as an oversight body and we
you know we really had the
um
the pro the problems that the Toronto
Police Services Board had gotten into
during the j-20 in the Forefront of our
mind we didn't want to go down the same
path and make the same mistake so we
were trying to in real time I guess
learn from that and seek as much advice
as we could
about our role and and you know the art
of the possible what we were allowed to
do where that line was and you know and
um
it might be a little bit foggy to some
people but Morton shed a lot of light on
it in their report and and it's a
valuable document and we wanted to
understand the solicitor General's
interpretation of some of that so it's
fair to say that during this first week
the you and the board were trying to to
come to a full understanding of what
your role was in this kind of situation
yes and uh maybe at a high level could
you you know what were the the key
takeaways that that you can recall of
what the board's role was
um
so
the Morton report basically
um
is sort of
sort of a guideline for what happens in
this kind of a
large event situation large scale
situation and where that line between
the oversight and the operations is and
I I think what Morton was pointing out
and my understanding is the board can
the board cannot direct the chief in
terms of operations but the board can
certainly ask questions about the plan
the details of the plan the board can
ask questions about the
resource requirements what they what the
service needs and the board can work to
assist the service in those areas and so
uh
um and you know all of that with the
backdrop of our mandate is to ensure the
provision of adequate and effect of
placing so we were in this situation
trying to learn from the Morton report
and make sure that we were ultimately
fulfilling our oversight role
thank you that's helpful
um was your
understanding also that the board had a
role in setting priorities and
objectives in the context of a large
event yes yes
great
um
saved me time not having to read a quote
so that's good
um if we could just go to uh ont000112
um so this is just an email a week later
um
Mr Sweda I believe one of the board
members
I guess had heard if you can go right to
the bottom to the first email in your
chain had heard that
this engagement between Miss Ferraro and
and uh
and the advisor had taken place and was
was asking to be briefed
um do you do you know why
kind of the information wasn't provided
to the whole board from the outset
I would suggest to you that there was
um it was just a resource issue our
Board office has an executive director
and one administrative assistant and
there was an awful lot coming at that
board
office during this and I think it was
just a resource issue
thank you
okay I'd like to go to OPB uh five zeros
four two four
so this is on February 3rd
and it's an exchange between you and
chief slowly so if we could go uh to the
first part of the exchange uh keep going
down to the next yeah
so this is an email from you to the
Chief and my understanding is that you
are offering him support and securing
additional resources
do you recall that and then if we go up
to Chief slowly's response
that he responds that the Ops is making
efforts to secure additional resources
from the RCMP OPP and Municipal services
and he's encouraging
the board to use their influence to do
the same do you remember that yes
um
what
and it may be that you've already given
me the answer but what kind of resource
request did you understand were being
made at this time
this was four additional
mostly boats on the ground officers
um
yeah
and those were requests being made
directly from the Ops to their police
encounter Parts at the opp and the RCMP
yes okay
do you know uh
how many how many officers were being
requested at that time so that was the
issue they they weren't providing them
with uh in my estimation enough
information about the resource
requirement they're just saying we need
help and send what you can and and to me
that wasn't good enough it wasn't clear
enough that's why I ultimately called
that meeting on the Saturday and and how
did you know
as as the requests were being made
police to police how did you come to
know that that was the the the nature of
the requests being made
I was in constant touch with Chief
slowly we were talking about resources
every day how many were there how many
were coming how many were going
um you know the what was possible with
the resources that we had I mean we're
getting requests from members of council
especially in the impacted areas to send
more resources we don't have more
resources we have a police service by
now that is very tired we've had people
working overtime they've been working
under very stressful conditions they
haven't had any time off and we know
that there is a real need for more
assistance and you know at this time
these resources were they being
requested to
maintain kind of a tired police force or
was it to build up to enough capacity to
take enforcement action do you do you
know well in one conversation I can't
tell you the day because it's all kind
of
melded together in my mind but in one
conversation with the chief I mean he
was saying the resources that we're
getting now are just allowing us to do
what we're doing and not allowing us to
advance any further and you know we have
a whole city to police out there's not
just the downtown and we've pulled
resources out of that as well but
um you know it's not sustainable do you
know if that conversation was before
your letter went out to the the feds in
the province
I believe it was
um
so uh on February 5th as we've discussed
you you call this uh this meeting of the
board
um
and so what I I understand it was called
on short notice what led you to call it
on an urgent basis
um
it was the weekend a lot more people had
come to town they were wreaking havoc
honking horns having parties on
Parliament Hill
um you know
really terrorizing our residents and it
was just going on and on and I felt at
that point we're spinning our wheels and
something something more had to be done
something had to change and I was
getting frustrated and we're probably
going to talk about this that later but
I didn't know that there were issues you
know that the RCMP and the opp had
because nobody told me that
but I couldn't understand why the
resources weren't coming but in my mind
we needed to enunciate exactly the
resource requirement and what that was
for and what it would take I mean we'd
have the chiefs say publicly that there
was perhaps no policing solution I took
it to mean we didn't have enough at
Ottawa Police so what did we need what
what would it take what did that look
like to bring it to an end and by
Saturday I was just I think I was just
you know my weights end honestly and I
was just bombarded with constituents and
calls from members of council and calls
from board members and people
with all kinds of suggestions from what
we might be thinking of doing from
bringing in the Army to everything else
and I'm I just
trying to be rational about this and
think we we need to lay out exactly what
we need and we need to do it now and I
phoned Chief slowly I said I'm going to
call a special board meeting and I'm
going to ask you
what it would take
in terms of resource requirement to
bring this thing to an end and I want
you to answer that question and I I mean
he was really busy and understood that
he didn't want me to do that meeting but
I just felt it had to be done
um go to opb401264
so these are the minutes of that
February 5th meeting if we could go to
page five
so in the
um
in the second paragraph
says that although the board expressed
frustration at the lack of clearly
outlined plan that would result in the
end of the demonstration the service
noted having articulated a framework
aimed at their Surge and contain
strategy
so
I take it at this meeting the board was
pushing to get more information on what
the plan was right
um and were you advised at this point
that there was a plan
to actually bring the uh bring these
events to an end
we were advised that there were plans in
place there were pieces of plans
um and uh you know that they were
working on they it was an evolving
strategy as I understood it as things
evolved the plan was evolving and they
and being worked on in sort of real time
um but I just I was looking for more
detail
and where you provided with more detail
the next day the Chief came back and
provided more detail he provided a list
of his resource requirements and what
that looked like in terms of Officer
officers and other civilians that would
be useful in the overall plan
so the next day he provided you with
details on the resources that were
necessary and we'll go to that that
table
was any further Insight provided on what
the you know the the operational plan
was to to specifically bring it to an
end
um I don't remember how much information
they gave us on on like detailing out
we're gonna do this on this day and this
on this day we didn't get that level of
detail
um until the very very end we were
starting to see those levels of here it
is but my impression was it wasn't that
well hatched at that point
and here it says the service noted
having articulated a framework aimed at
their search and contain strategy what
was your understanding of the objective
of the surgeon contain strategy was it
to bring the bring this to an end or was
it to uh to manage the situation
yeah
and the ultimate goal was to bring it to
an end
um
I know that some of their strategies
were specifically targeted targeted to
uh specific installations
um and you know I guess they felt that
it was methodical you had to do things
in in a certain order and you know
address one issue before you addressed
uh the next issue and it was a resource
requirement I guess the more resources
we had the more they could
move forward okay
um let's go to page three and it's the
fourth paragraph down
uh
so it says the service had received
supports from the opp the RCMP multiple
surrounding Municipal Services however
still needed more
um I take it again that you were aware
of these resources coming in because you
had signed mous yes
um
but I mean yes I was aware of them
coming in but it was
there was some creative math around
around how many resources were actually
there and who knew they were there and
on the ground because there were three
shifts I believe
one time they were 10 hour shifts they
moved to 12 hour shifts so
um to get the to really get a clear
understanding of how many
police officers at any one time were you
know inactive service was a bit
difficult
okay
um
and at this point again this is on the
fifth
are are the resources coming in more
significant
yeah it's it's such a good question
because
um
you know we were hearing
that there were more resources than we
were seeing and chief slowly and I not
just this day but many days had
conversations about
who was there and who was saying what
and what those officers were and both
from the provincial perspective I mean I
think Sylvia Jones actually dialed back
um
she said they had sent 1500 officers
they had done no such thing
but she did she did actually walk that
back later and said that's actually not
correct and then some of the RCMP
officers weren't under the command of
Ottawa Police for the purpose of this
demonstration they were doing other
things so there was some Creative
Accounting when it came to to the number
of police that were available for this
occupation and when you're saying the
RCMP we're attending to other things
is that I understand some of them were
attending to to Federal institutions
Federal properties correct okay
um maybe it's helpful uh so at this
February 5th meeting the board approved
the appointment of 257 RCMP officers
um which I guess would have been sworn
in as special constables so did that
mean that 257 were on the ground like
what does that mean in practice if 257
are are approved well in practice
um they're not all on the ground at the
same time obviously because you have
shifts either two shifts or three shifts
a day so
um
you know that many are approved that are
available but in the case of those 257 I
believe some of those were ones that
weren't under our commands so we I mean
it sounded like we had 257 but we didn't
we had far less
um if we go to page three and and the
third paragraph
okay
um
oh sorry I have third paragraph from the
bottom
so the second sentence the service later
however highlighted the need for
additional legal supports in both the
short and medium term requesting
assistance to find uh Uncharted legal
territory the service reference the
criminal code is being archaic and both
the provincial highway traffic act and
city of Ottawa bylaws is being Limited
in that they've all failed to consider
events such as the trucker Convoy do you
recall who said this
I believe it was too slowly
and what did you understand
this to be to mean
um
well it's just that we didn't have the
tools that we needed in terms of
um this specific Convoy with large
18-wheel vehicles to be able to
effectively address
legal issues around that because this
had not perhaps ever been considered in
terms of criminal code or even our own
Ottawa bylaws in the past
did you understand it to be saying that
they needed uh new enforcement authority
to
effectively end this
these events
I don't know that I would say I
understood it just to mean enforcement
Authority I think I understood it to
mean that
the actual
policies that were in place under those
Acts were insufficient
um to do to deal with this particular
event was there any specific type of
authority that you understood they were
they were asking for
um I
I I honestly can't recall what those
would have been now
let's go to page five at paragraph five
um
a question was raised regarding whether
the service's assumption that the
demonstration was only going to last for
the initial weekend was due to a lack of
intelligence the service noted having a
large amount of intelligence from the
time the Convoy began its travels across
country the intelligence indicated that
there would be small groups staying into
the weak but ultimately it had seemed as
though the crowd would be departing
um do you know who provided this
information to the board
most of the information the board was
receiving was provided by Chief slowly
some of it was provided by deputy chief
Bell and others was provided by acting
deputy chief Ferguson but most of the
information conveyed to the board
I mean really the police service and the
the
um
the command senior command was the
boards really only point of information
um if we could go to
opb000 sorry four zeros one six four
seven
so these are the in-camera minutes for
this same meeting
um page two paragraph four
the
um
oh sorry yeah the chief reassured the
board that there was a comprehensive
plan however he could not provide all
the details of what the service was
doing uh operationally why was this
raised during the in-camera portion of
this meeting
I I think that the board was
increasingly becoming concerned that
there wasn't enough of a plan
and
um I can't specifically remember that
conversation or who had raised it in
camera but I think the point was that
there was some pressure being brought to
bear on the chief for more detail around
that plan
and did you understand him to be saying
that the board was not entitled to that
information you know there's always this
little push and pull between an
oversight body and the the service
itself and the senior command and
um
you know if you talk to Chiefs across
the country it wasn't just Stars they
will tell you that we're only entitled
to this much and we can't interfere and
there is some tension between boards and
the service in this regard and I think
it's fair to say that as this occupation
of our city continued the board started
pushing harder and harder for more
details around that plan and we're
perhaps a little more emboldened in
recognizing that
we needed that information
foreign
do you recall the chief ever telling the
board or telling you that he needed to
receive the resources before he could
finalize a plan
remember those words but I you know I I
definitely had the impression that
um
we
we didn't have the resources to bring
about an end to this occupation he'd
made that very clear so
um yes you you need to understand your
resource
availability in in having an operational
plan
okay
um
Ott at three zeros one seven three four
nine so this is a February 5th email
that a resident forwarded to
um
an email between a resident and and
counselor McKenney that was forwarded
um to the board as well
and if we just go down just a little bit
thank you you see here a response from
your colleague counselor Meehan and she
was also a board member correct
yes and you see she says so so very
sorry Catherine who had she had
forwarded this residence email wish we
had the power to do something uh besides
watch
did you or other members of the board
share in this sentiment
fairness there was a lot of frustration
and we all wish that there was more we
could do
um
um you know this is counselor mayhem's
um uh statement that she felt that we
were watching from the sidelines I mean
I I don't think I necessarily fully
share that sentiment that's expressed
here
um but certainly the role of Police
Service is for in terms of oversight is
limited
so what did you feel that you could do
as a board
I I mean I think I've described that to
you earlier that
felt we could push for more details of a
plan we felt we could high level sudden
expectation we thought we could assist
in the acquisition of resources from
other police services and use our
political channels to perhaps put
pressure on other levels of government
to shake loose those resources that we
needed okay
um
so
let's go to
ott10010
so these are notes from Jessica Bradley
who I understand is your assistant of a
meeting between you the chief and the
mayor on February 6th do you remember
that meeting yes
and you've seen these notes before yes
and they reflect generally you know
content of that meeting yes
um
so at the top it says large operation
going on at Coventry planning has gone
on overnight operation commenced around
4 pm elevated level of resistance
brought in more resources at not going
well
so
um
I take it an operation was ongoing at
Coventry to clear out Coventry at that
time that's right and why was it not
going well
yeah I mean a good question for the
chief but they
I think it boiled down again to lack of
resources I mean they secured one area
but the plan was to secure the entire
area and they didn't manage to do that
and
um and was the board advised as to or
you or the board as to why it failed
Chief slowly and I spoke about some of
of those issues around the the failure
again and I I think our Focus was on the
resources that were needed and what was
happening there and
um
you know a lot of information about uh
you know did they have more information
did they Freedom Convoy people have more
information about that operation than we
anticipated did we have enough resources
when
um but it didn't go well I mean that was
the bottom line and
again it came down to having a plan that
we could operationalize and having the
boats on the ground to make it happen
um if we go down just a little bit you
see this heading pass or enhance
existing bylaws and then there's a
number of sub-bullets and then it says
slowly to provide top three bylaws we
should focus on can you maybe just
explain
what this discussion was about
yeah
um there were
a lot of concerns I by this time I think
there was you know a growing lack of
faith in the city and the police service
and in just about everyone to get this
job done there were frustrations being
spoken about about how bylaw Services
was or was not assisting and
um you know I had heard issues around
bylaw Services giving our own citizens
in those areas tickets but failing to
ticket the freedom Convoy members and
there was just a lot of of of
frustration
um
and um
so you know we're trying to practically
assess are there bylaws that we could
focus on right now in real time that
would be of assistance
to help help with the situation we're in
and that included the possibility of
passing new bylaws
um I I think we could have passed new
bylaws if they would be helpful yes okay
and so this final bullet slowly to
provide top three bylaws we should focus
on that was kind of the action item from
this discussion yeah yeah and and what
was he supposed to do
well it just just tell us what we're not
doing is municipality I mean this is
more wearing my heart as a member of
council and the mayor wearing his hat is
the the head of council to say well if
their shortcomings and our bylaws that
are an impediment to
progress here then tell us what bylaws
you need fixed and what that would look
like and we'll we'll take it from there
and was that list of three bylaws
provided
okay and what was the idea here
I guess the question that comes to mind
is if there was difficulty enforcing
existing bylaws what was the reasoning
here in identifying additional
um enforcement power under bylaws
well the difficulty in enforcing bylaws
was specific
um to some of the bylaws we were asking
them to enforce and if there were other
bylaws that would be useful I mean I
think just the exercise of passing a
bylaw in the middle of this and bringing
attention to it might have been helpful
and there might have been bylaws that
Chief swole could have assisted uh could
have identified that were enforceable
okay
um then it says at the very bottom of
the page there the chief needs 1800
officers
um is that the first time he he kind of
specified the number
he was on the six I think this meeting's
on the sixth it was on the six yes
okay
um so let's go to ott405590
so the next day at my understanding is
that you and the mayor received a table
from Chief slowly setting out the
resources he required and substantiating
essentially that 1800 number you
remember this yes so let's go just down
to see the table
there we go thank you
um and so this was a response to to that
discussion the day prior
correct well with response to the
discussion the day prior and to the
meeting of the board on the fifth okay
and were you satisfied with the with
with the level of detail provided in
this table
generally speaking yes
um did
slowly ever brief the board on how these
1800 officers would fit into his
operational plan no
you weren't provided with that kind of
level of detail I I do not believe we
were
okay
um I expect that we'll hear testimony
suggesting that in preparing this table
and this request for 1800 she slowly
instructed his officers to ask for
double of what they required had you
ever heard anything about this no
no
and so later this that later that day
this I don't think I've mentioned I
think this email is dated the seventh if
we could just
thank you so later this day you and the
mayor issued those letters to the feds
and the province requesting the 1800 was
this table ever provided to the province
or or the federal government do you know
I do not know
do you know if they ever receive kind of
a detailed breakdown to to go along with
your request
I mean that would be
a a question I think best put to Chief
slowly okay
we heard from Mr acting the other day
that the mayor was initially reluctant
to send out that letter
um
but that the Ops had essentially told
him that their requests were not being
heard and so it needed to be escalated
uh to the political level uh does that
align with your recollection
can you just repeat that question so Mr
I think uh testified that the mayor was
reluctant to sign the letters to the
province and to the the federal
government
um initially but that
um the the Ops had communicating to him
that their own requests for resources
the ones we'd talk about earlier
um were not being
received we're not being heard and so
that it required escalation kind of at
the political level
was certainly I was aware that the chief
was frustrated in being stonewalled and
getting the resources he believed he
needed I was not aware that the mayor
was reluctant to sign the letter okay
thank you
um and and so you sent and and you I
mean you and the mayor sent these
letters to both the province and the
federal government at essentially the
same time
um I expect that we'll hear that the the
federal government had some concerns
that this request didn't follow the
proper process
set out in the police services act where
it should have essentially the the
notion being that it should have gone
first to the province and then if
necessary to the federal government uh
were did were you made aware of those
concerns at any point
uh no
did anyone ever advise you from the
federal government or the province that
a different process should have been
followed
no
you weren't advised that
this would somehow delay the process or
delay the the response to the request
not to best of my recollection
um I'd like to pull up ont 50851
so do you recognize this letter
this is the response from Minister Jones
on February 10th
if we could just go to the top of page
two
so it says regarding the city of Ottawa
and Ottawa Police Services board's
request for significant additional
operational resources please note that I
have shared your correspondence with
Ontario Provincial Police Commissioner
Thomas Creek commissioner Thomas Creek
and the rscnp commissioner Brenda lucky
will continue to liaise with Chief Peter
slowly to determine how policing
Partners can provide support based on
available policing resources and the
operational plan proposed by the Ops you
remember reading this yes and what were
your thoughts on reading this letter
foreign
I mean I took it as generally positive
that their the lines of communication at
the police level were open they were
going to continue to
discuss it
um I I guess you know we're politicians
we we sent the letter between
politicians to try and put a little
pressure
um because Chief slowly was expressing
concern that he wasn't getting the
resources at the policing level that he
needed and so you know my feeling was we
needed to exert some political pressure
on the process
let's pull up opb858
so
um this is a email chain with respect to
your approval uh and sorry this is on
February 10th your approval of 400 RCMP
appointments if we can just go down so
if you re yeah so that one in the middle
sorry
so you see this email from Krista
Ferraro to yourself and asking you to
please provide approval for the the 400
officers and if we just go up to the top
of the chain
there's a response from Julia Keith
she's she's from your office correct
correct and she says the chair approves
this request she's asked me to convey
her concern that mousse for new
resources articulate that RCMP officers
are fully embedded in the Ops and fully
Deployable
um
that was in
in reference to your concerns that
you've previously indicated that
they would be assigned to Federal
resources or otherwise not Deployable is
that correct that is correct they were
not helpful to us in this situation
unless they were embedded in the Ops and
Deployable
can you briefly explain to us I think it
would be helpful if we could understand
the process for uh squaring in these
officers
um so you know you the and I understand
this only happens with RCMP officers
correct now where uh
yeah you may be correct I wasn't at any
of the swearing-in personally but the
swearing-in was done by the CEO of
Ottawa Police it was done twice daily I
believe at nine in the morning and nine
in the evening and it was flexible so if
there was a need to do it
any other time
um Blair Blair was flexible to do that
so could we just walk through let's say
the rcnp says we're going to give you
250 officers what's the first thing that
needs to happen
do you need is it that you need to you
need to approve it yeah I so so I would
do the approval and then the CEO would
do the swearing-in there was I I asked
Blair dunker about this was there any
delay on our end and swearing in
officers and her answer was no
and then what happens after the
swearing-in
um presumably there's some I I mean
that's an operational issue so probably
best to put to the cheap but I presume
there's some sort of training that goes
with you know being deployed under the
Ops and you know our specific
issues and
um and then they would be deployed so is
it fair to say your line of sight is is
just on the approval and the swearing-in
and and what I think the the only other
element is the signing of the mous at
what point does did that occur in in
kind of that sequence it was occurring
throughout when when they'd send me a
pile of Mo years I would sign them okay
and and do you know if that came before
the swearing-in
it would come before the swearing him
okay all right
and my understanding is it's necessary
to to swear in the rcnp officers as
special constables so that they can have
the authority to enforce provincial uh
uh bylaws and laws correct
okay thank you
so I think you've already said that
um
we we've heard from Mr afte and his his
Communications with Mr Jones from
Minister mendocino's office that was
there was a difficulty reconciling the
the numbers being provided by the RCMP
and the numbers being provided by the
OPP you were you were aware of that I
take it
I was aware through Chief slowly that
um that the the numbers that he was
actually staying on the ground and the
numbers that were being communicated
were different okay
um
and I think we've missed ours we missed
one step in our in our previous
discussion I believe that the the
solicitor General's office also needs to
sign off on the uh the approval of these
officers
are you aware of that I I'm not aware of
that no okay
so you wouldn't be aware if there was
any delays at that level no okay
okay
um
we heard the other day that Mr Jones
reported to Mr African that our CMP
officers were assigned to Ottawa but on
standby because they hadn't been given
an assignment by the Ops are you do you
have any information that you know are
you able to confirm or deny that
those kind of statements
no okay
that that information was not shared
with me or with the board and I I was
actually a little bit surprised to hear
that City officials were given
information in that regard that was not
shared with the police oversight body
so you were never told that that
RCMP officers were assigned to Ops but
on standby
okay
so from your Vantage Point where was the
where was the hold up in the deployment
of of these resources
um I didn't have a vantage point on
where the holdup was it just the way it
was communicated to me was more that
there was confusion or you know some
sort of Creative Accounting and the the
actual numbers but what was being
spoken about and the reality were
different but that that was as far as it
went
um
Mr Jones also reported to Mr akhte on
February 12th that there was delays in
deploying officers because Chief slowly
hadn't signed off on a plan had you
heard anything about that no
by this point on February 12th had you
seen a plan
we were
um
we had we had not seen the full plan
so let's go to OPB four zeros one two
seven two this is the these are the
minutes from the February 11th uh public
meeting
and if we could just scroll down
okay so right in the first paragraph can
we just expand that so it fills the
screen uh Chief slowly provided opening
remarks indicating that there remain
sensitivity surrounding the ops's
operational plans he noted that
demonstrators were now subject to higher
penalties and fines the service was
aware that more people were planning to
return to Ottawa over the weekend and
they were deploying all available
resources the chief indicated that
although progress was being made the key
remained uh resourcing
um
do you know again here why this was
raised at the very beginning of the
meeting in terms of sensitivity around
ops's operational plans
um
I think this was the real point of
tension in the whole thing that we
needed to have a solid plan there needed
to be properly resourced and there was
this continuing tension that we weren't
getting the resources that we needed and
by then the you know the incidents that
happened in I think Coots Alberta and at
The Ambassador Bridge and other places
and there appeared that the resources
flowed easier to other locations than
they flowed to Ottawa so it was a point
of contention
were you beginning to suspect at this
time that there was some association
between the delay and and the plan
no and I know because I was listening to
the testimony in the last 48 hours that
City officials were made aware of that
but they did not communicate that to
myself as chair of the board or to the
board
um
so let's go to OPB four
zeros1648 these are the in-camera
minutes for the same meeting on February
11th
um
at the outset it mentions that threats
were received by you and your staff can
you maybe shed some light on what uh
what that was about
I think they were similar threats to
threats that other officials were
receiving they were
extremely aggressive
mostly by telephone call I forwarded the
most egregious ones to the Ottawa Police
Service who followed up they offered me
um
security
I I turned it down I didn't think I
needed to take those resources and I
believed that
some of the most egregious ones which
were you know threats of murder and it
was they were ugly
um
I
I mean I some of them weren't even
coming from inside the country so
um but one of my assistants a young
woman that works for me and was the
person on the front line because she
answered the phone uh was very very
upset by some of the messages that we
received and I ended up giving her some
time off work because she was so
triggered by it
yeah
and do you recall
um these threats
was there any information provided in
them that would associate them with uh
you know your response to the Convoy or
or something like that yeah yeah there
there were a number of them like there
were a number of them
um and and they were definitely linked
to the uh occupation of the city and
comments that I had made publicly that
they took exception to
thank you
um let's go to page uh I guess the
bottom of this page
okay
um so a question was raised regarding
resource supports received from the opp
and RCMP they had 60 OPP officers and 40
RCMP at that time and had since Monday
that was the total additional officers
received or provided
um
was this aligning with the number of
officers that had been committed by The
Province and and the federal government
it's a tough question because what they
were talking about and
um
publicly was
you know that they would send more than
this
um
but the commitments that were being made
at the place to police level I I
couldn't answer that
and is do I understand this correctly
that there had effectively been no
change in the number of resources
between February 7th when you made your
request and Friday February 11th I
believe that is the case
again these numbers reported were
reported to you via Chief slowly you
weren't seeing these numbers directly
right as I said almost all the
information the board was receiving was
through that Soul Channel
do you remember during this meeting a
conversation about uh
a possible request to invoke the uh to
to ask for the use of the National
Defense Act
I know there was starting to be
conversations about what tools would be
available to assist
um I can't recall any details I know I
was actually receiving
um calls from
lawyers
who were also my constituents suggesting
that we needed to
ask for enactment of of special
you know help whatever that would look
like
because this was not being resolved and
the anxiety was just growing and the
public concern was growing and it wasn't
about people's freedom to protest it was
about
the occupation of our city and the
disruption of people's daily lives
um let's go to the top of page four
it was noted that at the time of the
convoys arrival there is no intelligence
that suggested the demonstration would
turn into the occupation that it had
become you remember that yes and who
made that statement
do you recall
hey
I don't know who made that statement
okay
um let's go to
ott301055 is this a good moment to take
the morning break sure so before you
turn to that so we're going to take a 15
minute break and uh so we'll be back at
a quarter to 12. thank you thank you
the commission is in recess for 15
minutes
foreign
order alert
I think we're sure to witness
foreign
[Music]
okay thank you go ahead
okay so um I'm just gonna go back to the
minutes
of the um
the February 11th meeting that we were
looking at
and if we could just uh expand that
um
so I just want to ask again about the um
this last paragraph
the board expressed concern that it did
not seem as though the service was being
provided with the resources required a
question was raised
regarding whether the service would be
in favor of a number of counselors
asking the mayor to request the Attorney
General's support through the National
Defense Act
do you do you remember uh you know
here's whether the service would be in
favor do you remember what that how that
discussion went were they in favor of
that
I
I don't remember I
I I don't think I can comment on it
because I don't think I have a clear
enough recollection
okay
fair to say the request was never made
but yes okay
all right so let's go to ott1055
this is a text you had with uh Blair
dunker who's the CAO of of Ops correct
correct uh this is on February 12th and
let's just
go to the first payout sorry back to the
top
the first text exchange there
down down down
okay uh
so you
you say
uh how many RCMP officers have been
sworn in since the start of the
demonstration are any pending if we
scroll down
layer responds 4 21 RCMP officers are on
the list provided to Ops of those 306
are sworn in there is no delay in
uh swearing in RCMP asks for two
swearing-in at times when shifts change
9 A.M and 9 pm from the time we get the
name from the RCMP to getting it
approved by the ministry and sworn in
it's within a day or less we are very
flexible it's important to note that
this does not mean the officers sworn in
are deployed and it doesn't mean the
ones on the list that are not yet sworn
in have arrived
so do you know who is deciding whether
or not to deploy an RCMP officer that
had been sworn in
was it Ops or the rcnp do you know I
believe it would be Ops when they become
come under our Command it would be Ops
that would make those deployment
decisions
and when she say it doesn't mean the
ones on the list that are not yet sworn
in have arrived so am I is my understand
correct that they would first have to
arrive in Ottawa and then they would be
sworn in by Ms dunker yes okay
and you asked Miss dunker to provide you
with a table of daily deployments uh
correct yes
so let's look at OPB four zeros1014
this is a copy you can confirm for me
but I believe this is a copy of the
table you were provided by Miss dunker
so if we can try to fit the table on the
there we go thank you
um and so you've seen this table yes I
believe it was provided to you the next
day on the 13th yep
um can you describe what it shows
large scale it shows the number of
deployments
Billy by shift
and they it it shows the officers from H
municipality Durham London PL York that
were here the numbers from Opp that were
here
RCMP and then other Municipal services
and and do you know whether and maybe we
just scroll up a bit so we can see the
the title of the chart at do you know is
this showing officers that were
Deployable or officers that had
actually been deployed
I believe these are officers that have
been deployed okay
and what was your impression the first
time you you looked at this table
don't know if I
was terribly impressed one way or the
other with it I mean it was just a it's
a chard it's information it's a it's
showing that we have a pretty pretty
specific understanding of who's here on
shifts and where they're from
okay
um
would you um so if we can
if I look on the big screen it's okay
um
so would you agree that the the there
seems to be
some increase uh rather significant
increase in the RCMP and OPP numbers on
the very last day on the 12th yes
and and do you know why that was Well I
this was getting closer to the end and
the The Log Jam seemed to be breaking
and at the time my understanding is
because and
um
the command center had integrated RCMP
and OPP into the command and once they
were integrated in the command center
and started having more of a senior role
in terms of decision making they were
freeing up more resources
and do you know
if this trend continued over the rest of
your term and it's 13 14 15 16. it's the
short term
do you know how many resources were
available to Ops when you were removed
on the 16th um I
met
climax occurred that the number of
resources deployed were very similar to
the number that Chief slowly had weeks
before told us that he needed okay
uh let's go to Ops three zeros one one
six one zero
we can go down
uh okay so it's the second email there
an email from Jessica Bradley again from
your office to John steinbach's who is
John
he's a communications director for
Ottawa Police okay
and uh so you say I recognize that this
was not part of the initial request for
the in-camera briefing but the chair and
the board have been asking Chief slowdie
to provide an overview of the plan to
end this occupation specifically the
chair would like to know the methodology
behind the request for 1800 additional
resources and how they will be deployed
we recognize that some information with
respect to the plan will be confidential
and cannot be shared however as an
oversight body the board should be
apprised of the general priorities and
objectives of the plan the chair would
like to be able to put out a statement
similar to the one Toronto put out at
last weekend
and then if we go down you say I've
highlighted the relevant sections
uh sorry let's go back up
okay so the Third
third uh paragraph under the the Bold
heading there board members were briefed
on the details of the operational plan
including the priorities and objectives
of the operation and had opportunities
to ask questions of the chief and obtain
further information so you remember
making this request on February 14th yes
okay
um
and
was your and and so why did you make
this request I was a little frustrated
that Toronto City Council seemed to get
more our Toronto police board seem to
get more information from their senior
command than we got from ours and we
have been asking and asking and so I
just got to the point where I want the
whole thing laid out so so when you read
this what led you to conclude that they
were getting more than you had well
um the the line that you just read to us
the board members were briefed on the
details of the operational plan
including the priorities and objectives
for the operation and Hunt opportunities
that as the chief to and obtain more
information I mean I never felt that we
were briefed on all of the details of
the operational plan I mean even there
was there was one day I was sort of
melding together in my mind but there
was one day when there was an intention
to go in with an operation to take out
the installation at the corner of Rideau
and Sussex and
um the chief had not given me the
details of the plan but he told me that
there was a significant operation to
occur that evening
and it didn't happen and so I just
at that point I just felt like we
weren't getting the whole story we
weren't getting enough information I
I just felt the board as the oversight
body needed to understand more about the
operation so I I I was pushing harder I
was but from the beginning to where we
are now two and a half weeks in or
whatever it is and maybe my patience is
running a little thin but I wanted more
information about what was happening
what we needed to do and how this was
going to end
so the Toronto Police Services Board has
actually provided us with an
Institutional report uh and that's TPB
dot i r dot 701
I I won't take you to specific passages
um but they relay that in applying the
lessons from Morden
um
they had integrated a board
representative uh into uh there was one
sitting at the executive management
table for the event one was invited to
attend the services executive Command
Center
and uh and that this allowed on ongoing
board access to operational briefings
and updates in real time
um
was this was anything similar offered uh
to the Ottawa board no
and do you know
why that was felt not to be possible
no I didn't know it was possible I mean
I hadn't been around that long I you
know I was in my first term as chair of
the board and so I think this was a bit
of a learning curve for me too
so
you you were requesting a a greater
um
more insight into what the plan was and
what the operational plan was
um and you were not receiving it
correct is is I'm getting little
Snippets we weren't getting a whole plan
yeah yeah did the board how did the
board push back
you know presumably when it was not
getting what it was asking how how does
the board push back
well I think you can sort of see it in
the flow of information and in the in in
just the information you've put up here
this morning that it was getting like
okay now I wanna I I want the number I
want the resource requirement I want the
plan I want it I want to see the details
and it was like that it was I think it
was growing as we went along that we're
realizing we weren't getting information
and I have to say through this
commission I've realized there was a lot
more information the board was not privy
to that the city was it was very
frustrating
and and did you ever did the board ever
formally direct Chief slowly at to to
produce an additional information my
understanding is under the police
services act there is authority to
direct the chief uh was any kind of
formal Direction ever issued in that
respect
I would have to look back
we did I know we certainly were asking
for it were we directing it through
motion I'm not
sure
was it
um did you understand that that would be
a POS that would be an option
I mean we were working together the I
mean this was uh this was a tough
situation it wasn't to you know it it
wasn't that we wanted to
um create any more uh angst for the
chief then he was already under we're
just
trying to assist him and bringing about
an end to this and be as useful as
possible and ensure that as the
oversight body we were doing our job so
it wasn't it wasn't
it wasn't a relationship that I would
describe as we we're going to tell you
what to do because you're not doing it
and it was more conversational it was
like we're all working together here and
and we need to get this done
um in your witness statement you say
that when you requested to see the plan
you would receive wiggle words can you
explain what you mean by that
I think just what I've been describing
here this morning that we would see
parts of a plan we'd hear little bits
about
um you know there's going to be some
form of an operation but
um you know I recall at one point she's
slowly telling me that he couldn't share
the details because you know it
obviously the element of surprise is
important in these operations and if you
start sharing the details
this city has a way of that not becoming
a secret for very long so I mean and one
level it kind of accepted that because I
I know that to be true but on the other
hand I just uh felt that we needed more
can we go to OPB four zeros one six four
six
so these are text messages between
yourself and Amanda
gal brace I'm not sure that's that uh
February 12th
if we can just go down to February 12th
at 10 59 A.M
um so who is uh who is Miss Galbraith
she's a principal at Navigator which is
a crisis Communications firm that the
Ottawa Police Service uses to assist in
Communications in lieu of having a
Communications Department a full-blown
Communications Department at Ops and so
she was advising you on communication
matters she was advising the service but
um I was also speaking to her okay and
and so here February 12th at 10 59
um these are texts again between
yourself and Miss Galbraith
you say I wish I thought there was a
plan
yeah I hear you ignorance on operational
matters while appropriate only provides
so much comfort and you respond not much
at all juanchianello from CBC sent me a
message last night and asked if I think
there is a plan I didn't respond
I think we've we've already talked about
you not being satisfied with the
disclosure of the plan to this point had
you concluded by this date that there
was a possibility that there wasn't yet
a plan on how to bring an end to the
occupation I was worried that there I
mean I know they're working on a plan I
know there were pieces of apply and I
knew there have been some operations but
I was just increasingly becoming
concerned that there wasn't a Soup To
Nuts plan to bring this thing to a
peaceful
expeditious end
foreign
so from what I heard from you earlier
um it sounds like the reason that the
board didn't direct the chief more
formally to provide that information is
um
is because you wanted to maintain a
Cooperative relationship would that be
accurate the the chief was under intense
stress
throughout this I was I was just doing
Wellness checks with them I was just
phoning to say are you okay I mean he
had the weight of the city on his
shoulders he was getting
um it from every corner from the public
from Council from the board from
internal sources inside police that were
I mean I think some of them using it to
to get to shave slowly I mean there was
a lot going on and I was concerned for
chief slowly he was our coach if you
will and and we had a crisis and we
needed to see this through and
um I would it was not my goal to add to
his anxiety level it was my goal to
support him and to support the service
and to assist them to get the resources
they need to get this job done
do you know
um during the relevant period did the
board issue any formal directions to
Chief slowly
um
I I would have to check through the
minutes I I just can't recall offhand
what the Motions that we did were
and did the board adopt any policies
during that time
pertaining to the freedom Convoy yes
not that I specifically recall
so
I just want to get your understanding
here
um of kind of the the tools available to
you and the exercise of that over fun
oversight function if you were to have
directed
um the chief to provide additional
reasons information and that was not
done
were there any tools available to you
to enforce that request to your to the
best of your knowledge
well we are the employer for the Ottawa
Play service and we are Dave slowly's
employee employer so to the extent that
we have an employee employer
relationship there are tools available
some of them are hammers I mean one is
suspension I mean I don't think
that's a big hammer in the middle of a
of a crisis
um so you know the tools that are
available in my mind it it wasn't about
that it would
I wasn't focused on that so much as I
was focused on working together I my
view we needed to be in the same boat we
needed to be rowing in the same
direction we didn't need to be in
fighting or fighting amongst ourselves
or you know calling each other out we
needed to be working collaboratively
every step of the way at all levels to
to bring this this thing to a peaceful
end and I still believe that to this day
I mean one of the issues I think at play
here is that
um it was new we didn't it wasn't like
the G20 we didn't have a lot of
preparation time to really get our ducks
in a row but we didn't work as smoothly
together it wasn't a well-oiled machine
and there were a lot of people in my
estimation working at Cross purposes
here and everybody
you know with the best of intentions
let's assume
but not necessarily
um working at their very best and when
people aren't working together
I don't think you get the best result
and I think that's what we saw
were you aware that Ops had arranged for
an in-camera briefing by the OPP on
February 15th that would include a
briefing on some of the intelligence
that had been provided to it I believe I
was aware of that okay had you requested
that kind of a briefing how did that
come about yeah and I
so hard to remember the details of you
know who asked for what when but I I
can't tell you how it came about but I
believe I was aware of it
do you know why that kind of brief
briefing was not provided earlier
with the opp
um
I know I don't have a clear
a collection of when they were fully
embedded
and taking more of a they took more of a
leadership role coming near the end
which I think was very helpful
but I think it was at that point when
they started providing this kind of
information
did did and I understand that that
briefing was canceled was was put off
because of Chief slowly's resignation
that same way correct yeah yeah and yes
that's right did you ever have any
briefings with OPP or RCMP well it was
scheduled I think for the next day or
day after but then I was gone so I never
saw it a lot changed in those few days
yeah
um
let's go to ont four zeros116
so this is a PowerPoint that the Ops be
prepared for the February 15th meeting
that's my understanding have you ever
seen this document
um
saw in the documents that were provided
in the run-up to to this hearing yes
previously had you seen it
I don't
think so okay
okay is it possible that it was also
part of that kind of canceled briefing
on the 15th yes
okay
um we can take that down thank you
could you please tell us how Chief
slowly's resignation on the 15th came
about
yeah
um
so as I was describing to you a little
while ago
um you know there was increasing anxiety
in this community at all levels and a
lot of the
um
concern was aimed at Chief slowly
and
um
you know I told you I was doing Wellness
checks with them I was you know checking
make sure he was okay because he's a
human being and he's under intense
stress and I felt that that was
important to do and I'd had a
conversation with him the week previous
and I had made some comment along the
lines of Chief slowly you know there's a
lot of people in the city that
want your head and
um he he sort of surprised me with the
reply that he made his reply wise well
cut me a Chuck and I'll be out of here
and I didn't expect that and I didn't
know if it was
kind of just said in passing if it was
flip it was just
um you know frustration In the Heat of
the Moment I didn't know the I didn't
really understand the context
necessarily of that comment
but in the in the days after that and
then in the next week you saw there was
a lot going on
and
um one of the things that was going on
and you heard it in some of the
testimony from the witnesses that came
before me is that members of council
were
um
considering
um a motion to ask to slowly for his
resignation in a public forum
I was very opposed to that that one not
City council's job
and I know they were under intense
pressure too and they wanted to look
like they were doing something but they
were not members of the Police Services
Board Chief slowly was not their
employee and it was not their job it was
also in my mind constructive dismissal
to ask a public official like that in
the heat of a crisis for his resignation
is tent Mountain my mind to constructive
dismissal and
you know if if I can take a moment to
explain the sort of culture that exists
at City Hall the mayor has a group of
counselors that are very supportive of
his agenda and generally speaking will
deliver to him any vote on any issue at
any time and so
um and that's a reality and I know that
no motion of that magnitude would ever
see its way onto the floor of council
without the mask effect
and so when I got wind that this was
being contemplated I started asking the
mayor's staff if this motion was coming
because I was very concerned about it I
didn't share it with Chief slowly I
thought he had enough stress frankly and
if it was never going to see the light
of day on the council floor I wasn't
going to tell him about it because he
didn't need that stress but if it was
going to see the light of day on the
council floor then I felt that I needed
to let him know so there was that
happening
and then there was what I would describe
as some sort of insurrection from within
that was happening and there
there was always some tension in the
ranks with Chief slowly right from the
beginning the honeymoon for chief slowly
in this town was short-lived and there
was always
um
I never I don't think he ever felt I
shouldn't speak for him he can speak for
himself but I don't think he ever really
felt entirely supported by his senior
command or by the rank and file
inside police and so in the midst of a
big crisis like this it all comes to a
head that's what happens and crisis sort
of beget crisis and he
I
I didn't I don't think he had enough
support from within and then I was
contacted by
I believe his name's Stephen Hoff uh
producer at CBC
and he told me that there was a story
coming out
um about Chief slowly and his behavior
inside police and he offered to share
with me the highlights of that story and
they were extremely damning
um and they were also disturbing in that
I mean we
at Ottawa Police and the board is the
employer of Ottawa Police and
um you know we have spent a lot of time
on the issues around workplace sexual
harassment and violence and
um you know we I really take seriously
um the notion of having a positive
working environment and so
um this kind of these kinds of serious
accusations against our chief I mean if
I describe them to you broad Strokes
it's like he's yelling at people and
he's sort of tyrannical dictator and it
was that was I might be overstating it
slightly but not too much I mean it was
that kind of
um accusations that clearly came from
within the service
and chief slowly had been intimating to
me
that there was infighting occurring
inside Ottawa Police I didn't ask him
for a lot of detail on that nor did he
share a lot of detail he did tell me
that deputy chief Trish Ferguson had
gotten caught and caught up with some of
the wrong elements in that and he had
had to send her home for a number of
days which was in the middle of a crisis
so obviously extremely worrisome
he had told me that the Incident
Commander had changed
um
more than once
during this crisis and so there was
obviously this other problem that we had
that inside Ottawa Police probably not
well known to the poet but inside Ottawa
Police there's a bit of an Insurrection
going on and there seems to be
there seems to be an intent to use this
crisis to undermine the chief further
that was my assessment of what I saw in
that situation and that story they gave
me a heads up CBC gave me a heads up
that they were going to be breaking that
story within hours
I believe that was the evening of the
14th so I called Chief slowly about 9 30
at night
I asked him I I talked to him a little
bit about the CBC story I asked him if
he was aware of it which he was
and I S I just said to him I said shave
slowly last week when I spoke to you you
said
if we cut you a check that you would be
out of here and I just wanted to ask you
if you meant that
or
or not or if you wanted to stay and
chief slowly said to me that
um you know that he's the chief of
police he's put his heart and soul into
this operation he's worked very hard
we're getting close to bringing this
thing to an end he had every intention
of seeing it through till the end
um and that he wasn't going anywhere and
I said okay fine shape I I just wanted
to check with you because you know it's
gonna it's gonna be a little bit of a
rough ride
and and I and I just left him with
saying if you sleep on it and change
your mind let me know and the next
morning I think it was about 8 30 in the
morning he called me and he said I want
to leave
thank you
um
did anyone reach out to you ahead of his
resignation to to suggest that you
should put pressure on him to resign or
anything like that
um
no I mean I heard all the talk about you
know my Council colleagues wanting to
push them out and uh interfere in in all
of that but no not directly
did the I I understand and I from your
witness statement that the board had
some conversations about his leadership
um did it consider whether it had the
authority to uh to remove him
yes because in light of the CBC Story
the board felt that we needed to
understand
our options and
um expectations that would be upon us
and what would be the right thing for
the board to do
and
um
yeah so yes
and you concluded that you did not have
that authority of support
we concluded we did not have the
authority to remove the chief
we did conclude that we have the
authority to suspend the chief
and is it fair to say that the concerns
that the board discussed about his
leadership were uh work related to to
what you previously have talked about in
terms of infighting and and those kind
of issues
yes and yeah the the yes it was related
to the allegations that CBC were going
to run with
thank you
did your personal interactions with
Chief slowly give rise to any concerns
about his leadership
my personal interactions or my
interactions as the chair of the board
as the chair of the board yes sorry
um
there were some occasions there there
had been two
um
two issues raised about Chief slowly's
performance that the board had referred
to the ocpc for follow-up neither one of
those I believe have been dealt with one
was an anonymous complaint and one was a
complaint from
an inspector
at Ottawa Police and I guess what I
meant by my question is in your your own
interactions with him in your role did
did you have any you know did anything
arise from those Communications that
gave you concerns
I
slowly it's a very passionate person
Chief slowly was under intense pressure
and I saw the
um emotion
and him and I know that he could get
very excited and when I spoke to him
about
um you know some of the things that were
outlined in that Ottawa and the CBC
um story he didn't deny that you know he
had raised his voice and and perhaps
acted in a manner that he would prefer
he had not acted in
but
I mean I think he also you know his
defense was it was very stressful at all
levels
and and coming back to the he planned to
end the the the protests in Ottawa did
the board ever lose faith in his ability
to to accomplish that task
Ford never stated that they had lost
faith in Chief slowly I do not believe
the board had lost faith in Chief slowly
as the chair of the board I publicly
I publicly stated my support for him
I did it willingly I did support the
chief I did not agree with my Council
colleagues
interfering I understood that there were
a lot of questions that were being
raised and I believed that there would
be time after this incident had ended
for postmortem where we could
you know we could consider all of what
had happened and and you know
hopefully learned some lessons from it
make some determinations if any changes
had to be made but in the midst of this
crisis in my opinion it was not the time
to be questioning the actions of our
chief
turning to the the February 15th meeting
once you know the announcement was made
that he had resigned
um but then there was a briefing from
Ops
um
would you agree that during that meeting
it
was clear to the board that the Ops
the wheels were in motion to now bring
this to an end can you maybe describe
that um
things were improving I could not tell
you that I understood how
um a minute the end was
do you know what led to this change in
tone
you know I've contemplated that so many
times since this
um I I really feel that
um integrating the opp and the RCMP into
the command center and giving them more
of a role in developing a plan was
important because I don't think Ops
really had
um they
skill set inside
Ops to really
um build a plan like that I just don't
think they have the experience so I
think having
those senior police agencies integrated
into the center had helped a lot in
developing a plan and you started seeing
in the stuff you're showing me you start
seeing more of the development of a plan
as as they integrated and as they
integrated they started sending more
resources and it was always that we were
never going to end this thing without a
clear plan and without the resources
that Chief slowly had had
said early on that he needed
turning to the 16th and I don't have
much time left and so I'll only briefly
touch on the events on this on the 16th
um let's go to
Ott
8842
this is the draft letter that I
discussed with Mr akh pain the other day
and that he he drafted on behalf of the
mayor to explain their perspective on
what occurred on on February 16th and
specifically your decision to sign a
contract with uh Mr to region to begin
um to replace former Chief slowly
so if we go under the top of page two is
the section that I'm most interested in
um
just a little higher sorry
just yeah the overlap between the two
pages okay so it says here uh no votes
were taken and no Authority was
delegated that would allow the chair to
finalize an arrangement board members
believe that they had mandated the chair
to undertake a search for an external
Chief of Police
board members insist on the fact that
the board chair did not seek delegated
authority to execute a contract for a
new chief of police and Ms draft Bank
told me the other day that this
information was provided to him by some
of your fellow board members I'm just
interested in in your response to this
information
well it is absolutely 100 percent false
Mr arpeg did not ask me about this
there are in-camera board minutes
available that refute this it was the
authority was delegated unanimously
delegated
um
and Mr R Pang uh discussing
this issue with board members frankly
was putting them in a conflict of the
code of conduct because this was
in-camera information not to be shared
so
it's wrong
he should not have been asking them
about this in-camera meeting
and I mean if a member of the board and
I don't I wish perhaps you had asked who
but if a member of the board did did
provide that information I would suggest
to you that it was probably a board
member that does not have a lot of
governance governance experience and
perhaps did not understand delegated
authority
but it was a unanimous vote of the board
um
Mr actpe and his testimony the other day
in the mayor's witness statement say
that you told the mayor on the morning
of February 16th that you wouldn't sign
the contract uh with uh with the new
Chief without his approval and that you
then did it anyways later that day and
that that's when he lost faith in you
um did you tell the mayor that morning
that you would not sign the contract
without his approval no
what did you tell the mayor
had a conversation with the mayor
I told him that the board had
um come to a decision to hire a new
Chief Matt region and that I would be
signing a contract that afternoon
the mayor expressed his concern
um
I think from a place of not fully
understanding all of the internal
issues that the board was aware of but
nonetheless he is the mayor of the city
and I provided that information in
advance of the announcement to him in
out of respect for the office of the
mayor of the city
um
and I told I I said to the mayor
if you are telling me not to sign that
contract
then I will go back to the board but the
board decision had been made Let's be
clear the board had that that was done
um and I said if you are telling me
not to sign the contract I will go back
to the board but the mayor stopped short
of giving me that direction
so we proceeded
in the intervening time I mean
the mayor was on the telephone to my
colleagues who in turn were letting me
know that he was
um
um asking them to unseat me as the chair
of the board and by the way I'm you also
heard some testimony in the last couple
of days that uh when I was asking about
the council
um looking to construct a constructively
dismiss Chief slowly they were also
looking to unseat me as chair of the
board and I was aware of that asked them
about it and they said they didn't know
but nothing comes to the floor of
counsel without the mayor's knowledge
and consent so
um it was pretty clear to me that that
was the event that was unfolding as soon
as I left that room the phone call
started to
set up the votes to to unseed me and a
member of the media I recognize it's
hearsay but it's a member of the media
that I hold in high regard
that told me that
um
it was the mayor's office that leaked
the information about the hiring of Matt
trigian and
the the problem with the leaking of that
information was that it created in my
estimation of false narrative about the
hiring of a new Chief I mean they're
suggesting to the public that we had
abandoned our own process we didn't go
through you know the normal process and
this was this was a short-term hiring
designed to shore up the senior command
we were flying with One Wing and our
senior command senior command normally
has two deputies achieved and a CEO we'd
hired a brand new CEO we had one of our
deputies was suspended from the service
our chief had just resigned we were Bare
Bones senior command in the middle of
our biggest crisis ever and so there
were a number of considerations that the
board had made in coming to the
conclusion that it was in the best
interest of the place service and our
citizens to go go outside one was to
shore up the senior command to give the
resources frankly one was to protect
deputy chief Bell because in my
estimation at the time anybody that was
going to assume that role if it didn't
if if it didn't come to a positive
conclusion quickly was probably going to
um
you know take some of the criticism for
it it might and and I would have
expected that he would you know
probability be a prime candidate to be
our next chief and I didn't want to
damage Steve Bell through this process
and frankly
we were looking for
more depth of experience in these types
of issues than we had internal to Ops at
the time and it was basically those
three reasons that said okay we need to
Sharp our senior command we need to get
more help from the right people and we
need to protect deputy chief Bell and it
was for that reason that we thought
hiring someone on an interim basis from
outside the service made sense and with
all due respect
to the mayor I do believe that the board
and the chair of the board were in a
better position to make that calculation
than was he thank you
um
my understanding is that uh
your assistant made an audio recording
of this conversation with the mayor she
did
and
um
that recording was disclosed to
commission Council this morning it was
yes
um thank you
um
I have a concern
um we received a copy of that uh audio
recording uh 10 minutes or 13 minutes I
believe before the hearing commenced
um I was surprised that it had not been
disclosed previously the Ottawa Police
board disclosed a number of other
documents it was clearly something that
they believed was relevant it was not
put to Mayor Watson yesterday and I
guess what I'm concerned about is the
Integrity of the process when we get
these kinds of things 10 minutes before
a witness is about to testify I need to
obtain instructions with respect to this
I have not been able to do so and I
guess what I worry about is what else is
not being disclosed or what are we going
to see after Witnesses have already
testified it's unfair to Mayor Watson
and it's unfair to the process quite
frankly to have this kind of
recording come up 10 minutes before the
witness testifies
okay well thank you for the comments
firstly as you I think was noted is you
received it maybe two minutes after the
commission received it so it's it's not
a question of the commission it's a
question of the documentation coming in
I think it's been generally
explained why it was not produced but I
I think that could be explored further I
do share obviously the commission shares
the concern about fairness fairness is
fundamental to this process so if there
are fairness issues I will entertain
them whether that's required or not at
this stage
I don't know then nor do you I gather
because you don't have instructions so
what I'd suggest is is that
we explore a little further why this
wasn't produced so that the record is
clear at a minimum and then once you get
instructions so we'll see where we go
from there
um yes um that's fine um I think I'm the
first person to cross-examine so I'd
like to get those instructions before
and I just want to make clear I wasn't
suggesting that the commission hadn't
disclosed it I appreciate that they only
just received it as well my concern was
I think you're concerned with clear I
understand it I was simply putting for
the record that and and if the reality
is and I think it was clearly put in my
original statement is that you know we
are pressed for time so are all the
parties but first let's start where the
why this was late disclosure I think
that's important to be on the record and
maybe that can be explored briefly and
if it's any comfort you're not the first
on the list to cross-examine so you'll
you'll have the opportunity to get more
time on that and uh but be assured the
commission is concerned to the degree
that we want to be fair
uh and
not knowing what's in the recording me
either uh I'm not in any position to say
much more
go ahead thank you Mr commissioner I
think the commissioner framed the
question can you tell us uh why the
disclosure occurred this morning sure so
when when I provided documentation to
the commission I I might be a
technological [ __ ] I don't know a lot
about getting all of this stuff off my
telephone it's effectively or off my
devices so I handed over my devices to
the city to take whatever they wanted
from any of this and then yesterday when
I was listening to the mayor's testimony
on this point because
in my estimation it was quite inaccurate
um I sent a message to my former
assistant who is now on a leave of
absence from my office but I said did we
did they get that document
and she said no because it was on my
phone not your phone and
um so I had mayor Watson is aware of the
existence of of this recording because I
had shared it with the city's Integrity
commissioner so I sent a message to the
city's Integrity commissioner yesterday
and asked if that recording if was still
in her possession and it was and she
sent it to me so I disclosed it this
morning
um to to you thank you
okay so I think that that's helpful uh I
assume to uh for your uh getting
instructions uh in terms of the process
and uh the fairness issue uh and we can
deal with it after lunch if there are
for if there's follow-up on that
Mr commissioner would it be appropriate
for me just to State for the record the
document ID for yeah go ahead
um so it's p-o-e and I don't need anyone
to bring this up p-o-e dot o p b
seven zeros one
okay I have two short questions before I
wrap up and I'm gonna have to make it
quick yes they'll be very quick
um you were the chair of the opsb for
one day after chief slowly's resignation
at did you notice any change in that
short time sorry I'm sorry another
objection no my my only concern is
um now that we have assigned it a number
my understanding was that it would then
be an exhibit at the hearing and I would
ask that if that if my understanding of
the rule is correct then I would ask
that we'd defer making it an exhibit at
this time at least so that we can get
instructions and speak to that issue
Mr commissioner Eric brousseau
commission Council that that's fine Mr
majakovsky's correct typically uh when
we refer to a document ID it is made an
exhibit those are the rules we've set up
but in the circumstances where
um there may be objections and uh we
haven't you haven't ruled on the sort of
admissibility
um I think uh my colleague was just
reading it out for the benefit of
of Council in the room and it won't be
marked an exhibit until we've dealt with
its admissibility after lunch
thank you okay right in that one day did
you notice any changes
yes
um we saw a lot more detail around the
plan
um and
did the board ever consider making a
request
um I understand under section nine five
of the police services act there can be
a request by the board
for the opp to to provide assistance did
the board ever consider making such a
request
I don't recall okay
those are all my questions thank you Mr
commissioner okay so we have a little
bit more time uh the first to
cross-examine I think is uh Mr uh the
council for the former Chief Mr slowly
good afternoon good afternoon councilor
Deans and commissioner I'm Rebecca Jones
and I am part of the council team for
Chief Peter slowly
um
I I will not be able to complete my
examination of you counselor Deans uh
before the lunch break but why don't we
get started
um and then we can come back uh
after the break
um so I'm going to start with the hiring
of Chief Slowly by the board uh Council
Dean's after you were appointed to the
board in January 2019 part of your
important work was to hire the new Chief
correct okay and chief slowly was
recruited and asked to apply for the
position he was
and he had been a deputy chief in the
Toronto police service for many years
correct and he was known as a National
Police leader at the time he was okay
and one of the one of the areas he was
particularly known for was his
Progressive community-based approach to
policing right right
and that is exactly what the Police
Services Board was looking for right
that's correct
at the time that she fully was hired
the Ottawa Police Service was facing a
lot of challenges
yes
and they were facing challenges both in
their relationship with the community
and in particular
racialized members of the community
okay
and the Police Services Board was also
facing challenges internally within
within the Police Service
yes
and there had been audits done of these
issues within the Police Service correct
correct and there was very low morale
yes and there was very low morale among
racialized members of the Police Service
in particular yes
and
when Chief slowly came in to the city
he was given a change mandate right it
was yes
and not everyone was happy about that
and you've and you've talked about that
right right okay
and the Police Association wasn't happy
about that
no
you agree with me I do okay she slowly
was not their preferred candidate
well
I don't think so but I had the
impression that the Police Association
would have liked to choose their own
candidate I don't think they were
pleased with who our second choice would
have been either
um from Congress from messages that were
sent my way I actually
I don't know if initially how much
information or knowledge they had of
Chief slowly but I can tell you that the
honeymoon was short-lived right
and
part of the reason the honeymoon was
short-lived was because she slowly
published an op-ed after a black
motorist was stopped by the Ottawa
Police Service correct
don't recall the details of that but
I'll take away your word you won't
disagree with me that the Police
Association the head of the Police
Association said it was a failure of
leadership or he that he had failed the
leadership test in raising this issue
publicly
okay
so that was the circumstance faced by
the chief before the Convoy arrived is
that fair yes okay and you've talked
about Chief slowly and his Deputy Chiefs
briefing the board before the Convoy
arrived on January 26th right right
and you made a statement at that board
meeting about the importance of the
right to protest right yes and it was
important to do that
because Ottawa is the capital region
right
right and I happen to believe in the
right to protest I've participated in
some of those protests right
um and the citizens of Ottawa are very
respectful of the right to protest
okay
and so
you talked about the priorities for this
protest that you had and that the police
service had right and the priorities
were shared correct correct okay and
those priorities were to provide a space
for protest and to protect the right to
protest yes but to ensure that this
protest happened without any loss of
life or Serious injury correct and that
of course is what happened right it is
okay
so
you also gave evidence about the
information that you had available to
you from Chief slowly and we've heard a
lot about Chief slowly this morning yeah
haven't we we have and she slowly wasn't
operating on his own was he
what to me he had a command team
right
he did okay and acting Chief Ferguson
was in charge of operations you knew
that yes okay and uh deputy chief acting
deputy chief Ferguson I should have said
and uh deputy chief Bell was in charge
of intelligence yes okay and this is a
team effort of course but led by the
chief right
now
you talked about the information that
you were provided
um and commission Council showed you
um a snippet of a situational report do
you remember that and that situational
report referred to the fact that certain
people were saying they weren't leaving
until whatever demand was met right
right okay
and your expectation though for your
Police Service for chief slowly for the
head of the intelligence effort deputy
chief Bell would be that they would take
all of the intelligence into account
correct yes okay and you don't have
access to all of the intelligence you
rely on them for that I didn't have
access to any of the intelligence let me
ask you about that because a lot has
been made about that today you
understand counselor Deans in your role
as uh the the chair of the board that
you are not provided with intelligence
reports yes okay you hadn't been
provided with intelligence reports in
the past either correct correct and the
reason for that is because intelligence
reports are highly confidential right
and if we actually look at the Hendon
reports which we can do now or after
lunch we'll see that on each page of the
Hendon reports which came from the opp
it specifically states that they are not
to be shared
okay is that fair makes sense okay it
makes sense so
when we're talking about what
intelligence reports and you didn't see
the intelligence report you said you
relied on Chief slowly for telling you
that that was normal right correct but
you also knew based on your own
experience
that intelligence reports are not given
to the board right right okay
I think I was saying is we've relied on
Chief slowly to provide us that
information the information he could
provide right legally right
operationally right okay
so
if we can put up
um a document now please it's OPP
10 24.
I just referred to project tendon
reports and this is an example of one
counselor Deans and if you scroll down
to the bottom of the page
you'll see the reference to the third
party Rule and that's a that's a rule
that when one intelligence agency shares
information with another that agency
isn't it they're not to share it outside
of the police service right right okay
and if we can go to page four please
here we see actually if you scroll down
a little bit more here we go at the the
last paragraph
it says although the stated intent of
some Convoy participants is to remain at
Parliament Hill until the Convoy
rescinds all covid-19 related
restrictions and mandates this goal is
likely to prove unrealistic in the long
term right
until the government rescinds all
coveted restrictions not the Convoy but
the government until the government
rescinds all covered restrictions
um and then but says you know even a
small number remaining would be
disruptive right right and this is
actually the information that you
obtained from the Ottawa Police Service
that the expectation was that people
would leave but there could be some
people that hung on right
that was much more the information that
we were getting right so you agree with
me
um I don't know how much I really
understood the part about there would be
some hangers on but I guess there's
always some Hangers On so
right because we've heard that Ottawa
has 99 or 100 protests a year and it's
very common for there to be some people
that hang on at the end of a protest
right well
we would hope to enjoy what Ottawa has
to offer not to continue the protest
right but sometimes they're there to
continue the protest right
yeah I
suppose okay and so this information
um that the goal to remain in any
numbers was unrealistic this is the kind
of information that you would expect the
Ops to put together with all the rest of
the intelligence information to share
their assessment with the board correct
yes okay
we can take that uh down now and
um Mr commissioner I don't know the time
but if this is a convenient time for the
lunch break
so we certainly can it's a little early
but uh if it's a good time for you we'll
take the lunch break and come back at
two o'clock
the commission is in recess for one hour
foreign
thank you
order a lot
the commission is we can win like a
missile Trump
foreign
now counselor Dean's to uh planning and
we heard a lot of evidence this morning
about the plan
so you testified that there is always
some tension between the police and the
Police Services Board about the sharing
of operational planning details right
right
um and
we spoke before the break about the
sensitivity of intelligence information
and I suggest to you that there are very
similar sensitivities involved in
Sharing operational information
yep
the information of police operations is
considered highly confidential for
safety reasons right
including the the safety of officers
right and as chief of police the safety
of officers would be of the utmost
importance right of course
and
like in the case of intelligence reports
it was not the practice of the board to
demand operational planning information
prior to the Convoy right
um
I don't think we demanded operational
planning information I think we you know
inquired about
operational issues in accordance with
what we understood
that limit to the
under the art fair so prior to the
Convoy you wanted some high-level
operational information but you weren't
asking for tactical plans for example no
you agree with me on that I do okay
um but here with the Convoy everyone was
under a tremendous amount of pressure
a lot okay
okay and you were under a tremendous
amount of pressure yes as was Chief
slowly yes
um and you and the board started wanting
more information about the operational
plans right that's fair yeah
and you'll agree with me that it was a
highly volatile situation during the
freedom Convoy I will
and there were threats as you testified
this morning to members of the board
right there were threats to Chiefs
slowly there were threats to the mayor
right
yes yes yes
and you also testified this morning
about leaks of sensitive information
from the board right
yes yes and that there had been leaks of
information from the board in the past
is that fair
it is fair okay and
commission Council also showed you an
email from one board member Mr swida
asking for more information about the
planning correct
and I'm sorry if you can just say yes
yes okay thank you I know it that's fine
um and Mr swida a few weeks later
stepped down from the board is that
right
yes okay and
and he stepped down from the board
after evidence emerged that he had
attended the freedom Convoy protests on
two occasions right
I don't know if that's why he stepped
down my impression at the time as he
stepped down the same day the other two
provincial appointees stepped down and I
was left with the definite impression
that they got pushed
out okay were you aware of the media
reports at the time that he had attended
the Convoy protests and wouldn't answer
questions about whether or not he had
donated food to the protesters yes
an example of the lack of operational
detail that you felt you were getting
was in relation to the operation at Rito
and Sussex right
an example of it yes yes
and
you told the commissioner that you
were told there was going to be an
operation in advance right yes
and you were told some details of that
operation not a lot but
a very very high level right you were
given high level details of a police
operation right yes okay and that is the
kind of details that the board gets
about police and operations right in
Ottawa that's the kind of detail we were
accustomed to getting okay
okay but you didn't get as you put it
the full plan for the operation right no
or even as much
information as after I had seen that
Toronto report I thought they were
getting
okay well I think this is before the
Toronto report yeah okay okay but no I I
okay Carry On Okay so
did you've been following the evidence
in this commission so far yes okay so I
take it that you've heard the evidence
that the operation at Rito and Sussex
was seen to be a particularly sensitive
operation yes right correct uh there was
reports that there were uh people
involved from Criminal organizations in
Quebec
I heard that evidence right
right and so you you would agree with me
that
with a board with a history of leaks
may be a little bit concerning to share
the full plan of operational details of
going into Rito and Sussex is that fair
no I don't think I would agree with you
on that I
you know as chair of the board any
highly sensitive information that was
being shared with the board I would have
really
you know read the riot act to the board
members about confidentiality and
reminded them of their oath that they
took when they joined that board and the
sensitive nature and the potential for
putting officers In Harm's Way by
linking that information so no I don't I
don't think I can fully accept your
premise okay well maybe maybe you'll
fully accept this okay that for chief
slowly
he would be concerned about his officers
going into an operation like that
absolutely okay
okay
and
you were asked by my friend for the
commission uh whether you were ever
offered by Chief slowly to be have a
member of the board embedded within the
Police Service like we heard about in
Toronto right
and you weren't asked whether you asked
whether you could be embedded or someone
could be embedded uh within the Police
Service I don't believe we asked okay
and in terms of your evidence about the
plan and your concerns about the plan
um just for the benefit of the public
and for the commissioner
I take it that you are not commenting on
the sufficiency or the appropriateness
of the plan that that would go beyond
your expertise correct okay and so what
we can take from you was your concern
solely about the level of detail you and
the board were given about the plans
like to have seen more detail I'd also
like to have been able to Greater
satisfy ourselves that there was a plan
well you were assured there was a plan
and you were given details about that
plan I suggest to you daily by Chief
slowly
um what days are we talking about we
were seeing more details of a plan as we
went on but for a lot of those 20 days I
did not feel that I was getting detailed
information about a plan right and and
uh and I hear you about that okay and
and what I'm trying to establish here is
that what you were not satisfied with
was the information you were getting the
level of detail you were getting about
the operational plan correct
foreign
yes and for at least a considerable
amount of the time that there was a full
plan well you you understood as Chief
solite said repeatedly
um in board meetings and Council
meetings that are recorded uh that the
plan was well in hand and was evolving
as information evolved right
yes okay so
I want to talk now a bit about resources
um I I think you gave evidence
um that you first heard about the Ops
requiring more resources around February
1.
yeah okay and just just to to refresh
your memory about that and I can put the
documents up if you'd like you were
actually signing memorandums of
understanding for additional police
officers from before the Convoy arrived
in Ottawa oh yes okay so you knew from
before the Convoy arrived that Chief
slowly was making efforts to secure
additional resources yeah I think that
was sort of standard practice in some
large-scale events that the city hosted
in the past that there was sharing of
some resources at that level exactly and
actually that's exactly what I wanted to
get to
um with you which is that is how
resources are in the ordinary course
obtained right for for big protests or
big events
yes okay they're obtained by Chief
slowly drawing on his police
relationships
yes okay and that's what he was doing
from before the Convoy arrived correct
correct
okay and uh you have no basis I take it
to disagree with me that he was doing
that on a near constant basis during the
Convoy reaching out for additional
resources yeah it amped up as time went
on and it amped up exactly and what was
exceptional here
was not that she slowly was asking for
additional resources although the extent
to which she was asking was exceptional
what was exceptional here was that he
was asking for so much help from the
board in getting those resources right
we saw the February third email where he
wrote to you and said I need your help
getting resources
right and that wasn't usual correct no
it wasn't usual it was unusual and so
that when you get to the February 5th
meeting where you say to him I want to
hear what you need he had already been
asking for help from the board he had
been asking for help but we hadn't it's
like send more resources send more
resources but I didn't I didn't have the
information what that actually looked
like how much the numbers the numbers
the numbers what would it take and he
had made that comment as you will recall
he had made that comment about
um not
being certain that there was a placing
solution so yeah with all of that it's
like yeah we need to understand this
better right and you understood his
comment about there not being a policing
solution or there may not be a policing
solution
to be a call for help I did yes very
much so and the call for help was we
cannot as the local police of
jurisdiction do this on our own
yes okay and you understood it that way
and he also explained it that way we saw
it up on the screen right yes he
explained we need the help from all
levels of government yes and
people you say didn't understand that
comment right when you when you first
made it yes okay and
but you've said publicly and we all know
now that he was right
I believe he was very right he was just
right earlier than a lot of other people
he probably had more information than
everyone else but
um yeah I think the way this all ended
actually did prove that Chief slowly
when he said early on was in fact
correct
now
Chief slowly after getting at the
board's request on February 5th at for a
number more details about resources the
next day he provided uh that number and
you were satisfied and the mayor has
given evidence that he was satisfied
with the level of detail of that request
yes yes okay
and
foreign
asked you know was was it ever suggested
to you that he asked for twice as many
resources as he needed uh what you
weren't asked was to confirm that he was
right about that too wasn't he
what he asked for yes I believe that he
was right about what he asked for okay
now
I'm going to turn to
Chief slowly's resignation um you gave
evidence that a week before his
resignation you called him
as part of a wellness check
well I was in constant touch with Chief
slowly but we were chatting about
you know we had a lot of stuff to talk
about but I also wanted to make sure
that he was okay and that he was aware
of you know what was happening in the
broader community and so we did speak
about that okay and during that that
conversation you expressed to him that a
lot of people wanted his head
I don't know if it's those exact words
but I mean in a broad sense that was he
knew that I knew that there were calls
for his resignation and
um and you know I I probably christly
described it but but I think the
sentiment was clear
okay and and just to be fair to you I'm
going to suggest to you that he didn't
say cut me a check I'm not resigning but
rather I'm not resigning so if you want
me out you're gonna have to buy out my
contract
um
no I mean that might be what happened
the next week in terms of a like closer
to what you're suggesting but the first
week I mean I think it as I said this
morning I wasn't certain of the what he
was trying to convey was it just the
frustration of the moment or like
um is it something you actually had in
his mind I I didn't have a sense of that
I didn't pursue it I had just heard that
comment and it may have been and I said
this this morning it may have just been
off the cuff and he may not have meant
it at all I did I didn't know I didn't
I I didn't pursue it so I didn't know I
followed up on it a week later right and
then so a week later you called him
again and we're right now in the middle
of the crisis right yes
um and you ask him about resigning right
I asked him if what he had said the way
previous was what he was thinking about
and you testified that
as far as you saw he was never supported
by the senior command
there was
there were problems in the senior
command okay and
is it fair to say that that call on the
on that evening of the 14th asking him
about resigning would have felt to him
like a loss of support by his board
it wasn't intended to be that it was
I I don't know how he would interpret it
I was concerned for him as I said this
morning
was concerned for this story that was
going to be coming out from CBC that was
casting him in a particularly dark light
and
um I I didn't know how much he could
withstand and I
you know I I
I wasn't doing it to
suggest in any way that he should leave
and when he said no he was going to see
it through that evening I said that's
fine Chiefs like I didn't want to leave
him with the impression that we were
pushing him out that wasn't the case it
was a conversation
I probably knew more about some Council
motive than he did because I hadn't
shared that with him and
um I you know I just thought it was
going to be
um a tough few days
and
very briefly on the CBC article
um the article you're referring to
refers to confidential sources including
within the Ops about tension raised
voices during the crisis correct correct
and is it fair that
we've seen footage for example of the
February 16th council meeting that there
were a lot of raised voices to go around
in this period oh my goodness yes
everyone had difficult days during this
period yes okay
and
I can see from the commissioner that I'm
out of time but I do have
um Mr commissioner some more uh
questions for this witness I would ask
for leave
um for a few more minutes to continue my
cross-examination uh make it very short
please
if we can pull up uh please
OPB one six four nine
if we could go to page six please
these are the uh minutes in camera
minutes of the Ottawa Police Service
Ford on February 15th
and this was the day of Chase Lily's
resignation correct
if you can scroll oh there we go so in
the first big paragraph we see at the
top a point was raised regarding Mr
slowly having struggled to be accepted
within the organization given that he
was considered an outsider and you've
given evidence about that correct yes
um and then the last sentence of that
paragraph reads in conversation with
chair Deans the week prior deputy chief
Bell had advised that he would not have
done anything differently if he were in
charge right yes and deputy chief Bell
told you that he did okay
okay you've also publicly stated
um that in your view Chief slowly was
the subject of racism yes
and that he was the subject of
scapegoating
yes okay
and that at the end of this there were a
lot of finger pointing and a lot of
blame
right yes and a lot fell at the feet of
the first black police chief in Ottawa
right exactly and you'll agree with me
that it would be very unfair to lay
blame for the events of the freedom
Convoy
on the feet of Chief slowly alone alone
absolutely right there is a lot of blame
to go around a lot of blame to go around
a lot of things that we can learn about
how things could have gone differently
correct oh correct okay
um but as you've confirmed you never
lost confidence in your chief of police
during this entire event I did not
those are my questions thank you
commissioner okay thank you uh next on
the list we have the Ottawa coalition
thank you commissioner and Miss Deans my
name is Paul champ I'm legal counsel
through the Ottawa Coalition of
residents and businesses
just have some questions for you for the
tier testimony this morning
Miss Dean's I just want to ask you first
about
um
the context or the environment with the
Ottawa Police Service immediately
preceding the freedom Convoy this was a
bit of a tough time for the Ottawa
Police would you agree yeah yes there
had been a series of scandals you had a
deputy chief jaswall was had been
suspended due to sexual harassment
allegations there'd been a a termination
of the CEO the chief Administration
officer
uh there were workplace reviews that
were coming out of low morale and
harassment and discriminatory attitudes
and the police uh these were all the
things that were going on just in the in
the in the
previous year is that fair that is fair
and when you referred to this morning
about uh the Auto police was flying with
One Wing to some extent you meant that
there was only one permanent deputy
chief that being deputy chief Bell and
then the other deputy chief position had
had a number of rotating superintendents
is that what you meant that's what I
meant and um we know that acting deputy
chief Ferguson who was in charge of this
operation was one of those
superintendents was just acting deputy
chief at that time correct so so
presumably had a bit less experience
than than others who you know who would
have been in that role otherwise right
now uh turning to the the freedom Convoy
and just before the arrival as a
layperson I think you told us this
morning that you know you were following
the news you were following some social
media and you saw the huge number of
trucks uh that were rumbling across the
country and you saw the millions of
dollars being raised and GoFundMe
um and on that basis you had concerns
that these protesters look like they
were planning to stick around for a
while is that right I was concerned
and uh were you aware that some police
intelligence at that time I think we're
going to hear about that evidence later
today
um were that were that some of these
protesters saying they plan to stay in
Ottawa until their demands were met were
you aware of that
um
I don't think I was aware of that right
but notwithstanding all of this Chief
Sully was uh reassuring you that in
their assessment based on all the other
inputs they had that they believed that
the the freedom Convoy protesters were
going to be moving out by the Monday is
that right yes but did he give you any
indication whether the the Auto police
had a contingency plan in the event that
didn't happen
yeah I I don't believe I was aware of a
contingency plan
and uh
councilor Deans looking at um one of the
documents uh that's referred to in your
your interview summary about some texts
that you're having with the deputy chief
Bell on January the 31st just after the
weekend where you asked him uh how we
can ensure that no more trucks are
allowed into this city we had all these
trucks that were gridlocking downtown
and you want to know that there were no
more trucks allowed in and deputy chief
Bell told you that there no more trucks
could drive into that area now do you
recall getting that assurance
if it's in a text message I I guess I
got it there was a lot of text messages
yeah yeah for sure not with the mayor
but we'll get to that one in a moment
but
um the uh
but there were more trucks coming in uh
after that first weekend correct yes
there were and did you ever get any
answer to that from from either deputy
chief Bell or chief Saliba why more
trucks were being allowed into downtown
Ottawa after that first weekend yeah
there were I mean there were a number of
questions being asked about that because
I mean at one hand
um first they were telling us that there
was a constitutional right there was
nowhere else to put the trucks they were
allowed to come then it was like we're
gonna try and keep them out and then
they're coming in I mean it was just it
was
it was a fluid situation
um just a brief con uh question about
your telephone conversation with uh city
solicitor David White about the
potential for an injunction I've had
some conversations with Council and I
can ask you a question that doesn't get
to the substance of what Mr White was
advising you but I um
Mr White did express to you that they
they did not have a plan to go for an
injunction correct yes and
um now did he say it was because of one
of two reasons one that there was
concerns that the Ottawa Police would be
unable to enforce an injunction or was
he suggesting that they would be
concerned about their reputation if they
were unsuccessful at that they might be
embarrassed if if the court denied their
injunction
well I think it was the latter and
perhaps partially the former too
is that what he expressed to you
yeah
I I don't know if I'm allowed to tell
you but he told me we've been permissive
I think that's the end of the discussion
um did uh Mr White tell you who would
make the decision or who was responsible
for making the decision Mr kennelakis
the city manager that's and Mr kanalakos
he's the see manager later on referred
to Miss Exley the person who did get an
injunction is some 20 year old that's
the same city manager he it is
they only city manager now
um
you testified this morning Council Deans
that you weren't aware that the opp and
the RCMP
um were perhaps delaying uh deployment
of officers or resources because they
had some concerns about the Ops
operational plans you never had heard
about that before is that right no and I
I listened to the testimony and I have
to say I was
angered by it I I really believe that
the oversight body
could have usefully used that
information in the performance of our
duty and I listened to the testimony
from Mr kenolatkers where he said what
was operational there was no need to
give it to
counselor James or the board and I
respectfully disagree with that what
could the board have done with that
information well we certainly could have
questioned we could have asked what is
it about the plan that is insufficient
to gain resources what do they need I
mean
um I think there was a lot we could have
done I think we would our Focus would
have perhaps shifted to that plan and
what we needed to shore up the plan to
get resources rather than just asking
for resources but we didn't have that
information
foreign
had you heard concerns that um that or
that the opp were raising concerns uh
that their officers at times being
misdeployed uh sent one place and then
sent to another and and time was being
wasted then they had concerns about that
I think we're going to hear about that
for a minute yeah no I that information
was not shared with the board
and uh Miss Dean's did you
when we were getting later into the
protest there was all these concerns or
this or that happening
um did you ever uh speak to uh either
the deputy Chiefs about you know what
was happening whether whether they had
concerns about how things were unfolding
or what what the Auto police how the
Ottawa Police were responding I found
deputy chief fell one day I mean I felt
that I had a
good relationship with him and it was a
you know just between him and I
conversation which obviously it's not
now but I intended it to be then
um and I just said to him deputy chief
Bell I just really just wanted to ask
you one question
if you were the chief right now what
would you be doing differently
and his answer was very simple it was
nothing
and so from that you drew that there
there was no concerns at the senior
command with Chief slowly's leadership
per se
that's what I drew from it I just heard
from it that they wouldn't be doing
anything different fair enough
now I want to turn a little bit to your
relationship with mayor Watson
um
if you uh while you're a chair of the
board if you ever wanted to have a
private conversation with mayor Watson
could you just call him
and why was that
um I asked mayor Watson early on in my
tenure as chair of the Police Services
Board if he would share his phone number
with me in order that we could Converse
and I mean in times like this in
particular it was actually during the
protests of the black lives matter and
you probably recall that there was a lot
of tension during that particular
protest and I had gone through
his chief of staff to get to him and I
said could you just give me your phone
number because like it would just be
easier if I could phone you when there
are issues that are you know
um on the front burner and Urgent and he
just said no he said he doesn't answer
his phone he doesn't usually have it on
nobody has the number and no
um with some of these other uh key
players that we've heard about uh Chief
slowly deputy chief Bell Mr arpan
himself city manager canalakos you had
all of their numbers and communicated
with them yes yes
and is it fair to say over the years uh
counselor Dean's uh you've had a number
of political disagreements with mayor
Watson is that fair to say yes
we've both been on City Council in one
fashion or another for two decades or
more yes
and um just prior to the freedom Convoy
or around that time you you had been uh
you'd indicated an intention that you
plan to run for mayor this year at that
time in December yes
and did mayor Watson never speak to you
about about that about whether he
thought it was a good thing for you to
run from air or not did he say anything
to you about that no
in uh notwithstanding your political
history uh with the mayor did you
believe that all of Ottawa needed to
respond as one team to this crisis
absolutely I think I described that this
morning like
um you know you can have
disagreements with someone
at any point when we're not all going to
like each other
but you have to be able to rise above
that and work together and especially in
a time of Crisis that has to be entirely
set aside you have to be as I described
this morning in the same boat rowing in
the same direction
and in retrospect councilor Deans
um is it now seen to you that this uh
political rivalry to some extent did in
fact interfere with the ability of uh
you to work collaboratively or
effectively with the mayor
um for your ability to work together
during this crisis I mean it certainly
it was impeded I I guess
take a little bit of issue
issue rivalry I was always willing to
work with mayor Watson
always and
um you know I
I mean we have political disagreements
it doesn't have to extend to a personal
animosity and I didn't want that I had
spoken to Mayor Watson about that on a
number of occasions I didn't see the
benefit of it
um so I don't know if I was feeling any
need to carry on a rivalry I was just
feeling a need to do my job
but did you perceive that he had some
animosity towards you yes
um just turning to then uh after chief
slowly resigned and and you and the
Police Services Board took steps to to
find a temporary replacement for him
um we'd heard the Mr pan testified that
he had a lot of criticism or even mayor
Watson you know they didn't follow a
process and so on and so forth why
didn't you follow a big lengthy
extensive process like the eight-month
period that we're seeing Police Services
Board now follow I mean it's just to me
the
the suggestion of that
kind of ridiculous I mean you can't go
through a protracted process in the
middle of an emergency when when you're
trying to shore up your senior command
and make sure that that senior command
has the tools in place to address a
crisis in your city and so there was
never an intention to hire anyone to be
the ongoing chief of police in Ottawa
without a process and I was frustrated
that it was characterized I mean the
mayor's office got ahead of that story
in the media by leaking it which it was
confidential information it was leaked
and they got ahead of that story and
characterized it as something quite
different than it was intended to be
you felt they were playing a bit of
politics with you in the midst of this
crisis in the city
I'm about never wasting a good crisis it
also presents an opportunities to settle
some old scores and I guess that's the
way I I viewed that yeah that's how you
felt yeah
um and and I'm not getting into the
reasons why you've already explained
quite well the rationale of the board
about why they were preferring external
candidate but just to be clear
um without Mr turingian taking over as
Chief as a result uh there left the auto
Police Service with an acting Chief and
uh two acting Deputy Chiefs is that
right
that's right so the the three top
positions in the Auto police were all
acting senior commanders his two
deputies and a chief and the CEO and as
you mentioned we had released our CIO
CEO in the past year and we had just
brought in a new civilian senior member
of the command team uh Blair dunker and
she had only just started so not only
did we have everybody in an acting
position we also had a brand new hire in
the civilian member of that senior
command
and just taking a just a half a step
back um you told us about you got wind
over the weekend of a potential motion
by city council to to call for the
removal or or resignation of Chief
slowly and when you heard about that you
contacted Mr arpan is that right yes Mr
Mayor Watson's um chief of staff
um now Mr arpan testified that he
communicated to you
um that such emotion would be a bad idea
he didn't you know that he needed to
work together to try to stop such
emotion is that what he told you
um we we had some text exchanges I know
that they've been provided uh to you
about this but
um
yeah I think you know he he's he
intimated through
that that
um at that point
um they weren't going to agree to it but
there was a lot of room for that to
change in in the conversation and there
was one text who said I forget what he
was referring to now but he said if
Peter's that stupid then it's his own
funeral
so so I he didn't he didn't give me any
confidence that
um the mayor's office and and I
described before the strong mayor model
before Doug Ford even conceived of a
strong mayor model we had one in Ottawa
that was devised by the mayor at the
beginning of the term and that our mayor
could
really win any vote and you know put on
have any any resolution put on the floor
of council or not have a resolution as
the case may be put on the floor of
council so it was always with the
consent of the mayor that what council
was dealing with
so if I understand what you're telling
us is that notwithstanding Mr pan saying
to reassuring you that you know the
mayor wouldn't necessarily support such
emotion you yourself had concerns that
he might flip suddenly and then support
emotion like that without I didn't hear
anything that was telling me that motion
wouldn't come forward it was there was
some hesitation there that didn't give
me relief in it it when I say that any
motion
wouldn't come to the floor of counsel
without the consent of the man I'm
talking about with his
um his 15 members of council that you
know always vote with him there are
other more and
yeah
often referred to as the Watson Club
um but the the independent members of
council May well have brought emotion
but that group usually worked with the
mayor in lockstep
now turning to uh your telephone call
with the mayor the the morning after uh
Chief slowly had resigned and you were
about to later that day announce that a
new Chief had been hired correct correct
and so we've heard testimony from you
already and mayor Watson about it we've
got this recorded conversation
um I just want to ask you did
you record that conversation with mayor
because you didn't trust him completely
is that fair yes
and uh oh by the way incidentally were
you aware when you were having that
conversation with the mayor that uh the
mayor's staff were already working on a
motion to remove you were you aware at
that time
um I'd heard it yeah
yeah but he didn't tell you that that's
that's what he was trying to do
no I I knew it
yes uh Maki Valley had nothing on our
mayor thank you very much Miss Dean's
it's all happen
thank you so the next up is the Ottawa
Police Service
commissioner
if I might raise this matter I
understand
um that there is going to be that the
recording the audio recording was going
to be played I understand that that
request has been made and we are not
opposed to it and I would suggest that
if it is going to be played let it be
played now before I start my
cross-examination
okay so it's just to get the
confirmation is there any objection to
the recording being played
the commissioner the city consents
seeing no objection uh
we'll sit back and listen to the witness
in our own words and uh the witness from
yesterday okay is that has that been
lined up is are we able to do that now
or is that a problem I believe we can
this has sort of just been dealt with on
the flight but I believe the hearings
clerk has its
poe.opb
uh0001 very efficient eh okay and I'm
Clerk
plan
just current version
hi John
hi I've got uh surge in the room with me
all right
there okay
go ahead
all right so so I'm hoping that I can
get a briefing on uh next steps with
respect to cheese facing Chief and um
uh What uh
those steps are in terms of you know
bringing some stability to the
organization so basically I'm going to
sign a contract with a new Chief today
and I believe he will start on Monday
and
Tuesday
pardon me
you're bringing a new Chief today
Monday he's going to start on Monday
who who is this and how did you find him
or her so his name's Matt turinikan and
he's former Chief of Waterloo you might
actually know him Jim he was he was a
deputy Minister maybe when you were in
Ontario
um but he is extremely well respected in
the police world and
um the the solicitor General's office
helped us gave us a short list we called
the people on the short list and he's
going to bring a team with him basically
of some former Chiefs with a lot of
depth of knowledge that are going to
come into assist him in getting this
thing to an end and it's a short term
like the way the contract is going to
work is it's going to be somewhere
between
um like a couple of months and the year
and I'm thinking probably the year end
so the new board can choose the new
Chief but it's basically a sort of a
semi-permanent contract it's for sort of
three months to ten months
so this is obviously a surprise
if I want to know yeah what what happens
to Steve is the Deputy Chief I mean I
the way I see him is that this is
probably going to save Steve's
opportunity to become the next chief
because you know the poison environment
that we have right now anybody we put in
there is not going to last very long and
Steve's going to get blamed for this so
um he will be Deputy Chief and continue
that way and then I think we'll have the
opportunity to become the next chief
well this is uh I I guess the problem I
have with this is there's been no
process there's no transparency there's
no uh sending out a call for people to
apply and we're in the midst of a crisis
and he's been the chief for acting chief
for one day and he's going to be
replaced tomorrow I mean I feel like he
knows that because I had a conversation
with him yesterday and I I sort of
intimated to him that we're looking to
bring someone in with you know knowledge
of experience and a team with them to
bring this thing to an end
um
um and you know I said to him I
recognize if we were to put you in there
right now like you own this I phoned him
last week by the way Jim and I asked him
what he would do differently if he was
the chief right now and he said nothing
which didn't instill a lot of confidence
um actually but I I think in the long
term that he will have a lot better
chance of of being able to be the the
chief of police in Ottawa If he if he
doesn't own this right now
so are you bringing this to the board
today the board's already approved it
when did they have a meeting to approve
them
yesterday
by reading your presidency is already at
work to put in place a new command so
actually pointing a new Chief very soon
my understanding was that we were going
to get through this with Steve
so it's a done deal basically well I
haven't signed the contract and then if
you want to tell me that you don't think
you want me to sign that contract I mean
I can go back to the board and tell them
that you would rather not
but I actually believe this is the right
thing to do Jim
wait well I I think this has come as a
big surprise where I live you know the
eve of some potential action obviously
something's gonna happen we think you
know I don't have any inside information
but want to assumed for the next couple
of days I think this would be very
destabilizing to the organization to
have someone who knows nothing about
Ottawa who's I don't know this guy don't
recognize his name maybe he was a deputy
when I was there but I it doesn't ring a
bell yes he is very well liked the
solicitor general told me that this the
soul dance officer advisor on our board
is a guy named Graham white he told me
that there's he called it an elegant
solution he thinks it's a very good
Solution on an interim basis for Ottawa
uh anyways you know I I don't support
this I think this is uh the wrong
Approach at the wrong time we're going
into the midst of what could be a very
serious operational uh
activity and uh the science will become
so by the way Steve uh we're sending you
aside to a guy who doesn't know where
Queen Street is
you know I I I respectfully disagree
like I really believe that this is one
in Steve's interest and two in the
community interest to get some people
with a lot more depth in this kind of
stuff than we have internally to
Ottawa Police right now to get this done
and you know Steve there's a lot of
internal angst I don't know how familiar
you are you are with the gym but there's
a lot of internal angst in that
organization I was just talking to
someone right now that was telling me
how they've been called off and
Steve's part of it so that there's
there's internal angst in the top ranks
right now
um and they're they're infighting you
probably know a little bit about the
infighting that's been going on in the
top ranks but I really think actually
bringing someone that rises above that
wouldn't be a bad idea
well I guess
process has been obviously secretive
you've had no opportunity to consult the
Bible Community or other members no is
that it's only an it's only a short-term
solution it's not the next chief of body
whites and interim until we do a search
for a chief
I mean I can't put Steve
in there to be the new Jeep without a
search either no this is protecting him
he's entitled to apply like anyone else
is who has the qualifications uh so you
know
I don't think there's a conflict because
he's the acting she said he's gonna fly
but right now it's basically our sole
source contract that these are about to
sign
which I accidentally but anyway you know
uh it's your call but I won't support
that and I think it'll destabilize the
organization
well
that's why I raised it right I mean I
thought you should know you you were the
mayor so if uh if you're telling me not
to do it then I will not do I don't I'll
go and have another board meeting and
tell them we're gonna have to change
again and I'll say I don't know what
I'll say right now
um is there in front of non-confidence
in me or the board coming to council
I haven't seen any motions
like you're Frozen that
hello
let me just text her I'll text her see
if she's disconnected
a picture
yeah I think she might be frozen I have
it too
hold on I'm just gonna rejoin just go
tell him I'll rejoin oh you're good now
Diane you're good now
am I back you're back
okay Jim I what what do you know about
what's coming that impacts me today or
the conversation that's happening I
think I I've worked really hard for the
last 20 days I think it would be a
courtesy to at least let me know what's
coming at me
and uh
see what uh their plans are and and if I
get any sense of what's going on I'll
try to give you a heads up
are you would you support a vote of
non-confidence in me
okay thanks all right well listen I
appreciate uh the heads up as I said I
hope that there's um that you don't rush
into this because I think it would be a
mistake uh at this point
and I think it would undermine Steve
Bell to have someone he's you know to
come in uh literally you know two or
three days after what what could have
been a
you know police action to try to consult
this nightmare we're all living through
there are a lot of people in the upper
Branch just so you understand that do
not support Steve Bell right now and
it's part of what's Happening inside I I
do you know never mind never mind
it's the it's the advisory body that
would come with this new chief that has
OPP and everyone else with that kind of
experience in terms of organization to
get this done
it's actually it's actually a really
good plan Jim
later yeah take care bye
okay
um so that's uh 10 minutes of your time
um
so uh go ahead
that's what I was trying to avoid
foreign
good afternoon councilor Deans my name
is David michikovsky act for the Ottawa
Police Service
counselor Deans um am I correct that
while Chiefs slowly
um was the chief he had asked for an
increase in the number of officers
yes
and uh officers had been hired uh over
the last several years but just to cover
attrition there was a hiring freeze
correct
yes
and as of 2022 I understand that Ottawa
Police had less officers sworn officers
than it did in 2019. is that correct
I'll take your word for it
um could I ask you uh please to turn up
OPB
one zero one two seven eight
and if we could please go to page four
uh you'll see
um that this was the meeting that you
were at correct
yes and at this point
um uh interim Chief Bell was in command
yes and a question was raised regarding
the services operational plan
um and then you got some information
from uh interim Chief Bell
correct yes he provided a briefing
and is it fair to say that you'd got a
lot more information as a board on
operationally what was going on at the
time when Chief Bell became the interim
chief there was definitely more
information provided this day so yes
and I believe on page four
if we go to the
uh the paragraph that starts a question
was raised uh yeah thank you
you'll see a question was raised
regarding the ineffective policing
having been seen in the city and it was
suggested there were instances in which
police could have engaged in enforcement
but did not am I correct then the
minutes accurately reflect interim chafe
Bell noted that the service had
committed to a review of all actions
having brought them to their current
situation
yes he indicated he would review it and
then if you look two paragraphs later
um if you go down to the paragraph a
question was raised Regarding why
roadblocks had not been installed prior
to the arrival of any convoys the
service again noted they were supportive
of a full review being conducted to
identify any mistakes made or laws that
required updating however their focus at
the time was forward-looking correct yes
and um if you go to page five
there was a request in the third
paragraph for twice daily updates from
the service to the board and this is
because the board wanted to get more
information than they felt they'd been
getting from Chief slowly is that right
I mean things were really heating up and
I think the board was getting more
assertive in
demanding information so yes
and interim Chief said he supported uh
increased Communications with the board
but twice daily updates wouldn't be
possible because from a resource point
of view that's taking a lot of Command
Staff away from time that is needed
operationally correct that's right and
that seemed reasonable uh to you it did
um you talked about
um
not trusting the mayor
is that correct
I don't think I talked about it I think
I confirmed an answer to a question that
I had recorded that conversation right
and in fact the person who recorded it
we can hear at the beginning is Jessica
correct correct that's Jessica Bradley
my executive assistant that's Jessica
Bradley yes and you asked her to record
it I did and that was a team's uh
meeting correct right right and so teams
has a function in which you can record a
meeting but if you do that it will show
that the meeting is being recorded so
that's not what you did is it um that's
not what we did I don't know if I knew
that or not I as I said earlier to the
commissioner I'm not
um the leading most expert in anything
technical but I just wanted to make sure
that we had an accurate reflection of
that meeting and you didn't tell uh the
mayor that you were recording that phone
call I did not nor did the mayor mention
to me that
um
Steve canalakis the city manager was a
silent observer in that room you heard
at the beginning he said that Serge was
in the room but he failed to mention the
city manager was also in the room and
are you saying that by way of justifying
why you recorded it no I I I I don't
feel a need to justify why I recorded it
you don't have any problems with the
ethics of recording a conversation and
not telling somebody that you're doing
it
didn't understand there to be any
um
reason not to and I could see in this
particular tense situation where I was
hearing rumors that I was going to be
unseated that there might be a reason
for me to file an Integrity commissioner
complaint later and an accurate record
of our conversation might be in order
and
wouldn't you be able to file an accurate
record of the conversation by saying hey
mayor I'm taping this conversation
yes I wouldn't have had any problem with
that either I I just failed to do it
I don't think it was calculated and is
that something you do regularly tape uh
no conversations it's not
so this just seemed like a good idea to
you at the time this was a very tense
moment I've been a member of council for
28 years I take pride in my reputation I
think I've worked hard for this city and
for the citizens of our city and I could
see that
um you know my my feeling was that the
at this point you know there was a lot
of information that was possessed by
senior City officials and the mayor that
had not been shared with the board
um
and they felt no reason to do that even
though we had the political oversight
and the only time we seemed to come into
their orbit was when they were looking
for a scapegoat
um I I take it uh councilor Deans you
support openness and transparency I do
and you would agree with me that
openness and transparency doesn't
include doing a secret recording of a
conversation I would suggest to you
Council that openness and transparency
is providing to a commission a fair and
reasonable and accurate description of a
conversation and what I said to the
mayor is that if he told me not to
go ahead with it with a emotion that had
been approved by the board I wouldn't
but he fell short of that he never he
said he hoped I would reconsider but he
never told me not to and so if you want
to talk about openness and transparency
maybe we could start there could we go
back to my questions sure my question
was would you agree with me that
openness and transparency uh doesn't
support doing a secret recording of a
conversation with the mayor
no I don't think I would you don't agree
with that no I think these were times
times and I think that
um you know there
I I felt a need to do that
and openness and transparency isn't a
problem for you
I think I've been very open and
transparent in my career
um and what I understood
um when I listened to the recording was
what you said to the mayor was if you
don't want me to sign the contract I
won't
there was I heard those exact words on
the audio yes and then you also sorry I
haven't asked my question
um
and am I correct that
um mayor what that at the end of that
convert and mayor Watson's response to
that comment was quote I think it would
be destabilizing
I don't favor it
I don't want it to occur was there any
doubt in your mind after that
conversation that mayor Watson did not
support what you were doing
no I agree mayor Watson did not support
what I was doing but mayor Watson does
not direct the operations of the board I
I'm the chair of a board that had taken
a decision and unless the mayor of the
city was directing me
not to then I was going to proceed and I
think I made that clear I mean I can
understand there's some Nuance on that
tape I understand that but I thought I
was quite clear if you were telling me
not to then I won't and I'll go back but
he fell short he said he hoped I would
reconsider at the end of that message
well aren't we playing word games I know
I don't think so let me finish my
question if you don't mind
um what you said was quote if you don't
want me to sign the contract I won't and
my question to you was was there any
doubt at the end of that conversation
that he did not want you to sign he
can't direct you to son not sign it no
and I said the question don't don't add
the
the editorial sure
yeah I think there were two parts but
perhaps we'd have to play it again but I
said if you are telling me not to I
won't
okay so and and I understand there's
some Nuance on the tape and perhaps he
misunderstood what we were saying to
each other but I thought it was quite
clear that unless I had
a direction for the mayor of the city of
Ottawa to overturn a decision of the
oversight body that had been taken
then I would proceed it I
I reported to the board not to the mayor
I I informed the mayor out of courtesy
and out of respect for the office of the
mayor
um you indicated
um I I am correct by the way when I say
the mayor cannot direct you as chair of
the Police Services Board to not do sign
a contract correct
yes I told him if he did direct me at
that point I would go back and have
another conversation
um one of the things you indicated was
that Graham white Graham white said that
your suggestion of Matt torrigan was an
elegant Choice correct An Elegant
solution he said um if I could ask
please to turn up document onto 01121
can you repeat the number counselor
I'm sorry it's uh o-n-t-o
o o o
one one two one
and you'll see there's an email uh from
uh Graham white Graham white was the
Police Services Board advisor yes
and so if you'd be good enough please
just scroll down
and so uh sorry if we can go up to the
first paragraph
just there perfect thank you
um
chair Dean stated that Matt torrigan had
tentatively agreed to take the role and
asked if the advisor me thought that was
a good idea I stated that I could not
endorse any person for the role but that
the Board needs to have a chief in place
ASAP because Chief slowly's agreement
expired at the end of the day I stated
clearly to the board that they are
prohibited from not having a chief in
place and should take steps to appoint a
chief of police as soon as possible that
is what Mr White uh his advice to you
was
yes
and um
you um
talked about the various complaints that
you heard uh about in the Ottawa Police
Service which you described as a
poisoned environment I think
right and I take it uh in spite of those
concerns you took no steps to
investigate whether that was true or not
true
um we had taken a lot of steps to delve
into the significant issue of workplace
sexual violence and harassment inside
Ottawa Police we hired
um Janice Rubin from Reuben Tomlinson in
Toronto we conducted a 10-month
investigation
into what was happening inside Ottawa
place with a view to improving the work
environment and the culture sure that
related to issues of sexual harassment
and sexism in the workplace correct
and and harassment in the workplace
right and so you did nothing to
investigate the specific poisoned
environment that apparently you heard
about from others and from Chief slowly
and in Your Capacity as board chair you
did not
investigate we forwarded specific
concerns to the ocpc for investigation
and you had not and there had not yet
been any investigation is that correct
we had not received a report from the
ocpc as to the outcome of their
investigation but it it's not the board
that investigates
themselves they forward it to ocpc for
investigation and so of course until you
have some sort of Investigation you
don't know you're operating on rumors
and innuendo and hearsay right
well you're operating on perhaps
allegations
but they are
unsubstantiated until the outcome of an
investigation
and so you indicated that you heard uh
that there was uh some issue with
respect to uh deputy chief Bell
you know particulars were provided and
you never investigated that correct
well we didn't have time to investigate
that but I had
heard that deputy chief Bell was
involved in some of that yeah and so you
thought it was okay to tarnish his
reputation and what he had done without
any investigation into that I don't
think I was tarnishing Deputy Chuck
Bell's reputation with all due respect I
mean I felt that we were making a good
decision at a very difficult time and
the way I saw it at the time is we were
preserving deputy chief Bell's
reputation
and you indicated that ultimately Chief
slowly was right
proved to be right I believe he was
right and so and yet when you spoke to
the mayor you recounted that when you uh
spoke to uh deputy chief Bell at the
time and he said to you he would not
have done something different you
thought that was a mark against him
and yet you're saying Chief slowly was
correct
in what well it turned out that what he
he had
what he had identified early on as the
resource requirement to end the
occupation of our city was quite correct
in the midst of that chaos that our city
was facing
um
I was wondering if there was more that
could be done and I phoned Chief Bell he
had a lot of experience inside the
Ottawa Police Service to ask him frankly
what he might do different and
he said nothing and in fact what he said
was the changing the leadership would
not be a good thing to do at this point
you phoned him before you'd made the
deal with Chief slowly you asked him
about it and he showed that he was loyal
to the Chief and he said it would be
destabilizing to now uh change
leadership correct yeah I think that's
fair
and you talked about allegations of
racism
I don't think I'd talked about it I
think I answered a question about it and
again am I correct that you had no
particulars of it you weren't faulting
anybody uh it may be a systemic issue in
policing is that is that fair
observation of what Chase slowly faced
when he got here racist memes uh other
things I'm sure you're familiar with
that made it very difficult for him
early on in his tenure and as a result
you entered into an agreement to pay
Chief slowly how much money to terminate
his contract
so commissioner
I'm sure there are a thousand people who
want to be heard on this issue I have no
idea how that could possibly be relevant
to the Mandate of the commission
I don't see why it isn't uh that's not
the test well the test is it's a pretty
broad mandate uh commissioner that you
have you're looking into all of the
circumstances we've looked at uh whether
the service had enough resources you're
going to look at how they expended their
funds the decisions they made during the
Convoy uh I submit that it may indeed be
relevant uh about an expense that the
board occurred at a time when this was
going on and it was a rather I suspect
significant expense
I'm sorry I've missed something
you say the commission is to look into
the expenses of the city no sorry I'm
sorry I wasn't there uh what I said is
that the or what I intended to say was
that the commission will be looking into
the circumstances that led to the
emergencies act you're looking at what
was going on in the Ottawa Police
Service you're looking at what happened
at the Ottawa Police Services Board and
it seems to me that in looking at that
issue uh it may be relevant to determine
what funds the board expended at this
time
I I don't see it as any having any
relevance the amount that was paid I
think it's been in evidence that he was
paid Severance and uh I don't think we I
don't see the relevance of going any
further that's fine thank you
um
uh you indicated and by the way your
time is up
if I might just have two more minutes
I'll give you a minute and a half
uh one of the things you said uh in your
conversation with the mayor was a lot of
people don't support Steve Bell correct
yes and you would agree with me that a
lot of people did not support Chief
slowly either
yes
and so those kinds of things are not
really things that you can take into
account in making decisions fair
well I think what I was referring to in
that conversation is
um the reason that the board had decided
to go outside with the temporary hire
and finally um
my question uh to you is
um
in retrospect because we have not had
the full review that um Chief Bell
indicated would take place you would
agree with me that we really do need to
examine what went on uh why it went on
and ultimately how to prevent it for the
future I don't know who is responsible
for that yeah I I would agree with you
that there needs to be a full
examination we need to learn from this
let's repeat it thank you very much
welcome
thank you you came under time
okay next is uh the Convoy organizers
good afternoon my name is Brendan Miller
I'm counsel for Freedom Corp which is an
organization that was incorporated to
represent uh
protesters are in their city in January
and February of 2022 first off though I
am not from here uh thank you for your
service uh as the police commissioner we
called police commissioner back home
thank you very much I I just want to
start off
um of course we didn't get the recording
until uh this morning in that recording
of your conversation with mayor Watson
uh you said you had been contacted by
someone with an Ops who had been called
off under the interim Chief ship that
was then in place of Steve Bell can you
kind of explain that for me
yeah
um
um I I have senior officer inside police
had phoned and and shared his version of
events with me and sort of just
informing me from his perspective what
was happening
um and
um he said that the day of that
particular
um planned event that The Incident
Commander was changed that day and that
um
oh there was some
um internal to just disagreement and it
led to the end of that particular
um operation okay and so I'm just gonna
have to ask you to clarify what is the
event and what is the operation you
speak of it was to a planned take out of
the intersection of Sussex and Rideau
okay so the plan that got canceled
so that my clients could move on and
then oh well that confirms what I was
looking for thank you uh
you uh did you know about the tripartite
meetings that the mayor was having with
federal government elected officials on
February 7th 8th and 10th of 2022 at the
time no he didn't tell you about that no
okay and so obviously you weren't
invited I was not invited no right and
of course that meeting was about police
resources yes right and you're the chair
of uh what we you know called commission
the uh uh
Ottawa Police Service Board correct and
so you run that board that decides how
to Dole out resources to the police
right right okay
and did you know that on January 30th
2022
um Chief slowly had asked the city and
the city somewhat agreed to get an
injunction were you aware of that
um on on what date uh January 30th 2022.
it's all a little foggy there was
definitely discussions about injunctions
that didn't move forward I don't think I
can confirm for you exactly the dates
okay
um the injunctions that you did discuss
did you ever discuss that the terms of
that injunction would be to both remove
the trucks and get the honking to stop
is that fair
I don't think I had that level of detail
no okay
did Chief slowly ever tell you in any of
your conversations that on January 31st
2022 RCMP commissioner Brenda lucky uh
told him not to get the injunction
because it would be an official movement
to another stage that it would involve
the whole country and that anything
official will spark a national response
did he ever say that to you
not to the best of my recollection I'll
ask him and commissioner lucky then so
you did not know
um that but you did know that the
federal Police Service the RCMP had been
involved in the matter in dealing with
the protesters yes okay and to your
knowledge after January 31st 2022 did
Chief Sully ever advise to get an
injunction still after that point
there was I believe I mean the timeline
is just a little bit all meshed together
in my mind but I believe there were
still ongoing discussions
okay
and
to your knowledge I just want to make
this clear because I know that you were
in sort of a vacuum so but you did know
that from January 25th to February 14th
22 that there were multiple Police
Services involved in dealing with this
matter yes right and that included the
Ottawa Police Service the Ontario
Provincial Police and the RCMP
among others among others yes
and
I take it that
um you know as well at the federal level
and the provincial level it's not
politicians that decide where to uh
execute or carry out and apply police
Resources with respect to events and
investigations but it's the police
agency itself because they're
independent
right
and to my knowledge as well and I wanted
to put this to you is there any
prohibition on yourself or members of
the Ottawa Police Service Board of
council uh contacting someone like
commissioner lucky or the commissioner
of the opp to have a discussion about
resources
I believe there's any prohibition doing
that I think the um
protocol though would be that
politicians speak to politicians and
police officers speak to police right
but is it true with the commission that
you do invite sworn members of police
agencies like the opp and the RCMP to
meet with the Ottawa Police Service
board at times and you have in this case
too I believe yeah right so is it fair
to say that there was nothing stopping
the Ottawa Police Service Board from
asking for any of the Commissioners from
the opp or the RCMP to come before them
in order to have a conversation about
resources
yeah I think that's fair to say okay can
I ask just and I'm not trying to poke
but why wasn't that done
yeah I I've been asking myself that
question too
um
I mean our
I don't know I mean if I were doing it
again would I to that probably yes
um but at the time we were receiving
information through the channel of the
police service and and that was our
primary source of information okay and
you'd already discussed the company
Navigator a little bit and it was in the
news and I know they contacted you when
was Navigator retained for the Ottawa
Police Service do you remember months
and months previous to this event I mean
we the board had given a direction to
the Police Service to
amp up the communications function
because we felt that it was quite
inadequate but they came back to the
board with I mean I'm not going to get
this entirely right but the the
sentiment was we don't have time to amp
up because we don't have enough people
to do that so we just need to hire some
help from now and they wanted to hire
Navigator because they had some
relationship with Navigator and so
that's they they chose I know their
crisis Communications firm but they were
also providing regular Communications
advice to Ottawa Police okay because how
it was seemed to have been spun in the
media is that they were hired
specifically due to Chiefs slowly not
being able to deal with this yeah no
that was done way in advance okay that's
good I just wanted to know that and then
I understand that when the retainer did
happen and it's good to know it was that
far away I if I'm what I'm about to ask
you is correct I understand the retainer
with Navigator was 75 000 on a
fee-for-service basis but it was a maybe
not paid up front but it was a 75 000
cap which is usually less than what
their normal retainer of a hundred
thousand is is that about accurate don't
know if I actually knew what the details
of that retainer were okay now I also
understand the Ottawa Police Service had
retaining assistance from a company
called Advanced symbolic Inc also known
as ASI
yeah do you wear them when was ASI
retained
and certainly in advance of this this
occasion Chief slowly had
brought a representative from ASI to the
board
basically to talk about
the benefits of ASI and he he felt that
there was
um
that their services could be useful
okay and what was ASI doing for the
Ottawa Police Service exactly could you
explain that I have an understanding but
I I'd like you to explain it I'd like
chip slowly to explain it
if you don't mind because
um
I mean I think
my very
very limited understanding of ASI is
that it basically searches many many
many sites and and sort of pulls out key
words to create an impression of
public opinion if you will right would
it be fair to say and when the ASI was
discussed with you did they refer to the
phrase data analytics probably yes okay
so they get all this stuff and then they
give you uh in a report or to Chief
slowly the public perception of what's
going on so that Chief slowly and his
team know how to react right
I think generally speaking that's
correct okay
now I want to take uh you know one part
and I'm wondering if you're aware of
this and it's come up with some of the
production
do you remember when it was announced I
believe the
Ottawa Police Services had mentioned
that they had been in touch with
provincial Child and Family Services
about apprehending children in the
protest do you remember that vaguely
were you aware that it was Navigator who
told them to do that no thank you
now
I just want to get into sort of your uh
you know what you had said you stated
that you had an intention to work
together and put aside political
differences and it's it's good to hear
that and I'm sure the public is happy to
hear that as well
um
I'm just going to have to ask you can
you tell me about your relationship
between yourself and mayor Watson
I mean I don't know what there is to
tell I have worked with mayor Watson for
a very long time we have worked on many
files together over the years I think I
enjoyed
more confidence in the mayor until
relatively recently until this term of
counsel when I detected just perhaps a
change in in mayor Watson's General
approach and it goes far beyond me I he
he had for whatever reason at the start
of this term decided to build more of a
coalition
approach to governing than he had in the
past and I wasn't part of that Coalition
so I suppose in some ways became a bit
more of an outsider than I had been
before but when I had worked with him on
a Transit Commission for example we were
Landing a Presto card that didn't work
we worked very well together okay could
you agree with me that the tension also
started
when you decided to you announced at
least to him maybe privately or or maybe
publicly that you intended to bring a
motion to fund uh litigation as against
Bill c21 do you remember that
well I don't think that's when it
started that was just one of many many
many
disagreements politically we had and
listen I don't think there's anything
wrong with political disagreements I
think it's actually quite healthy for
our democracy so we don't have to agree
on every issue I think the issue is when
it becomes personal okay and so moving
on to the issue with the hiring of the
interim Chief you heard yesterday and in
the recording we heard that mayor Watson
claimed that he had concerns about your
uh and your council's appointment of the
proposed new interim Chief Matthew
torgen because there was not enough
consultation with stakeholders right
right
before Steve Bell became the intern
Chief how much consultation was there
you mean at the very end when he's right
at the beginning so when Steve Bell took
over as interim Chief how much
consultation did mayor Watson DO
right so
it's fair to say that the issue that
mayor Watson took with your counsel or
your board appointing a chief on the
basis that there was no consultation
it's fair to say he went about it and
did no consultation and had his own
appointed would you say that
yes thank you
now
I just wanted to cover one point I
believe it was covered but just not with
the specific Association because there's
two police unions correct there's the
one for senior officers and then the
other ones I also understand your
evidence that it was also the Ottawa
Police senior Officers Association which
is those with ranks of Inspector and
hire who also did not want slowly as
their first choice for mayor or sport
for chief back in 2019 is that correct
yeah I don't think I really knew that
until you know sometime after he was
hired
okay
and with respect to Chief slowly's
relationship uh in your statement you
specifically mentioned he had issues
with the relationship with the Community
Health Resource Center can you elaborate
on what that was
yeah it was just an observation that I
had made through the budget process for
in the setting of The 2022 budget the
Ottawa Community Health and Resource
Centers came forward with proposal
really for some alternative Service
delivery in terms of addressing
mental health calls and
addictions calls and housing crisis
calls and
um
there was a lot of tension through the
budget process between those
organizations that I observed okay and
was that organization the community
health and Resource Centers I take it if
there was issues in the budget it had to
do with tension between funding that the
Ontario Police Service was getting
versus funding they were not or Etc is
that what it was
Ontario please sir oh sorry sorry uh
Ottawa Police Service so the Ottawa
Police Service is getting some a lot
higher funding I take it they wanted
more funding and was that the tension no
no I don't think it was that I think it
was that there is a growing
perspective in our community that police
are responding to
calls for crisis
situations like someone experiencing
homelessness or someone having an
addictions crisis or a mental health
crisis and that that isn't always the
right response and um there are growing
cries in the community to set up a new
system where if you called 9-1-1 you
might be calling for paramedic you might
be calling for fire you might be calling
for a place or you might be calling for
a mental health worker and so I think
um
there are a lot of voices in the
community and Community including
Community Health and Resource Centers
that would like to see you know at least
an opportunity where I mean if if
you might be dispatching more than one
you might dispatch fire and police and
mental health worker but right now
police are the responders
because they take up that space not
because they're necessarily trained
in crisis response of that nature or not
because they're necessarily the best
response and so I think there was some
tension between
Chief slowly and the community that
would like to see a change in some
modest change in police response to
those types of calls that was very
detailed has anyone ever told you maybe
you should be the chair of the police
board
not recently
question is this um is it fair to say
that one of the biggest contentions with
respect to getting information uh from
she slowly wasn't so much just with the
information based on everyone's public
statements within your Council what they
wanted to know is
can you give us a date when the protests
will end they can you give us a date if
it's not going to end how you're going
to remove them is that fair
that's really what you wanted to know
that's what your constituents were
bugging you about I I mean in Broad
Strokes I think that's fair right and
chief slowly and to know full of his own
and uh he couldn't tell you that because
he didn't even know
and and if those resources hadn't
arrived
um
or perhaps if we hadn't had extra tools
like the emergencies act uh
they might still be here well and I
understand the extra tools and I guess
we can argue about that sure any would
you agree with me that if there was a
like order to the emergencies act to
remove the protesters Etc as long as you
had the resources uh that you know based
on your knowledge as a former uh
chair of the Police Service Board the
police could have removed these
protesters simply with the court order
on the same terms is that fair
person to assess that thank you okay
make the pitch to him instead
thank you very much
okay thank you the next is the
government of Canada and as you come up
if I can just be clear I'm sure you know
this Mr majikovsky is that if it becomes
relevant the question about salary with
another witness or you somehow becomes
irrelevant to this commission you can of
course renew the question I'm sure you
know that but I just want to be to be
clear about that thank you very much
commissioner
but thank you um uh Ms Dean's uh
I'm uh Brendan Vinnie and I saw one of
the lawyers for the government of Canada
on this inquiry I'm just going to try to
ask you some uh hopefully less
controversial questions about your
experience and your capacity as the
board share for this jurisdiction at the
time sure and I'm going to do so by
reference to some of the documents that
you've looked at already but I'm going
to focus on some particular facts that
come out of them
um may I ask to pull up OPB four zeros
one six two four
this is the February 1st of a board
update a documentum
uh Council Deans which um
uh just to situate you February 1st was
the Tuesday after the initial Convoy
weekend if we could go to page seven
please
uh
and if you could just uh move down a
little bit
um into that paragraph that starts Chief
there just to confirm what the chief was
reporting to you already by February the
1st a few days into this was the
international dimensions of this matter
is that fair yes and that this is going
to have provincial National and
international consequences and he's
referring to demonstrations already
being seen in the United States stemming
from this one yes
uh any points to the fact that this is
coming out of a global pandemic and is a
very different scenario than what you
saw in November of the previous year
right
yes
could we go now please to opb401264
and this would be several days later
councilor Dean's it's the February 5th
meeting of the board and that would have
occurred am I right on the Saturday of
the second weekend that's correct
if we go to page three please
I think this is the for the initial
occasion on which Chief slowly both in
this some board meeting and elsewhere
indicates his view that there may not be
uh a policing solution alone to the
demonstration do you see that yes
and um if we look uh further down the
page on page three to the third last
paragraph
uh just a little further down thank you
um
it's that paragraph that starts in the
medium term there
do you see that there's an indication
that the service in the second sentence
is highlighting the need for additional
legal supports in the short and medium
term and is requesting assistance to
find Uncharted legal territory
and you appreciated that you were being
informed that the criminal code Powers
at the highway traffic act in the city
of Iowa Ottawa bylaws were somewhat
limiting in respect of their application
to the trucker Convoy yes
if you could just go over the page to
page four
in the third paragraph
the service pointed out to you and the
rest of the board did it that there was
an ability of the demonstration
organizers to spread a narrative via
social media
yes yes and uh that this was connected
to the need for additional legal
resources to advocate for legislative
changes that would provide for increased
powers of enforcement in these kinds of
situations fair fair
and did you take that as a suggestion
that existing legal authorities at the
time were at least in the view of the
service not adequate to deal with the
situation already by that second weekend
it took that they believed there was a
possibility that through
um legislative changes we could create a
better situation
okay can we go to um
opb401647 this is the continuation of
that same meeting but the in-camera
portion of it
and if you could go to page three of the
end camera minutes
if you could just move down the page a
little bit and just stop there do you
see the paragraph in which Chief slowly
is speaking and comparing the situation
to that of the 2011 Stanley Cup rights
in Vancouver yes
and here he characterizes a distinction
here in the second two in the last two
sentences he says that this
demonstration ongoing in Ottawa
consisted of thousands of people
convinced that the pandemic approach has
been wrong right yes and that's an
approach that was taken by not just
municipalities but by the federal
government and of course by provincial
governments across the country
yes
and uh He suggests that the service is
intelligence at that time suggested that
some participants
for them being arrested injured or even
killed was viewed as achieving a level
of martyrdom rather than a deterrent
you said that yeah was that a serious
concern when the board heard that
I think all of this was taken seriously
by the board yes could we go to calm
com50641
this is an article from the CBC um
website that appeared on February the
5th and I I take it this was the same
day well that would be the same date as
that board meeting so probably prior to
that meeting is that fair
uh yes okay yes if we could go to uh I
think it's the second page
um uh just continue on downwards
we're looking for a quote from from your
self-counselor Deans if you just keep
going down the page
maybe a bit further
uh okay so just at the top of the next
page which is Page four you see your
quoted dare is saying the city's Under
Siege yes and looking for a concrete
plant
that is how I felt yeah
uh could you go to the top of the next
page
you're quoted here councilor Deans is
saying people can't go to work or open
their businesses they can't sleep walk
shop go to medical appointments or enjoy
their neighborhood this group is a
threat to democracy what we're seeing is
bigger than just a city of Ottawa
problem this is a nationwide
Insurrection this is madness is that a
fair attribution of your comments that
is exactly what I said and is that how
you view things at that second weekend
already it is
can we go to um well I don't need the
duck but I just want to bookmark the
timing two days later on February the
7th which would be the Monday after the
second weekend
you co-signed a letter with mayor Watson
to the Prime Minister and to minister
Mendocino right yes requesting more
resources from the federal government
yes
and that same Monday February the 7th
you sent a similar letter or you signed
a similar letter with the mayor that was
sent to the premier as well as to
solicitor general Jones right that's
correct
and we've seen those before so we won't
go back to them should we now go to Ott
406610
this would be the minutes of the council
meeting the special counsel meeting that
was convened on the Monday evening of
the seventh yeah afternoon rather
and just ask that we turn to a page at
10.
it'll be the bottom of the page a motion
at the bottom of the page
uh and just so you can see the Mover is
secondary but go to the top of page 11
and you'll see the output this is the
motion that asks the government of
Canada to take responsibility for
policing in effect in the Parliamentary
Precinct right yes and you were in favor
of that motion
yes
and if you go then to page 17
of the same
document
and carry down the page you'll see this
motion moved by councilor me and
counselor McKinney
referring to the federal emergencies act
and resolving that the city should enter
into discussions
with the minister of Public Safety to
see whether the emergencies act could be
invoked right yes and that's because you
saw the need already for additional
legal measures from what the service had
been telling you to date
yes
and you uh voted in favor did you have
this emotion I did
uh February 8th was the Tuesday if we
could go to ott405837
and I don't need to spend a lot of time
on this but this is a note from Chief
slowly the next morning
uh sorry next evening rather and he's
writing in reference to that motion the
first motion we'd looked at with respect
to the RCMP assuming jurisdiction over
the precinct right right and if you just
scroll down the page for In fairness to
you do you recall Chief slowly providing
you this information to remind you I'm
sure you're familiar with it already but
that under the Ontario Police Services
act the RCMP does not defined as a
police service right right and for that
reason some of these steps that we've
spoken about earlier you've spoken about
earlier had to be taken such as having
each of the RCMP officers formally sworn
in in groups right
and another one of the steps that had to
occur was the signing of a formal
memorandum of agreement to Define their
roles correct correct and I believe you
signed that on February the 8th as well
right right
and if we could go to
um
OPB four five zeros 858
this is on February 10th it's the
Wednesday now ahead of the third weekend
after the second
um this appears to be an email from
Julia Kiest of your office yes and you
are one of the addresses and it is
approving a request if you want to
scroll down the page
it reflects you approving a request to
delegate the authority to swear in up to
400 members of the RCMP correct correct
and the last thing that would need to
happen in that regard was the approval
of the solicitor general for for those
officers as well right right okay
if we could go now to OPB four zeros one
two seven two
this will be February 11th the minutes
again of the board meeting
and these will be the public minutes
that will be the Thursday ahead of the
third weekend right
yes excuse me the Friday
um
if we could go to page three to the
second last paragraph
foreign
ized again to you by the the service if
I'm understanding this rate that there
was a number of different reasons that
individuals were demonstrating in no one
particular line of thinking right right
the demonstrations had become or and
continued to become a local provincial
National and even International issue
yes and the service was concerned about
money and supports coming in from other
countries including the U.S right
if we go to page four in the third last
paragraph
uh there you'll see the note that the
service had been in conversation
regarding the mitigation of risks
associated with counter protest you see
that
no
uh it's ready all right okay yep
and um what that's referring to if I
understand right is the fact that Ottawa
residents by now
uh we're awfully tired angry and
frustrated right
very and there was a real concern that
citizens would start to take matters
into their own hands in a fashion that
could lead to real violence right there
is growing evidence of that yes
and that was a concern to you and your
colleagues on the board it was
lastly
and I see him almost other times we'll
wrap this up very quickly
um if we could just go to the
encampments for one item OPB four zero
is one six four eight
and to the top of page four
thank you and I just want to point out
that again here you're informed by the
service and camera that National and
International Security blind spots were
being pointed to
and due to the cumulative blind spots
the Ops lacks the capacity to address
the unfolding situation right yes did
that refer in part or a substantial part
to
the awareness of the organization of the
Convoy online and the impact of social
media on those who'd come in to occupy
Ottawa I believe it did okay thank you
those are my questions
thank you
next is the Democracy fund and jccf
let's cut a little off guard there
um and for the sake of the sign language
interpreters who I'm sure I tortured a
little bit yesterday I'll try and go a
little more slowly today
um good afternoon councilor Deans uh I'm
Rob kittridge I represent the Justice
Center for constitutional freedoms as
someone who has caught up in as you put
at what happened in Toronto during the
G20 and uh in some of the more egregious
events addressed in the Morden report I
was encouraged to hear that you did your
best to prevent similar mistakes and
overreach in Ottawa
and in furtherance of that goal you felt
that you and the opsb might have been
able to intervene to help with Ops
requests for assistance from other
police forces or various levels of
government is that correct that's
correct
um you understood the ops's expressed
need for quote additional resources to
mean that they needed additional police
officers correct yes
yes when after that February 5th meeting
when Chief slowly outlined his resource
requirement not all 1800 were were
uniformed officers some were civilian
but he made that clear at that time
right but it was essentially people on
the ground that uh meant by resources
skilled resources yes did he uh did he
use the word resources to refer to
anything other than people on the ground
you mean like weapons or
no like I I guess I'm just getting at
the point that we've heard the word
resources a lot today and I just want to
understand what that means yeah I think
by and large it means
um it means skilled trained
right
um while we've heard that uh the
criminal code existing bylaws Etc may
have been somewhat limiting the Ops
didn't express to you any specific need
for any specific additional legislative
powers did they
I do not believe so
and your understanding was that while
legislative change may have been useful
to police it wasn't required strictly
speaking is that a fair characterization
I don't know the answer to that question
I mean maybe well be required and it
might be some things very useful but in
the moment and probably
wasn't going to happen
right
do you feel that uh Ops was making
effective use of the resources personnel
and equipment that they had available to
them at all times during the protests I
I'm prom by a question much better put
to achieve slowly because as we've made
pretty clear I'm not involved in the
day-to-day operations right as a citizen
of Ottawa were you satisfied with uh
there are extra with the use that they
were making of the resources personnel
and equipment that they had available to
them
you know was I satisfied with the
response the whole way through no I was
not
um but did that mean they weren't using
their resources wisely I I I
couldn't answer that question with any
degree of certainty I was aware that
they did not have sufficient resources
fair enough and a similar question that
I suspect will get a similar answer uh
did you feel that the Ops was
effectively of enforcing existing laws
and bylaws at all times during the
protests given the resources available
too I was frustrated with some of the
enforcement efforts especially getting
calls from constituents and other
members of council about enforcement I
understood the reasons that were given
to us that they had to put Public Safety
First on the safety of the bylaw
officers and their officers first I
certainly understood it but from a
public perspective it was frustrating
fast
we've we've heard that during the
protests there was an amendment made to
the city's idling bylaw can you tell us
what the time frame for making that
change was how quickly it was able to be
done it was done quite quickly I believe
I can't tell you exactly how long it
took would be something on the order of
a day
possibly
would it be fair to say that if the Ops
required further bylaw amendments these
could also have put been put in place
very quickly yes
um
and uh in light of uh our us having
reached a reasonable set of uh
agreements on my questions a few
questions ago I'll skip this one
um uh
so how how would you say that the
tension between yourself and the mayor
interfered with the resolution of the
protests we've heard we've heard a lot
about the fact that there was tension
but how did it interfere with uh
resolution
you know that
ah
as I said earlier I believe that
everyone needed to be working together
you know it you can equate that to a
team sport of kicking the ball up and
down the field in two different
directions and you're on the same team
you're probably not getting where you
need to go and I don't think it was just
the mayor and myself I think that there
were you know what just listening to the
evidence about the information that was
shared with the city of Ottawa I'm not
sure what the police board is
frustrating to me we all needed to be on
the same team and I think
um you know I'm I'm not going to Center
at the mayor for spent special attention
I I just think that
um
I mean and possibly part of it was the
pandemic and we weren't all in the same
room we weren't all operating out of
City Hall I was operating out of my home
the entire time and you know perhaps
some of it was that too because when
you're not together
you're not getting that same dynamic as
if you're all in the same room and there
might have been some of that too and in
that I I understand there was some
tension between Chief slowly and Bill
Blair and also some infighting at the
Ops that may have also contributed is
that fair to say I think it's fair to
say that we weren't all in the same boat
roaming in the same direction at all
times
it wasn't optimal
all right you would hope that Ottawa
would avoid the sort of mistakes and
overreach that occurred under then Chief
Bill Blair's command at the Toronto G20
in 2010 but Ops didn't really have a
plan to deal with the protests the city
lost control of its streets and in the
end a National Emergency was was
declared and here we are hard at work on
ottawa's own version of the Morton
report
as much as
well-intentioned people like yourself
tried to apply lessons from Toronto's
G20 you weren't able to prevent mistakes
and overreach on a similar scale were
you not entirely no maybe maybe we made
different mistakes we you know I if you
don't learn from your mistakes you risk
repeating them and I think that's the
benefit of all of this
um hopefully
um we're going to learn from our
mistakes and the next time something
happens uh it will go smoother than it
did this time right but this time the
crisis was mishandled by police and all
levels of government wasn't it
I think we could have done better thank
you very much those are my questions
okay thank you next we have the National
Police Federation commissioner they've
uh they've advised commission Council
that they're seeding their time
okay
so we're now back to uh the final uh the
uh Ontario Police uh the Ottawa Police
Services Board do you have any uh any
re-examination none whatsoever thank you
very much um
it did and I skipped you
ah
I apologize go ahead no problem uh
Alyssa Tompkins Council for the city of
Ottawa
uh councilor Deans uh am I correct that
your evidence was that the first time
you heard that resources were being held
up was because Chief slowly did not have
a plan for the resources was when Mr
kanolako said it on Monday
yeah I believe that's the case I had not
been told that throughout
okay so um Mr commissioner can I have
permission to take the witness to her
witness summary to refresh her memory
I think it's been entered uh as I
understand it so yes can we please bring
up document wts.000010
and counselor Dean's you this is your
witness summary yes it is I you reviewed
the summary and had an opportunity to
make any changes yeah
and you adopted it this morning in fact
so if we could just go to the bottom of
the third page
and that last complete sentence States
according to counselor Deans there is a
possibility that resources were being
held up because Chief slowly did not
have a plan for the use of the resources
counselor you'll agree
that in fact this is something that you
suggested during your interview with
commission Council and not something
that you heard for the first time during
Mr kennel aquos's evidence yeah I'm
going to agree with that because it's
right there but I can't recall exactly
what I was referring to
in in this statement I mean the the
level of detail that I've been hearing
through this process and heard from Mr
canalakis and
um are in the reports from the opp and
RCMP about uh their level of concern was
never intimated to me I mean I may have
broad scale
um heard something but I had no detail
that is now entered into evidence from
from this commission and it it came as a
huge surprise to me
no further questions
okay
yes
commission council with
I think that was it for the oh sorry
could I address you on just one point
commissioner um the question that you
ruled uh not relevant holds great
significance for the board as the
employer of the former Chief and we're
not a party
and I don't know how we would deal with
the possibility of that being Revisited
I know the council for for chief slowly
and the board would take the same
position but
um
uh I don't know that there's any is
there some other way to deal with that
if the board's interests were engaged
again I may not be able to achieve
anything but I thought it would at least
raise it with you you can raise it I
think Chief slowly's counsel uh our
former Chiefs slowly's Council would
would raise the issue if it is brought
up as I understand it I just was
pointing out the the normal routine and
if it becomes relevant uh uh
I'm not sure how we would deal with it
it was simply there because when Chief
slowly testifies I can't anticipate
what's going to happen
and sometimes something is not relevant
at one point but further Evidence
raises issues I not much I can do about
that but I'm on notice that you you have
a view and
uh I think we can deal with it when uh
when and if the time comes thank you
very much for your consideration that's
all I have today okay
um and uh so that completes as I
understand it's subject to
re-examination uh I because I I take it
you have no further submissions on
behalf of the board none whatsoever
thank you brother okay so go ahead two
uh brief questions
um counselor Deans you were asked a
number of questions on Cross about the
the uh information you received do you
feel that the board received the
information it required to exercise its
oversight functions
I believe the board could have done
a better job in exercising its oversight
function if it hadn't been provided with
relevant information that it did not
receive
and we we listened to the recording
there's a number of questions about that
as well in your view did the mayor
interfere with the board's autonomy by
exerting pressure on the chair
um the mayor fell short of directing me
not to do something so that clearly
would have been interfering with the
board I think that the mayor and Council
came very close
in the mayor made some public statements
that he was going to ask Matt to again
to step aside and and put to fell into
place and
um
I think the police services act there is
some draft legislation that hasn't been
proclaimed yet that would preclude that
type of interference in the work of the
Police Services Board and not allow that
kind of political interference by a
council or a mayor
so I think it was very close to the line
yes did you feel like it was a new
pressure was being imposed on you well I
understood the consequences being
imposed on me that was pretty clear but
I felt
I don't I've always felt this way I I'm
there
um to do a job and I have to do the job
to the best of my ability and if I
believe
uh and I believe that I had the most
information that that is in the best
interest of the community then I need to
do the job and not be
unduly influenced by a political
pressure
thank you counselors thank you Mr
commissioner
okay so I think that ends uh the
testimony of uh councilor Deans uh thank
you very much uh you uh for your
evidence for coming forward and as was
said earlier for your service
uh we're going to go take a 15-minute
break uh
until we move to the next witness it
looks like it'll be another late day so
people should prepare in consequence not
sure how late we'll go uh because what
we don't get done today will be added to
tomorrow
um so uh 15 minutes uh we'll come back
at 25 after four thank you the
commission is in recess for 15 minutes
and just one one last I just want to
thank Council for having worked out the
potential issues uh it's appreciated and
the resolution is is always appreciated
with respect to
time and disputes thank you
foreign
the commission is we convene that coming
so well
[Music]
go ahead commissioner Eric brusso at
commission Council and I'd like to call
OPP superintendent Pat Morris as the
commission's next Witness
foreign
superintendent Morris well you swear on
a religious document or do you wish to
affirm
I will swear we have the Bible the Quran
and the Torah are available
please take the Bible in your right hand
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out
Patrick John Joseph Morris m-o-r-r-i-s
do you swear that the evidence to be
given by you to this commission shall be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth will help you God I do
swear
afternoon superintendent Morris good
afternoon I'm gonna start with an easy
one what is your current rank I'm a
superintendent in the opp Bureau
commander of the provincial operations
intelligence Bureau and is that the rank
that you held in January and February
2022 that's correct okay and I'd like to
call up your interview summary which is
WTS 6035
uh and this this is a summary of the
interview uh the commission Council
conducted with you in the in the summer
correct correct and uh you're familiar
with the contents of this summary I am
you have no uh corrections to make to it
no okay thank you
um and you mentioned that you are
uh you oversee the OPP's provincial
operations intelligence Bureau which I
will refer to as poib can you tell us
how long have you overseen that Bureau
I've been the superintendent in charge
of poib since September of 2021 having
acted in that position since July of
2021 and prior to that I was an
inspector in POI responsible for two
sections that are relevant to these
matters and can you give us the
30 second elevator pitch of what poib
does
yes provincial operations intelligence
Bureau is the intelligence directorate
or Bureau for the Ontario Provincial
Police so responsible for our
jurisdiction and also under the police
services act for issues where we provide
specialized Investigative Services we
have six sections within the bureau the
first is intelligence operations section
which has to do with organized crime
Etc the second is the protective
services section which has to do with
close body protection for protected
persons in the province of Ontario the
third is covert operations section which
has to do administratively with policies
and procedures in relation to covert
operations undercover operations and
formant recruitment agent Recruitment
and handling
um and also the operational
responsibility for that the next section
is the criminal intelligence production
section which is primarily the handling
of metadata information and the
translation of information into
intelligence and the last section is the
provincial anti-terrorism section which
is a large-scale Joint Force operation
which engages in intelligence operations
covertly and overtly in relation to
National Security threats lastly we're
engaged in the integrated National
Security enforcement teams thank you if
I if I could just interrupt uh
superintendent just if you could slow
down a little bit because all this is
getting translated as you go so sure I
know you're
effective but effective with a little
more patience and D in speed speaking
will help thanks will do thank you
superintendent um you're familiar with
the term project Hendon can you describe
for us what project Hendon is
yes I you'll have to cut me short
probably
um in 2019 and to early 2020 the opp
witnessed
a significant amount of protest dissent
some of which caused us reasonable
grounds to suspect or believe that those
issues would engage in criminal activity
or illegal activity that would have a
public safety impact
as a result of that we
created a collection plan and reached
out to Partners in law enforcement and
in the intelligence Community to create
a Cooperative collaborative approach to
collect information on issues that
related to that the reasoning was
many of these issues I might say all of
those issues are larger than any
specific jurisdiction so we collected a
collection plan we sorry we made a
collection plan we created business
rules and we formally reached out to
multiple agencies in Ontario law
enforcement intelligence we went further
than Ontario engaging federal agencies
such as the RCMP many components within
the RCMP the Canadian Security
intelligence Service Department of
National Defense and then other police
services were added as we went along
because there was impact so for example
The Vancouver Police Department Sierra
Teja Quebec
Etc
the rationale for Hendon
was to deal with large-scale protest
matters that impacted Public Safety
very specifically we did look at
reasonable grounds to suspect and
believe as a sort of precursor for our
involvement
in a very practical way at the beginning
of 2020 and the end of 2019 there was
activity going on that had to do Under
the Umbrella of shut down Canada it was
activity that activists would engage in
to have a negative impact on the
Canadian economy and on the Canadian
democratic system generally
as we move towards
February of 2020 one of the major points
of consideration was rail blockades rail
shutdowns which came to pass in tie the
Nega for approximately three weeks
emanating from events in British
Columbia specifically the wet sawetan
issues and dealing with gas pipelines
Coastal Gas link Etc
we began at that time to engage closely
with all of our partners because there
were Main Events such as time danega
such as British Columbia but there were
also a proliferation of events and as my
colleague inspector Bowden will say and
provincial liaison team it was impacting
multiple jurisdictions and so that's how
we chose to approach it
As Time evolved
we had several events in Caledonia and
then the McKenzie Meadows occupation
which were relevant to our duties and
also had impact for other police
services I believe at that time we
engaged approximately 30 entities we had
regular calls we had regular
dissemination of intelligence products
and we regularly collected information
for that purpose
as the pandemic became more pronounced
or more prolonged some of those public
safety concerns or threat variants
altered by April of 2021 we noted the
emergence of something that we referred
to as the Patriot movement
and we focused on this specifically
because it presented
different threat components I will say
this we had concerns there was very very
little criminal activity there was
illegal activity and there were impacts
that we were facing
so through the summer of 2021 we noted
more and more of that activity
I will also say that other factors
occurred such as hate crime statistics
that were published in August of 2021 as
a result of that
we evolved our collection plan and
collaborated with our partners to focus
on what we consider to be the primary
threats
our findings our intelligence our
assessed information was produced to all
of our partners in the form of the
Hendon strategic intelligence reports
and I believe
that was going out at that time to about
32 agencies and it was going out to
approximately 200 individuals within
those agencies
thank you um if I could ask for document
OPP four zeros4571
and superintendent Morris
um I don't know if you can see that on
your screen is this a list of the Hendon
reports and who they were distributed to
yeah so I recall this list very
specifically on what you note in Blue uh
is a Hendon strategic intelligence
report or or situation report that was
disseminated what you note in white in
the first column on the left is a
teleconference because that was regular
as well and then we evolved our
dissemination we had our main Hendon
group on January 21st of 2021 our
commissioner commissioner Creek asked me
to begin to disseminate that
intelligence product to nine Police
Services the chiefs of the nine police
services to ensure that they were aware
so that's what you see in one column the
Hendon group in the next column where
you see the Highlight in yellow the
third column is a column I created
because of our geographical distribution
to keep the opp commanders aware and the
last column is our commissioner's
command team which consists of uh three
Deputy Commissioners and our
commissioner and those are all
individuals or groups who received the
hand in reports sorry that's correct
thank you and you also mentioned
teleconferences and so I'd just like to
bring up document opp401782
I believe this may be a list that you
put together as well is this a list of
all of the Hendon teleconferences during
this period
beginning on January 21st yes of 2022
that's correct okay
and roughly how how often were the the
teleconferences
only germane to this issue yes
um we held our first one on January 21st
and then on January 24th we completed
them daily I believe with one exception
okay and who from the Ops participated
in those teleconferences
okay so that's a difficult question to
answer
um but I will do my best we had a
dissemination list which was very large
as I've described at this point in time
I mean January 21st we had grown to
approximately 300 participants from the
Ottawa Police Service given that Hendon
had evolved since 2020 there were
multiple people on the distribution list
for the documents and that same list
received a request to participate in the
teleconference we could not go through
our entire list from Vancouver and
across Canada every time so we only knew
the people who identified as
participating I can say that the members
from Ottawa that showed great
consistency in their participation were
detective constables George Boris
detective Constable Steph Quinnell at
other times and I apologize I'm not
always aware of the rank I believe it's
staff sergeant Isabel Lemieux the
superintendents participated at time in
that case I mean Mark Patterson
inspector Ken Bryden there were other
people from events and intelligence that
participate at various times and we
would only know it specifically
by them self-identifying
thank you
um I want to take you to one of the
early Hendon reports it's opp401600
this is the Hendon report from Thursday
January 13th
um is this the first-handed report in
which the the idea of a convoy
approaching downtown Ottawa is mentioned
I'd like to make a point of
clarification here the simple answer is
yes but from August of 2021 to the end
of December 2021 there were regular
reports approximately one a week
the discussion about the possibility of
a galvanized effort to illustrate to
Ottawa some of the Grievances and the
possibilities of doing that via a convoy
was often discussed and was often in the
Hendon reports the events that were
planned
came to very little fruition I would say
or minimal fruition so it was discussed
it was commented upon the reports
previous to this
but in this report is the first
finite plan that says we are going to do
this and we are going to do it on these
dates
okay and so that information
um
I think it appears under key information
Point number one individuals within the
Patriot movement have undertaken to
organize through closed communication
channels and in-person networking
towards large-scale protest actions one
of these actions includes a commercial
truck work stoppage and Highway slowdown
scheduled for January 23rd information
shared through social media networks
indicates some of the participants of
this action may be mobilizing from
across the country to arrive in Ottawa
for a mass anti-government protest
calling for an end to all covid-19
mandates and is it fair to say that is
the that's the extent of uh poib's
knowledge at the time
but I think it's a little bit more
extensive
um than that but that's just a summation
provided for quick reference for people
who are reading the document
and if we can go down to the the bottom
of the of the page
um
it's a little bit small but meanwhile
the shift
the shift from the government appears to
have had little effect on the organizing
underway by members of the Patriot
movement who have taken to social media
advising truckers plan to carry out
their intended work stoppage
so as of January 13th was was poib
um of the view that there was going to
be a mass Convoy to Ottawa yes
and what were the the sources of this
early knowledge of the Convoy
so we had multiple investigative
techniques that we were employing
um so I could run through them one was
open source collection and I want to
stress that's information open so I put
a lesser value on that at the origin
Point
um also we had covert operations ongoing
which you won't see as related in the
documentation before you because of the
sensitivities
um we engaged in a large degree of
analysis and at times surveillance
operations and that's primary and Source
recruitment for covert operations that
information all of which is information
is collected and then we go through the
collation and Analysis process and then
we provide our analysis which I refer to
as intelligence and that is how we came
to the conclusions and assessments that
we did
okay and I want to take you to the next
Hendon report which is opp401028
and that one is dated uh Thursday
January 20th so at this point
superintendent uh the reports are being
published just on a weekly basis is that
correct that's correct okay
um and if you see the information and
the key information box there
number one the freedom Convoy 2022 and
operation bear hug will almost certainly
disrupt the movement of vehicular
traffic and goods on Canadian highways
and possibly at ports of Entry along the
border with the United States and then
point to some participants in these
convoys may attempt to disrupt the
business of government at both the
provincial and federal level by blocking
access to government legislators in
Parliament does that accurately
summarize the the risk as as poib
understood it
yes it does and if I can just add a
comment as a result of the information
we became aware of in early January as
reflected in the first report you showed
to me we stepped up our assignments our
taskings and our information collection
in order to produce more intelligence on
what we felt was a burgeoning
um
a burgeoning priority
okay and if I could take you now to page
three
there's a paragraph there further
redacted that there does not yet appear
to be an exit strategy for departing
Ottawa the intent appears to be to
remain in Ottawa until all covid-19
mandates and restrictions are lifted
um so what can you tell us about what
poib understood the timeline for this
protest to be as of the date of this
report which is January 20th
yeah it's an important question
um
for those not actively engaged in
intelligence operations there are knowns
and unknowns
um and we key in on those as
intelligence gaps so in this case the
fact that there was no exit strategy
but there were extensive demands being
placed and the fact that we felt those
demands could not be met it meant that
they meaning the protesters would be
there for a long period of time and I do
want to say this this might appear to be
anecdotal I refer to intelligence as
being engaged in acquiring Secrets or
Mysteries
their plans while in Ottawa were not a
secret that we couldn't discern the
plans while in Ottawa were a mystery
until they got there and I think that is
borne out by events
and I think we'll see some reports later
if we go to page four
um
towards the uh the bottom I believe so
there we go in addition to the convoys
themselves police of jurisdiction
resources could be stretched if rallies
are organized at the local level to
coincide with the arrival of the convoys
in a given community and so can you sort
of unpack that for us in terms of your
concern about the police of jurisdiction
sure
um so throughout kobit 19 and the
impacts of covid-19 and specifically
since I'll say the spring of 2021 the
growth of various movements and I want
to be clear on this
this is not one monolithic entity these
are Grassroots what I refer to as
Affinity groups that share grievances
they acted locally
and also tried to coalesce and I would
say that this was the first
successful coalescence so in doing so
the information that we were collecting
and the analysis that we were engaging
in to produce the intelligence
Illustrated that yes Ottawa would be the
culmination of this but there would be
other factors along the way and across
the country and specifically in relation
to
specific infrastructure like border
crossings and specifically in relation
to what we refer to as the business of
government so Queens Park and also
obviously Parliament that's what I mean
and discussion of plans to
exceed our resources and our capacity to
respond
okay and I'd like to ask you about the
uh the next paragraph which I believe
councilor Deans may have been taken to
you as well although the stated intent
of some Convoy participants is to remain
at Parliament Hill until the government
rescinds all covid-19 related
restrictions and mandates the school is
likely to prove unrealistic in the long
term however even a small number of
tractor trailers parked at Parliament
Hill will almost certainly be disruptive
in the short term so why did poib think
that it was unrealistic in the long term
and but extremely disruptive in the
short term yep I'm I'm thankful you
asked me that
they had certain demands we felt the
demands could not be met
but we believed it would be unlikely for
them to follow through on on the promise
to stay until the mandates were lifted
but we did think that it would be a long
term it's just that over the period of
time that would transpire people would
become frustrated people would need to
return home I want to be clear we felt
this would be
a long-term event
and when you say long term
um we're in January 20th when you say
long term what did you mean by long term
at that time we felt that they would
arrive on January 28th the 29th and we
were positioning ourselves to be
prepared for a longer term I don't know
that I had a specific idea in mind but
we were even beginning to schedule and
plan at that time for you know two weeks
three weeks a month Etc and we also
didn't know
um what the nature of negotiations or
discussion would be I.E in Thai and
ninega that occurred with multiple
levels of government so those things
would have impact as well but even at
this time we were talking about
scheduling to have relief Etc and we
were engaged in the opp within our major
Incident Management Group to be planning
between the various entities that engage
in that group
okay
um I'd like to take you next to the uh
the Hendon reports from Saturday January
22nd it's opp401603
and if we could go to page two when we
get there
under the assessment says it is almost
certain that the freedom Convoy will
disrupt the flow of traffic and goods
along Canadian roadways and at border
points
um
so and so how is it and why is it that
poip had concluded that that was that
was almost certain by January 22nd
because the information that we were
collecting from open sources and other
venues it was consistent that this is
what they intended to do
that's one point one of the critical
points in producing intelligence is the
reliability of the source
but also the validity of the information
in juxtaposition with all the other
information
um
traveling from British Columbia or Nova
Scotia to Ottawa
shows an incredible motivation and we
felt that it would be there for a long
period of time and we felt that for the
most part
the entities that were engaged in the
planning would follow through on what
they were saying
why did you feel that the the entities
engaged in the planning you mean the
organizers the Convoy organizers why did
you feel that they were going to follow
through
the pronouncements they made were in
Earnest I felt that they meant what they
said
um the Grievances and I want to stress
there were multiple grievances had been
expressed at this point for about 18
months we had seen expressions of those
grievances in multiple jurisdictions
throughout Ontario specifically
there were new factors that we took into
account the experiences that were faced
during the federal election Illustrated
that people were prepared to go to
further lights to illustrate
dissatisfaction
the experience with the incoming
passports that had occurred in relation
to covid-19 the impacts in the workplace
for some people and how some people
experienced that the vaccination I think
was called pediatric vaccination these
were all factors that for the people
involved for the people motivated
um
impacted their motivation and increased
their frustration and we believed that
they would follow through on what they
were saying they would do
and if we could scroll down on the page
there's a section called intelligence
gaps collection requirements can you
explain for us what uh what appears in
this section sure
um in any intelligence initiative you
create a collection plan
and when you satisfy the collection plan
then you feel you filled that Gap but
always you have gaps that are still
there the numbers
are always a gap like so for example
I've been asked a lot about the numbers
um
we couldn't possibly know what the
numbers would be because until that
given day we don't know how many people
will arrive what we could do and what we
did do was reach out to our colleagues
in the RCMP through the divisions to get
assessments of the numbers of people to
the extent they could the numbers of
vehicles to the extent they could and
specifically on tractor trailers the
types of vehicles the mood the behavior
etc etc so we were trying to determine
the size the impact of the protest
Etc
now that's for all now also in terms of
being armed I want to be clear on this
we had no
um we produced no intelligence to
indicate that these individuals would be
armed and there has been a lot of
hyperbole about that that was something
we wish to
in the
when people think about what happened in
January 6 2020 that is presence of mine
but we produce no intelligence to
indicate that that would be the case I
understand if we could go down I want to
go to the last two points in
intelligence gaps which are on the next
page if we just scroll up sorry the last
two points one is plan for any further
action should demands not be met and
plans for departing Ottawa so this is um
this is information that poib does not
have at that time
that's correct so uh if I could just use
I guess perhaps some of my experience
I've worked in undercover operations and
managed undercover operations in
entities that have significant
Grievances and in some of those
instances very specific plans are made
and followed through or not followed
through
apart from
stages music speeches
Etc we could see no specific plans for
actions of that type and
we believed because of the amalgamation
of affinity groups
there really was no specific plan in
relation to that it was a matter of we
call it being event driven and we'll see
what happens when we when we get there
Etc we had no expectation
that their demands would be met and so
we wondered if that would create
increased frustration and then we tried
to collect information to produce
Intelligence on how that frustration
might be borne out
thank you
um I want to take you to the Hendon
report for Monday January 24th now which
is
OPP four zeros one six zero eight
and I'll take you to page two under
assessment uh when we get there
so the first paragraph Convoy organizers
will almost certainly have minimal
ability to influence the behavior of
Convoy participants and protest
attendees why was that
um was that a concern and if so why was
that a concern
we were collecting information and
producing Intelligence on the organizers
that was a fast-moving atmosphere of
individuals that we didn't necessarily
know a lot about nor do they come from
our province
um so
those individuals may have a plan
probably a fairly loose plan but when a
large-scale
protest event
Etc occurs there will be a lot of
individuals or entities that attach
themselves to that to that protest
atmosphere and then they may engage in
activity that has absolutely nothing to
do with what the individuals who are
organizing the protest entertain so we
were collecting information which is
part of our normal operation about
Affinity groups or Associated entities
that may attach themselves to this
protest and trying to determine what
their actions may be
and did
um did POI take any additional steps
when it realized that the sort of Convoy
organizers weren't necessarily going to
have control over the participants
I can say that we had already taken
steps in terms of individual entities
that we were concerned about we already
had ongoing operations that would inform
us as to what was occurring in those
milieu and would they be engaged Etc
if we could pull up
opp401047 please
this is an email exchange
between yourself and Sebastian Tremblay
and I just want to go down to the bottom
of the first page
um
Sebastian writes you loved that you
asked the RCMP
to take some lead on their side to get
information from West and East I can't
believe that you had to ask though so
you tell can you tell me a bit about the
process of getting information from the
RCMP and and specifically what that
comment there was referring to
our collection plan for this issue
specifically
um needed to have the information on
numbers Vehicles mood
Etc that was emanating from several
different locations
at various times if I could just give an
example from BC on January 22nd but it's
not just BC Alberta Saskatchewan
Manitoba it's various locations also on
Route there were a number of many events
that occurred in Regina Medicine Hat
Winnipeg and I'm only speaking to the
West because that was the longest period
of time and we needed to get that
information and so we were reaching out
excuse me
um during the hand and calls to
basically create what we refer to as an
intelligence requirement for the um
divisions of intelligence in the RCMP uh
and and the reason Sebastian is
referring to it is we did the same thing
with the Serato Quebec
thank you
um if we could pull up the Hendon report
for Tuesday January 25th which is OPP
four zeros1609
and so here we're just to situate us
we're Tuesday uh before the sort of the
arrival of the convoys in Ottawa
um if we get on page one under
information those first three bullet
points I won't read them all but it
suggests that there's
uh 1200 trucks
coming the Regina Police said there were
1200 trucks coming there's another
unconfirmed information about 162 trucks
and a thousand private vehicles and this
will take Quebec uh says a thousand to
fifteen hundred trucks is it is it fair
to say that as of January 25th it was
anticipated that the Convoy would
involve thousands of trucks and vehicles
it's fair to say that the numbers would
be extensive and I would say in the
hundreds and the reason I say that is
this
a lot of the events in the western part
of the country were still a great
distance from Ottawa and may not come to
Ottawa and there were a lot of localized
events where people might just drive and
participate exuberantly yes but they
might only participate as far as
Winnipeg and and for us in the Ontario
Provincial Police we are cognizant
the drive from the Manitoba border to
Ottawa is like a 20-hour drive so we
could not
assess necessarily whether those truck
drivers or the drivers of private
Vehicles commercial vehicles would
continue in Quebec
much easier to do due to proximity when
Sebastian in Quebec and sorry Quebec
City in Montreal certainly though to
your point
we knew it would be in the hundreds and
we knew it would be significant and
there were multiple convoys because
that's the information coming at that
time from the West due to the distance
to be traveled
um
but there were multiple convoys from
within Ontario that just hadn't left yet
and I'd like to go down to page two of
this report into the second last bullet
and I just ask you about fundraising
um this it indicates that at this point
on the 25th the GoFundMe is at 4.4
million which is an increase of almost a
million dollars
in the last sort of 24 hours was this
something that Floyd was keeping an eye
on and concerned about
we were definitely keeping an eye on it
and here's why
for any type of event of this nature no
matter what the motivation is social
media has altered the way we collect
information and the meaning that we
derive from it
um
we can always significantly discount
some of the numbers that like it or say
they'll be there what we noticed in in
this event and in some other previous
events related to these grievances was
that there was much more
meaning in in the support and the reason
that the finances are so important is
money is a powerful motivator and this
was growing rapidly and I can say it was
growing at a rate that for us was
unprecedented and so that added impact
that added impact to our assessment that
this would be significant
and if you can just help me understand
was it concerned about what would what
the money would be used for or is it
that the money coming in is a reflection
that this is truly a there's there's
some widespread support for it and
that's concerning or is it both
I think it's both um we definitely felt
there was widespread support I mean I
realized that the narrative
um
going back to the spring of 2021 The
Narrative was that people who felt a
certain way
um
or a small number of people were Etc The
Fringe so to speak
um
this was difficult for us to deal with
in policing in Ontario specifically
because there was a large degree of
support and there were not were a number
of instances so it spoke to that support
that's one thing and yes how the money
would be utilized there were a lot of
ways we knew the money would be utilized
and our information said Fuel
and Logistics
Etc we didn't know all the factors but
it the biggest takeaway from the money
was the degree of support and the means
that would be in possession to make it
more long-term even for things such as
accommodations
if we could go down I just want to ask
you about the last paragraph under
assessment
the lack of information related to the
opp about events in Ottawa During the
period uh from January 28th to the 29th
and on January 30th represents a serious
intelligence Gap information provided to
the opp to date indicates a high degree
of planning for the protest and
Communications appear to have been open
between the opp and Convoy organizers it
is unknown why the details for these
time frames would not be shared with
police attempts should be made to obtain
this information
why like why weren't you able to
get that information out of the Convoy
organizers if there was a kind of good
rapport with the with the PLT or
undercover officers
I think the answer is quite simple
because there was no major definitive
plan the the organizing went into the
Convoy the transport the participation
but the event
what would actually transpire
um was less organized and I would say
that in my experience
that isn't that unusual
and so uh we're now it's Tuesday January
25th by this date what was uh poib's
expectation about how long this would
last
well it's I can't give a day I can say
this
we saw
significant support
we saw significant fundraising
in real terms we saw that play out in
significant numbers of people and
significant significant numbers of
commercial vehicles and private support
in fact our information from coming
across western Canada was not only that
it was almost unanimous in our calls
that there were people lined up on the
sides of Highways and on overpasses and
we even got to the point of talking
about inclement weather that people were
there and we were quite surprised so we
felt it would be a significant event
and it would be a long-term event
specifically because
the demands could not be met and the
promise was to stay until they were met
so I'm gonna I'm gonna
put my long-term question to you again
because I don't know that I got a an
answer but when you say long term do you
mean I mean it's not just the weekend
it's a week it's two weeks possibly
three weeks what do you mean by long
term oh certainly certainly a couple
weeks three weeks I mean there's just so
many variables after a plan meets a
response that I I can't speak to that
and I didn't know what the plan of the
Ottawa Police Service was
um so certain when I say long term I'm
going to say you know
certainly a week probably two weeks Etc
okay and
um
why isn't it that it was ever spelled
out in that degree of specificity in the
Hendon reports to say these people might
stay for two weeks or three weeks or
four weeks
yeah it's a good point and and perhaps
that's something we can take away to
improve our products in the future
um
these are strategic intelligence reports
there were other products that were
provided that were operational and
tactical in nature we felt that we were
stating that this will be a significant
event and a long-term event but we
didn't
say the number of days and I I can't
I played this back in my mind in terms
of knowing what I know today what would
I say if I could put myself back on
January 25th to use an example and I
would basically
say say what we said
but I don't know that I could have put a
day to it
understand
um if we could pull up OPP
four zeros one six one two
this is I believe a situational
awareness bulletin for the freedom
Convoy
so who would have received this
superintendent
so these are
um documents that we create and put out
to our Frontline officers so that they
are aware of what's occurring and so all
and there may be an officer safety
component it may just be informational
but we also have a vested interest it's
a way to collect information so this
document
absolutely would have gone to every
member of the Ontario Provincial Police
and I have an independent recollection
that this document was sent with our
Hendon report to our recipients so in so
saying that would go to approximately 32
Services as well
we also provided it to the criminal
intelligence Services of Ontario so it
could be further disseminated so it was
disseminated broadly and it would have
been up to those other agencies to
disseminate it to their officers if they
chose to right they could utilize it in
any way they could parade briefings
shift briefings Etc or dissemination
okay and if we look at the second
paragraph under background
I won't read that whole thing but this
is uh this is generally poib's
understanding as of January 26th that
there's no Express departure date for
when participants will disperse or the
action will end
that's correct
did
um on the Hendon teleconferences did you
or anyone from poib
specifically say you know take the next
step and say
so you should be preparing for a
two-week protest a three-week protest a
four-week protest
we talked about it being long-term we
talked about the logistical capacity of
the entities involved we talked about
the degree of grievances most of the
discussion was involved in collecting
just to give you I would do an overview
and introduce it and say what the
pertinent issues were for the day in
terms of information collection and
intelligence production
then our inspector Brian Barkley who was
our case manager would have an
analytical overview provided by our
Elite analysts strategically and
tactically and then we would go to the
other entities in basically an order of
primary importance Ottawa Police Service
being key the RCMP being key and the
serotated Quebec being key and then we
would do a round table for everybody's
input Etc
certainly we discussed this being long
term
um and how we what intelligence
requirements we would have in order to
be helpful we recognized that the Ottawa
Police Service was our primary client
there's only a few points in time over
this period of time up roughly up to
February 20th where the clients alter to
Toronto Police Service Etc
Ottawa is and the Windsor Police Service
if we could pull up
OPP four zeros one six one one which is
the Hendon report for the next day uh
Thursday January 27th
and on the front of this Hendon report
there's a list of convoys
and it a number of them I mean one the
first one has 471 but many of them have
a TBD why is that
um
so
there's some
I noticed that we were being pressed for
numbers and at this point I reached out
to our indigenous policing Bureau and
that may seem strange to some people who
are listening but our indigenous
policing Bureau houses our provincial
liaison teams and our Prince provincial
liaison teams are interlocutors to
organizers to truck drivers to all the
people responsible for running the
protest and they had established
relationships so they were the
individuals who were providing the
numbers because they were there to
observe them and stay in one place to do
that so at the start it was difficult
and I believe in some of the cases there
was really difficult weather Etc so we
made a clear delineation about who would
be responsible for which tasks so on
this case I'm sorry what what is the
date of that uh January 27th okay so
that's why the numbers weren't there on
on that
that point in time
did did POI extrapolate or have any kind
of estimate of the numbers as of that
date whereas this is the best best
estimate there is I think in our
assessments we said you know it's going
to be significant like in the hundreds
okay if we could go down to uh page
could I just make a point I just
a lot of your questions have to do with
preparation and the purpose of
intelligence I just want to explain my
mindset
um
and I this might seem anecdotal but it's
important to me uh intelligence is made
up of two words in Terror and legare and
um in Latin that means to choose between
so I really see it as our job as the
intelligence Bureau
um in so much as the Police Service Act
permits us to help police of
jurisdiction in in specialized services
to inform decision making to allow them
to choose between operational courses of
action in their preparation so that's
how
that's the premise under which we were
working
see
um if we could go down to uh yeah sorry
to the bottom of page four
uh the first paragraph there it is
highly unlikely that heavy machinery
would be transported in the Convoy if
there was no intent to use it or if some
individuals in the Convoy did not
anticipate that it would be needed what
can you tell us about the risk of heavy
machinery and what steps uh poib took to
to gather that information
right so this is a key component
um I'd have to put you in the mindset of
the Ontario Provincial Police at this
point in terms of large-scale critical
incidents and protests
um McKenzie Meadows occupation which
occurred in close proximity to Six
Nations for which there was an
injunction uh in September of 2020 was
something that we were contemplating at
this time there was the theft of some
large-scale heavy machinery and the use
of that heavy machinery to tear up roads
and impact Rail lines and to threaten
critical infrastructure such as gas
lines Etc so that was something that was
heavy on our minds at the time we had no
intelligence to indicate what the use of
that heavy machinery would be be it
compressors be it tractors Etc apart
from some in relation to snow clearing
for the purposes of parking so that was
a key thing that we were trying to
determine because
the inductive leap there is why bring
the equipment if you have no intent to
utilize it
what kind of heavy equipment did did you
see there were like on the back of flat
beds there was a large compressor there
were all terrain vehicles and I'm I'm
sorry I don't know these I mean a very
very large like a monster truck type
all-terrain vehicle and then there were
um there was equipment that could be
utilized for digging Etc
if we could go to the next Hendon report
it's OPP
five zeros eight one five and this is
the report for Friday January 28th
and it's got a an updated list
of Convoy numbers up the front
and so
um
by the next day essentially you've got
some more information about convoys
coming descending upon Ottawa
and can you just explain for us what CMV
and pmvr
yeah commercial motor vehicles and
personal motor vehicles and the
rationale for the delineation is that
large-scale commercial Motor Vehicles
would be consistent with the intentions
of the organizers and also more
detrimental uh and more more impactful
in terms of impeding the business of
government in downtown Ottawa
okay and and the number uh has jumped
from 500 and something the day before
now there's over 1300 vehicles that are
sort of confirmed was that concerning to
poib yeah absolutely it was concerning
I mean just from a planning perspective
what I'm what this is causing
this puts me in a hard spot because I'm
not in the Ottawa Police Service but if
I I was a Detachment commander in
Aurelia and if I was facing the
situation you're saying to yourself
where are these trucks planning to go
and how will we house this how will we
manage this and
at a certain point the numbers become
irrelevant because once you surpass a
certain number
it basically becomes impossible
and did you know where the trucks were
planning to go or where Ops was planning
to put the trucks at this point
no I was not involved in Ops planning
if we could go down to page seven
before we get there just
um were you concerned
about what was being done with this
information sort of in the the week
leading up and the Hendon reports we've
just looked at were you concerned you
just told us you weren't involved in the
planning but were you concerned that
planning wasn't being based on the
reports at all
well I'll be blind I wouldn't know if
the planning was being based on the
reports
um we have an expression often in
policing that you stay within your lane
um and so my Lane pardoned upon my Lane
is intelligence and my goal as I saw it
was to produce intelligence to assist in
decision making both to the Ontario
Provincial Police and to
the Ottawa Police Service was which is
what I was attempting to do I was
involved in planning as I've mentioned
in the Ontario Provincial Police we kept
we created the major Incident Management
Group and so we were having discussions
about that as it would impact
other jurisdictions including and most
specifically including our own
okay
um and so just just for clarity Did You
observe anything that caused you to
believe that the intelligence wasn't
being actioned on the Ops planning side
no I I yeah I didn't see Ottawa Police
Service planning I assumed they were
planning I now know information I didn't
in terms of other people's witness
statements I assumed they were planning
Ottawa as a very experienced Police
Service and has dealt with many of these
events uh so I I knew that they would be
planning and utilizing that information
okay if we could go down to the bottom
of page seven there's uh under
assessment the first paragraph
the available information indicates that
the protesters plan to remain in Ottawa
at least until February 4th we continue
to identify indicators to support at
least some protesters remaining beyond
the weekend of the 29th and 30th these
indicators include collecting donations
of cash food and water from supporters
when when was the February 4th date
Chosen and how was that date arrived at
I can't recall specifically why February
4th was said but I believe it was the
collection or capturing of Open Source
information that cited February 4th but
I'll say again
that would have only been from one
entity of many and so for me personally
um the dates
are less important than the fact that
there was going to be significance and
Longevity to the event
right if I could just use an example
um I I know you're asking a lot about
that and it's important question in
other events such as Toronto both on the
5th of February and the 12th of February
in that case we had definitive
information about timing from the events
we will not be there for long it will be
this long Etc we will not stay
um I'd like to take you to the the
Saturday January 29th Hendon report
which is OPP four zeros1614
and so this uh this is the first day
essentially of the the planned
protesting some of the convoys arrived
the day before but this is the first day
and if we go down to page three under
the assessment
there's a bolded paragraph or a sentence
sorry the protest in Ottawa has the
potential to pose a real Public Safety
and officer safety threat and so can you
unpack that for us and tell us why you
had why poib had made that conclusion
um on day one of the the protest
yep just
with the numbers that were there and the
Grievances that were possessed we felt
that there was the potential for a
public safety threat and an officer
safety threat due to the role that
police officers are put into in these
situations there was specifically a
great deal of frustration in the
province of Ontario with police services
in Ontario enforcing the reopening
Ontario act because a lot of people and
some people who are philosophically
supportive of that side felt that it
wasn't our role and that even the fact
that it was unjust and unconstitutional
and that would Elevate the threat posed
by some people towards towards the
police
and so I guess what can you tell us
about was that just a worry or were you
actually seeing sort of
threatening or aggressive behavior right
at the outset
so first coming across Canada and I'm
going to speak bluntly but
I have to say that I'm trying to be
blunt but I I don't have all the facts
in relation to this there was
almost no reported criminal activity
of any of this activity coming across
Canada
um
there was a motor vehicle collision on
the day before the event and that had to
do with somebody running into somebody
who was in the freedom Convoy so it was
conspicuous
for the absolute lack of criminal
activity
um
so
we were concerned because when a plan
meets
a counter plan
we didn't know what would transpire we
were also concerned in large cities such
as Ottawa such as Toronto protests
attract a multitude of elements who may
have absolutely nothing to do with the
protest there's been a lot made of
extremists Etc that's a difficult word
for me because it doesn't really have a
definition in law and it's very
subjective but even individuals with an
individual agenda sometimes I refer to
it as an independent asymmetric threat
in the vernacular Lone Wolf that's the
type of thing that we were more
concerned about
got it
if we could go to the the next day's
Hendon report or sorry Tuesday February
1st not the next day um OPP four Zero's
one six one seven
and if we could go down to page four
let me get there
at the bottom
we are unable to confirm a potential
second Convoy that may travel to Ottawa
from western Canada we continue to
monitor this issue closely we also
continue to monitor the blockade at the
Canada U.S border in Alberta the
strategy for managing or resolving this
blockade is highly likely to have
repercussions in Ontario you tell us why
poib saw them as related and why
managing one would have repercussions in
the other sure
um
we in the Ontario Provincial Police
we've come to call this the elastic
effect when you deal with a specific
event in a specific Locale the dealing
of that the dealing with that event will
immediately lead to
um a flurry of social media some true
some not and that information
that emanates will have an impact so
we've experienced that with a large
degree of protests elsewhere we
experience that in G8 and G20 we've
experienced that with indigenous
critical incidents so whenever we go to
take an action in a location we do a
strategic intelligence assessment to try
to ascertain what the impact of that
action will have so to be very specific
to this if the Arsen if the RCMP took
action On the Border in Alberta and if
the individuals in Alberta or the
individual entities were closely
connected to people in the Ottawa then
there would be an impact
and so let me ask you did
um having been in charge of intelligence
for Hendon throughout this Did You
observe that at any point
sorry did I observe what did You observe
um a sort of reaction in one part of the
country to some sort of enforcement
action in a different part of the
country yeah so just please recall that
Hendon wasn't all about this threat
variant so Hendon actually came to
fruition as a result of the enforcement
action in British Columbia in relation
to the wet saweton having immediate and
apparent ramifications in tie Indonesia
for uh three weeks and then in the area
of Six Nations for like a month and then
in the area of Six Nations again in
Caledonia Mackenzie Meadows for a period
of months so
significantly yes in relation to this
activity yes the publications of
enforcement in relation to the reopening
Ontario act LED at times to other
activity and other protests I remember
um specifically events in the Toronto
that had to do with certain restaurants
acting in defiance of the reopening
Ontario act
um
having an impact in relation to protest
so that is why Coots Alberta was was
important to us and I should also say
that at this point and from January 29th
on our lens and our collection had
evolved significantly from January 29th
on and every day until the fruition the
Ontario Provincial Police with the
permission of the Ottawa Police Service
was engaged on ground in a covert
capacity to collect information about
all the things that we'd be interested
in in terms of mood tenor plans Etc
um I'd like to go to the Hendon report
OPP four
zeros1619 this is from Thursday February
3rd
and when we're there if we can go to
page five under the combined assessment
heading
the ongoing truck blockades in Ottawa
and Coots Alberta have the potential to
develop into a national Civil
Disobedience movement that could extend
to Maritime transportation and
potentially other major transportation
sections
it is highly likely that new convoys
blockades and protests in support of the
Ottawa blockade will occur in Ontario
for the foreseeable future and will
strain law enforcement resources and so
can you tell us why you thought or why
the term National Civil Disobedience
movement was chosen here
yes Civil Disobedience or direct action
or terms we use for
um
for protests when it pushes Beyond
totally lawful descent like entirely
lawful descent and given that we had a
great deal of online rhetoric requesting
act if you cannot travel here act
locally and we had organic movements
communicating that they would do things
in certain locations I know right near
General headquarters in Aurelia and
Berry there was an organic growth of a
group that would engage in low-scale
Civil Disobedience on highways so we
certainly saw
growth in this regard and Hendon every
day talked about and these reports
um tracked what activity was occurring
and what locales and there was an
extensive amount so much so that some
things we just didn't look at because it
was sort of not below our radar but
below the threshold of what we would
engage ourselves in I know that there
was information
collected in relation to Maritime
Transportation so we were concerned
about different ports in Vancouver and
on the east coast and we were certainly
concerned about border crossings because
we had collected information to that
regard
um and and let me ask you about this
sort of foreseeable future prediction
because a few days earlier there was the
February fourth date in the Hendon
report now we're February 3rd the day
before uh and the report is saying these
will continue for the foreseeable future
why is that
the Grievances still exist
and the people aren't changing and
they're not achieving their goals of
ending mandates
um and and several other factors so we
felt that they would we felt that they
would continue and I'll be honest here
too like I have to say
a lot of this stems from pandemic
legislation and grieving but there were
a raft of grievances involved here some
I would say is anti-authoritarian some
may have had to do with Firearms
legislation some had to do with oil and
gas prices there were a multitude of
grievances
um that people
possessed some was specific to
individuals such as the prime minister
or the federal government so there are a
multitude of grievances occurring some
were specific to our Premier Premier
fort
um I won't I won't pull it up but the
Friday uh February 4th Hendon report
has a section about the protesters
Gathering intelligence their own
intelligence and sort of publishing it
online what can you tell us about that
that's a fairly common event if I could
go back to even the G8 and G20 and
canonaskus and the G8 and G20
um in um
Huntsville area in Toronto uh
entities of various Natures create a
security culture and collect information
and produce intelligence reports
um and that is how they maintain their
own security
and their various skill sets and I would
say the skill sets in this entity uh
were fairly significant especially with
some of the individuals so they produced
intelligence documentation in terms of
what they anticipated law enforcement
techniques Etc negotiating processes so
it was something that we were going
through
okay
um I'd like there was also sorry I
should say one other thing there was
also information collected that they
some of the individuals involved were
looking for quote-unquote infiltrators
because of course they would be
cognizant I would think they would be
cognizant that there would be undercover
operators collecting information during
the protest
I'd like to take you to uh the Henry
report for Sunday February 6th which is
opp401622
and if we can go down to the assessment
section
um
paragraphs four and five so just down a
little bit more uh I won't read them out
but it talks about support from public
officials or other influential figures
having an effect on the protests and I'm
wondering if you can speak to that in
terms of what you saw from an
intelligence perspective
yeah I would say that for any protest of
this type and I mean various types of
protests
um
they're primarily made up of
um Regular citizens and they're looking
for a form of legitimacy and then in the
media they are
presented in very different light
depending upon the nature of the media
whether it's news reporting or
editorializing but by and large they're
looking for
um legitimacy
so um and I'm not casting a judgment on
this but when they receive legitimacy
whether it's an indigenous issue in Tai
Indonesia based upon past grievances
residential schools or whether it's a a
freedom Convoy issue in Ottawa based
upon perceptions of civil liberties and
constitutional rights they become
emboldened because they feel themselves
to be legitimate already and when
they're lent legitimacy they feel
emboldened
thank you and they communicate to that
effect that's part of the strategy
um I want to take us to the next day's
Hendon report OPP
four zeros one six two three
and under uh assessment on page five
sorry I lose track of the date what okay
this is seven Monday February 7th so
we're past the sort of second weekend of
uh of the protest in Ottawa
um and so the assessment the first
paragraph the situation in Ottawa
remains volatile and represents a public
safety threat an officer safety threat
and potentially a national security
threat the available information
suggests that the blockade has ample
moral logistical and financial support
to remain in place long term
why did it use the phrase national
security threat yeah it's a great
question it's one I anticipated and it's
one that on that day we had a great deal
of discussion about why
we put in that there was a potential
national security threat because of the
movement to the borders and specifically
to the ambassador to the Ambassador
Bridge the
apparent long-term capacity for the
protesters to stay in place in Ottawa
the ongoing calls for actions elsewhere
the events in Coots and the movement to
the Ambassador Bridge and discussion of
the tunnel the Ambassador Bridge
specifically because I I believe it has
the largest sort of Exchange in terms of
financial
um like a dollar value in our country so
that is why we put that in in terms of a
potential I will say
um I I spoke about that with colleagues
from the Canadian Security intelligence
service and with the integrated National
Security enforcement team and they did
not see things that reach their
threshold in terms of what would be
deemed a threat to the security of
Canada so we were an anomaly in that
regard but we phrased it as a potential
and so you beat me to it but I'll take
you to an email where you reference that
it's OPP four zeros1038
this is an email from yourself to Jim
Walker and Brian Barclay
uh would and just after midnight on on
February 8th so
just after you've published
um
this hinden report on the seventh if we
can scroll down
uh at the bottom
Point number five in terms of National
Security the wording and Hendon
assessment concerned me slightly I agree
with the potential for officer safety
and Public Safety but inset and csis
concur there are no National Security
concerns confirmed today if we have
access to something they don't we can
meet them to discuss but I'm not aware
of it
um and so what is it
again from your discussions with them
what were their concerns about your use
of the word national security threat
sorry okay I just want to be clear they
weren't concerned about me utilizing it
I
want it to be certain that we were using
the best terminology we could in a very
fluid situation so
when this information is collected
um
our analysts are I use the phrase
drinking from a fire hose in some
regards and trying to produce
intelligence under tight timelines so
they came to the determination that
there were potential National Security
threats I reviewed the report and we had
inspectors Barkley and Walker and I
significant discussions about it and
it's why I reached out to my colleagues
I became content with the phrasing that
it was a potential and the day I was
also content with their assessment
um I want to take you to the next day's
Henry report February 8th which is OPP
four zeros one six two four
and we'll go to page four when we get
there under the assessment section
so the situation in Ottawa remains
volatile and represents a public safety
threat and an officer safety threat and
then the last
uh sentence in that paragraph as such
the ongoing series of protests and
blockades represents a Potential Threat
to Canada's sovereignty and National
Security is that can you sort of compare
us compare for us the language from the
February 7th report to the one here on
February 8th I think in essence it means
the same thing that we have a potential
concern in terms of sovereignty in our
border crossings and our economic
Integrity in terms of trade
um and National Security in that regard
it might also have to do with the
analytical assessments of threat to
reputation by virtue of um
coverage in the international media of
what was transpiring in Canada
yep
and do you feel that that
um
that that assessment was accurate at the
time that it was a potential threat to
the sovereignty and National Security
I agreed with the fact that it had
potential to be so
uh if we could pull up OPP four
zeros1837
these are meeting minutes
um
I think they're dated February 11th I
believe the meeting may have occurred a
couple of days earlier this is an early
integrated planning cell I've never seen
this document I did have a meeting with
the integrated planning cell wasn't when
it was initiated
um
so I'm going to say yes I just not
familiar with the document okay and if
we could go down
I believe just to be clear I was
contacted by then Chief superintendent
party of the Ontario Provincial Police
and he was contacting me together with I
believe a chief superintendent from the
RCMP Lou and they were
in discussions about the creation of a
joint planning cell and integrated
planning cell and um
and I offered to them an intelligence
briefing I believe that's what this is
about okay
um and if we go down to page four
there's a um
something that's attributed to you
superintendent Morris PLT framework has
been excellent in the past we have a
significant portion of this event
proper messaging and options in the form
of negotiation could occur this could
dissipate Chief superintendent party
agreed meeting with Chief slowly at noon
today and will be stressing the need for
a plan and an overview we need to come
to terms with what the intelligence
really is versus what is perceived I
want to ask you about that last part if
you remember sort of yeah so this is a
bit difficult because these aren't my
notes okay so um I was discussing
provincial liaison teams and I believe
that they are an absolutely
excellent source uh sorry
they're an excellent aspect to two-way
communication and events of this type so
they can communicate the situation to
people who are engaging in terms of
perhaps what Jeopardy they may be in
what consequences they may face and also
lead towards negotiated Solutions so
that's a very positive thing that we'd
utilized in the past if it's done if
it's done properly that was my component
of this in terms of the meeting with
Chief slowly at noon that's not me
that's um that's Chief superintendent
party I know that we discussed the
intelligence with Chief party and there
were other I'm sorry I didn't look at
the list I had my entire intelligence
management team to give a complete
overview Chief party was of the opinion
that the planning wasn't
intelligence-led and so he wanted to
have a discussion of that with with the
city sorry with Ottawa Police Service
okay
um if we could go to OPP four
zeros1158 this is an email that you sent
on the same day so or sorry it's on
February 10th the next day
and you've sent it to
um Mark Patterson who was Mark Patterson
I'm Mark Patterson uh was the
superintendent of the Ottawa Police
Service intelligence directorate
um we were notified of that in January
early January
okay and you've copied
Chuck Cox and Brian Barclay of your uh
the opp and Ken Brighton who is he uh
Ken Bryden was the inspector of the
Ottawa Police Service intelligence
director and report it to uh Mark
Patterson okay and I don't need you to
sort of read out the whole email but
perhaps if the hearing Claire can kind
of scroll through and you can skim it
and I just want to ask you why you sent
this email at this point in time
sorry my eyes aren't the best I'm trying
to keep up um uh yeah okay so uh I began
giving I was requested by commissioner
Creek and superintendent McDonald of the
opp to provide intelligence briefings to
what were referred to as the Big 12
meaning the Big 12 Services of Ontario
the chiefs of police
um I I did so
um
and following that
briefing uh
there's parts of this that don't involve
me so I believe detective Constable
Stefan Quinnell of the Ottawa Police
Service sent an email to inspector
Barkley of the opp and that email
stipulated that Chief slowly wished to
have every Hendon report since it's
since its Inception
and I was surprised by that request
because the Ottawa Police Service did
have every hand in report since its
Inception and chief slowly himself had
received every henon report since
January 1st of
2021 so for over a year and so
we were very very engaged in a lot of
operations and Analysis and I didn't
want people to be looking for reports to
disseminate for the course of
what was almost two years at that point
when the Police Service already
possessed them and
they weren't relevant uh the Hendon
reports in February of 2020 were not
relevant to the situation at hand so I
was explaining this to Mark Patterson so
that he could deal with it internally in
in the Ottawa Police Service and did you
understand why
um
someone on your team was being asked to
put all this information together
I referenced Hendon in my report to the
Big 12 and gave a background on it and
all of the people who participated
um they their services were
participating in Hendon
um it surprised me that we got that
request
because I would have thought they would
have already known and had their reports
so that's why I was very specific in my
response and told Mark all the things
that had been going on including
providing an extra
company and um Chief slowly asked you
directly for some information at some
point is that correct
yeah uh so I'm sorry I don't have my
notebook yet but anyways I believe it
was on February 11th it was a Friday I
believe it was Friday February 11th and
so that was a a briefing that I provided
to the Big 12 again I want to be clear
on this I can't tell you how many people
were on that call but they were Chiefs
of police there were definitely more
than 12.
um and I had been asked to provide this
and it was I think it occurred seven
times
so
I was asked to provide
I believe I had five questions and they
pertained to four Geographic locales so
the locales were the city of Ottawa
the city of Toronto
city of Windsor
and Sarnia slash
the 402 just outside of Sarnia and OBP
jurisdiction that was the four locales
the questions to the best I can I think
I should be able to remember I I could
pull up a document if you'd like okay I
wouldn't do that I do recall them if we
can pull up Ops
um three zeros one zero four one one
this I believe is an email
it's a forward of your email that you
ultimately sent answering the question
so if we could just scroll down
to the body of your email
I think next the next page
there it is
um
these are these the five questions that
Chief slowly asked you to to answer yeah
yeah that's correct and if we can just
scroll down
um if we stop there that he he clarified
that he wished the answers to be
provided by confirmed intelligence not
aspirational information what what did
you understand that to mean
well what I understood it to mean is the
best information possible but he was
very clear in articulating only
confirmed intelligence
um and that's problematic in that
you receive information
you produce intelligence
intelligence is not
necessarily always factual it's an
assessment and I certainly cannot
provide
confirmation of a quantitative Factor
about the future
so in terms of I only want confirmed
intelligence of the number of people in
a location in the future
intelligence trade craft or any
tradecraft could not possibly provide
that
um and had you had this request
previously in the LA in the last two
weeks before this or was this the first
time you were you had faced this request
no that was the first time we had the
request
uh and was it unusual for the chief of
police of a sort of different police
force to ask you for this kind of
information
yeah I've never experienced it before
um I found it unusual
um and one thing that I
perhaps found unusual is that generally
the chief of police
is trying to ascertain information or
intelligence about their jurisdiction
and you know the Ontario Provincial
Police or the RCMP may be different in
that regard but not about the exact
number of protesters on Highway 402 in
Sarnia in the future
and I understand uh the next day so that
puts us at Saturday February 12th you
gave a presentation to the oacp do you
remember
that
yes so yeah sorry there are two
presentations so just for clarity I
there were a lot of briefings that I was
asked to provide
um the Ontario Association of chiefs of
police had formulated a um a planning
entity our lead in that regard was a
superintendent Mike mcdonell and
superintendent Dan alakis so I would
provide briefings on what was
transpiring in multiple jurisdictions
and what I felt would occur in those
locations and the specific purpose of
that was that the various Police
Services could then make decisions about
the dispersal of uniform resources be
they
uniform resources or public order units
soft tack hard tech in terms of that so
that's
the oacp meeting
right and you attended one on the 12th
um
and I believe Chief slowly was there
correct
yeah so that meeting occurred later in
the evening of the 12th
um I know it was set for 1900 hours and
it may have been delayed and that's the
so-called Big 12 meeting which is a
different meeting than the oacp okay and
can you tell us about what happened at
that meeting
I was asked
um by the OPP commissioner karik to
provide an intelligence overview I have
to say that on that day
um
for Thursday and Friday I'm sorry I'm
going by memory the 10th and 11th
um there were multiple priorities so the
Convoy protesters or
the leadership of several segments we're
planning to
not move the entire protest but to make
a show of a protest in Toronto and
specifically at Queen's Park
so I created and my team created a
separate collection plan in an
operational plan to assist the Toronto
Police Service and it involved multiple
entities I mean Police Services because
there were multiple rallying points and
we were dispersing our intelligence
Personnel to go to the rallying points
to collect the information to produce
the intelligence for Toronto in real
time in their Incident Command Center
major event center Etc
that protest was to have occurred and
did occur on Saturday the 12th so the
meeting you're referring to occurred
after that
so I gave an intelligence overview
of what was transpiring across the
province obviously Toronto
um the events in Toronto played a
significant component or took up a
significant component of that
um
Chief slowly
um
was not happy with the briefing or the
presentation
he made
his displeasure
evident
and um
and articulated that he didn't like
comparisons
between Toronto and Ottawa
and and then spoke about Hendon
basically about the Ontario Provincial
Police
um not fulfilling their intelligence
mandate to us to assist Police Services
of jurisdiction and that he and his
I don't want to misspeak uh
I'm going to say his team but he
referred to a scribe and he referred to
a lawyer that were present
um which surprised me I never
encountered that before in an
intelligence briefing either
um had had reviewed the Hendon reports
and there was nothing
I don't know what his word was so I
don't nothing of value or nothing of
significance or nothing that could have
assisted them
and so the the meeting I mean it was
difficult our commissioner intervened
and we ended up having a uh a separate
discussion between commissioner this is
all virtual uh between commissioner
karik myself and Deputy Commissioner
Chuck Cox
and what was your view of uh Chief
slowly's assessment of the the Hendon
reports
well
I completely disagree I'll use the terms
interior and legary I believe we
provided uh I believe that a Discerning
read of the intelligence products
throughout the fall of 2021 and
certainly from the 13th of January in
2022 and then with the teleconferences
with the Ottawa Police Service
participated in and the intelligence
products that had been produced daily
since that period of time leading to on
this date February 12th
said that there will be a significant
event in Ottawa it will begin on the
28th or 29th of January it will
incorporate large groups of motivated
people who are protesting these are
their grievances it will incorporate
large use of commercial Motor Vehicles
tractor trailers their intention is to
impede the business of government and to
be in the downtown area we use
terminology like gridlock we said there
was no exit strategy and their demands
could not be met and it would be
significant and there would be other
calls for resources because there would
be other events I believe
I did say to him there's no golden key
like sometimes when people look for a
product an intelligence product it's
like a golden key that will answer
absolutely everything
um intelligence is designed
to inform
decision making
I believe that our information collected
and our intelligence produced from our
entire partnership
or instrumental in informing decision
making about what would occur so
I disagree
what I did say
that in terms of his displeasure with
the what he referred to as a comparison
of Toronto and Ottawa
one of the issues is
sometimes in planning people fail to
appreciate an event that hasn't occurred
yet I call it a deference of the
important for the Urgent when Toronto
acted Toronto
had the benefit of the experience in
Ottawa to say yeah this is a big deal
this is really going to happen
um so I I agree I agree with that and I
did also tell him
that he and the Ottawa Police Service
were faced with a difficult situation
100 I totally agree with that
um I want to ask you about one one last
document and then I'll be done which is
the the hinden report from Monday
February 14th the day uh the emergencies
Act was invoked it's opp401630
if we can go to page six
there's a bolded paragraph the situation
in Ontario remains volatile protesters
and their supporters are unlikely to be
significantly deterred by any invocation
of the emergencies act the potential for
conflict or an act of violence is likely
increasing as the Ottawa blockade
continues
Why did
um
conclude that the Act was unlikely to
deter the protesters and actually that
violence was likely to increase
from a philosophical or ideological
perspective many of the Grievances
believe that the legislation that was
being passed during covid-19 was
unconstitutional and unjust and that the
restrictions on their freedoms were
resultingly unjust
so new legislation being passed
um
was a self-fulfilling prophecy I mean
some people on one side of the coin call
it a conspiracy theorist
there's a conspiracy theory that they're
going to invoke the emergencies Act
so when the emergency Act is invoked it
impacts the people who feel that way
and it aggravates their perspective and
creates more frustration
so
the people who are engaged in the
protests did not believe that the
emergencies act should be invoked did
not believe government should have more
powers and police should have more
Powers so
they're seen in their from their
perspective
the correctness of their stance
uh thank you superintendent Morris those
are my questions
thank you I we're going to keep going if
you're up to it and if so
I take it you are up to it okay so we're
going to take a 15-minute break so that
you can
load up with water or whatever and come
back and we'll go through the
cross-examinations
okay 15 minutes
the commission and recess for 15 minutes
all right
order a lot
the Commissioners we can win the
commissioner
okay welcome back
um first up is the Ottawa Police Service
good evening superintendent Morris how
are you hi I'm David mitchikovsky I'm a
lawyer for the Ottawa Police Service
um I understand
um that the opp has quite a bit of
experience dealing with protests over
the years yes that's correct
and some of the protests I take it would
have been successfully handled some have
resulted in some public criticism of
OPP's role
yes that's correct
for instance if we go back hip or wash
and Dudley George were notorious
examples of where things went wrong and
then I understand in 2013 the opp was
also subject to much criticism I'm not
saying merited but criticism for how it
responded to the idol no more protests
is that right
I'm not aware of the criticism in
relation to I don't know more but
that is certainly possible well I I seem
to recall that there was criticism of
the opp for not ending blockades of rail
arteries at the time and injunctions had
been issued the is that coming back to
you I do I do recall that criticism yes
and as I recall the opp commissioner
went on YouTube and said it can be
sometimes difficult for the public to
understand why the police don't always
immediately take enforcement action
and I recall that and I certainly
understand that as well and you would uh
agree with that as well I take it
I agree that the events are difficult I
agree that it would be difficult for the
public to understand what actions the
police do or not do not take yes
and in some situations the the right
approach may be to not take immediate
enforcement action but for instance to
use the national framework for protests
and investigate and late charges after
the events where appropriate
and that may be the appropriate approach
yes and so and that because that may be
because immediate enforcement can
sometimes be dangerous uh in terms of
the public and officer safety
and certainly that's a consideration
that's a possibility yes
and immediate action can inflame or
incite or lead to uh even death in some
cases correct
yes it could as in it occurred in Nipper
wash yes
um am I correct that based on the OPP's
significant experience they've learned
some valuable lessons and have developed
some expertise
yes I agree with that yes and
um much of that expertise comes from the
experiences they've had
and I take it after a protest is handled
by uh the opp there's probably a review
and an analysis of what went well and
what did not
that's correct yes
and then you build on that experience to
address policing protests in the future
to hopefully do it better that's correct
and the situation in Ottawa we've heard
was unique and unprecedented are words
that we've seen and you agree with that
correct
I agree that there were elements of this
protest in Ottawa that were
unprecedented the financial component
the travel
I agree with elements of that that were
unprecedented yes and a demonstration of
this size involving large Vehicles which
became an occupation and resulted in
upheavalant trauma to the community
there's no other Municipal Police
Service in Canada that's experienced
something like that is there
I don't know that I can answer that
necessarily I can say this I do believe
there are elements were unprecedented as
you said I do believe there have been
attempts to do things like this for
shorter periods of time as in Toronto on
February 12th
um but I I definitely agree that the
longevity and some of the tactics
utilized are unprecedented and the
financing and we're going to be hearing
from some other Witnesses and you can
tell me if you would agree with that
that planning for major events can be a
very uh labor-intensive
job is that fair
it's fair that planning can be labor
intensive yes and so sometimes months of
planning take place uh with consultation
with many experts in different areas in
preparation for an event
it's true that months could be required
in relation to certain events it's also
true that circumstances present
themselves that require more immediacy
in terms of planning the G8 G20 is an
example of the months of planning other
examples illustrate themselves and don't
permit that
right
um
the first mention of the freedom Convoy
I think was on the January 13th ending
is that correct that's the first
production of intelligence from the
Ontario Provincial Police yes and then
15 days later it began to arrive in
Ottawa on the 28th of January that's
correct and so there wasn't a lot of
advanced notice
no that's true I mean there was 15 days
yeah and then the January 13th I'm I'm
not going to pull it up
um in order to save some time but I
think you're pretty uh comfortable with
it but if you're not please let me know
the January 13th hand in report did not
provide a lot of information because not
a lot of information was known at that
time it provided our best assessment
based upon the known information and it
stimulated further collection right so
there was no indication in that report
of the size of the Convoy
I I'm not able to remember the wording
specifically I mean you'd have it in the
assessment but uh
I honestly I can't I don't want to say
what it says in the assessment okay um
we have it marked so we can look at it
do you recall it saying uh that there
was no indication of what the Convoy
would do when it arrived
yes okay
and that's something that remained true
until it came to fruition in fact in
your summary that you prepared of the
Hendon reports you said the details of
the um Convoy on January 13 were scant
okay
um can I ask please if you could turn up
uh OPP
uh zero zero three four eight
and um if you go if you scroll down a
bit
there's an email from you to Deputy
Commissioner Cox at 6 30 on February
14th yes
and if we go to the second page of that
email
is that the um full page
thanks
and so uh the second last paragraph I
just want to read that to you I should
also mention there was a serious
complication in relation to these
activities these individuals and
entities are not for the most part
participating in the realm of criminal
activity most from Vancouver to Ottawa
have engaged as they said they would in
the lawful sphere the arrests from
Windsor to Ottawa illustrate this so the
balance of civil liberties and Public
Safety crime prevention not to mention
proactive intelligence targeting is a
sensitive one especially in these
politicized times and you agree with
that you you wrote that correct yes I
agree
and so the first real reference uh to
the Convoy where we have some more
information coming to Ottawa is in the
January 20th pending report I believe
you said that's the first sorry that is
the next provision of a written
intelligence document in the interim
there had been communication back and
forth between the provincial operations
intelligence Bureau and Ottawa Police
Service intelligence personnel
and so on the January 20th one again
without turning it up
um you would agree with me I take it
that there was some information that
turned out not to come to fruition
and so I can give you some examples if
you want
sure do you mind pulling it up just um
so I'll give you this example and um uh
one of the things in okay so one of the
things they did say was that it would
almost certainly disrupt the movement of
vehicular traffic and that obviously is
true
um and that's true about most protests
correct that's true yeah and then it
said some participants may attempt to
disrupt the business of government at
the provincial and federal level by
blocking access to Parliament you
remember that that didn't happen in
Ottawa because the work of parliament uh
went on throughout the Convoy correct
I think that they did impede the
activity of government by virtue of
their presence and I think that led to
significant discussion about the
workings of Parliament and some security
concerns I think they also attempted to
impede activity in Toronto in relation
to Queen's Park on February 5th and 12th
right I'm sorry I my question wasn't
clear I'm talking about Ottawa the work
of parliament continued correct
Parliament sat during that period okay I
can't yeah I can't speak to whether any
of the members of parliament felt
impeded so yeah so I've
um another thing noted at that time was
that some individuals from the United
States may join and that appeared
occasionally in hand in reports that
didn't occur either did it
I can't honestly say I mean I guess if
there was any American citizen that
participated I guess that would be true
um I can say that the impact and
influence that was feared possibly by
some American activists never occurred
and um most of the information as of
January 20th was that the protesters
were aiming at a lawful and peaceful
event
and there's no is that true yes and
there was no indication in the January
20th report that the trucks would end up
in residential neighborhoods and that
they'd break noise bylaws
that wasn't part of the hand in report
was it yeah to be honest we don't
concentrate I mean generally speaking in
Intelligence on byline fractions
although that was an important Point
here
um I do believe that it spoke to
impeding the business of government in
the downtown core and business right we
did not make specific reference to
residential areas right and so there was
no reference to trucks idling their
engines or having hot tubs or bouncy
castles or harassing residents or
engaging in anti-social Behavior
yeah it's a subjective term but no
there's no reference to that no and
there was an indication though that
although it was planned to be peaceful
there was the possibility of Lone actors
or small groups engaging in activities
that present Public Safety threats yes
that was certainly a potential a
possibility
and the possibility that lone actors and
small Fringe groups would present public
safety issues was in fact addressed by
the Ottawa Police and the opp uh in
preparation correct you had Pou units
here
yes I mean I have to say from my
perspective
the proactive handling of those
possibilities was done through
intelligence operations the presence of
a public order unit would respond to the
outcome coming to fruition
and the threats to Public Safety
fortunately didn't materialize on that
first weekend is that right
yeah I would concur with that
and although obviously very inconvenient
for residents that first weekend was
calm no serious threats or acts of
serious violence
correct
um the January 20th uh Hendon report it
was noted was difficult to complete
comprehensively because it involved a
wide array of individuals with multiple
motivations and plans that were Loosely
uh formed
that's correct so I just want to point
out on that there were multiple Affinity
groups and multiple individuals multiple
Grievances and we were trying to address
that and did through the creation of
tactical intelligence reports that were
completed later in that week and
provided to the Ottawa Police Service
and so another Hendon report on January
22nd
um that I believe you uh referenced
earlier notes that the number of
potential participants in Ottawa was
unknown and I believe what we see on it
is that online client claims of the size
are of unknown reliability
yeah that's true so I mean when we
follow social media it will be of
unknown reliability we try to mitigate
that unknown factor with uh juxtaposing
it in the context and we came to the
determination that there was significant
support
and the January 22nd Hendon report in
the assessment section also notes that
an intelligence Gap at that point is the
number of participants correct that's
correct and I should say as part of
intelligence tradecraft that is always a
gap right up until the event actually
occurs because we would never know the
exact numbers and the January 22nd
Hendon report has a sectioned headed
tactical considerations and I see in
that section I don't know if this you
recall this that one organizer there
claimed a million individuals and ten
thousand trucks would attend you
remember that I do remember reading that
that didn't happen did it no
um a January 26th so that's another
Hendon report that's two days before the
arrival am I right yep and that has a
section called the seriousness of the
threats
and um
lists a number of points in terms of the
seriousness none of those threats
mention the horns or the idling open
fires harassment of residents that's not
one of the threats is it
it's not listed as one of the threats no
and again it talks about the potential
presence of individuals who espouse
Fringe ideological ideologies and have
access to weapons
and that too wasn't a problem in Ottawa
correct that's correct well I should
comment on that in terms of it's a
subjective weapons no uh in terms of
being discerned as such no uh presence
of people with fringe views I would say
there were people present with fringe
views depending upon your determination
of Fringe
and I believe that Hendon report
indicates uh so two days before and it's
I believe in bold that project Hendon
has not identified any concrete specific
or credible threats uh with regard to
the Convoy that is that is accurate true
and the concern about the heavy
machinery that heavy machinery wasn't
used for any destructive purposes in
Ottawa was it
I not that I'm aware of that would be
best posed to the Ottawa Police Service
I just want to point out just just I was
involved in the production of strategic
intelligence and providing a best
assessment to inform decision making in
terms of some of the questions you're
asking in terms of the use of uh I think
that's best to the operational
commanders from the city of Ottawa or
sorry from the Ottawa Police Service and
if we look at January 26 again even two
days before the arrival we still don't
have any good indications uh and I'm not
being critical of the intelligence of uh
the numbers
and the length of the stay correct
well words such as significant in terms
I mean the numbers to me
become
if it's significant and there are large
numbers then perhaps the actual quantity
is not as important but no we didn't
mention the length of stay but we did
certainly say that we felt it would be
long term based upon the fact that they
were going to stay until their demands
were met and we felt they couldn't be
and the opp and the Ottawa Police
Service did work together uh from even
before the first Convoy arrived and had
Pou units in Ottawa cooperated with each
other
so we work together in Hendon with the
Ottawa Police Service and that was sort
of my purview of responsibility in terms
of public order Etc that would be a
question that should be asked to
superintendent Abrams in terms of the
opp operations okay I didn't see any
memos or briefings or emails from the
opp to the Ops saying what are you doing
what are your plans you're not aware of
such memos are you
I'm not aware of the memos but I
wouldn't be in my capacity as the
intelligence leader and the opp I take
it knows that if Ottawa Police needs
assistance it's likely to call on the
opp because of their size you have a
very large Police Service First yes
and Ops has um uh OPP has plts who were
activated for this protest
yes and Ops also had plts who were
activated before the protest as well
correct
that is not I'm not certain how PLT was
utilized in the Ottawa Police Service
okay
um and um if I look at the Hendon report
of January 27th the day before I still
see that indication uh in bold that
there's no concrete specific or credible
threat identified correct that's correct
and to be quite Blunt You're Going to
see that throughout because
there was no con apart from the public
order event that would occur and be
significant of long-standing there was
no specific intelligence about a
specific action I.E an attack on
Parliament an attack on anything else
um if you could please um turn up uh
opp00815
and Page seven
your your time is just about out on my
clock so if you could try and wrap up
sure
foreign
can you repeat the number counselor
opp00815
thank you uh if you could please turn to
page seven
foreign
assessment
so this is the January 28th um report so
January 28th being the date that they're
here
and so what we see in the first
paragraph is the available information
indicates that the protesters plan to
remain in Ottawa at least until 20 uh
until February 4th 2022 correct yes and
then we see
um we continue to identify indicators to
support at least some protesters
remaining beyond the weekend of
2022.01 29 30. so in other words some of
them are going to remain past 29 30 and
some of them are going to remain until
February 4th correct
I want to be clear on this we felt it
would be a long-standing the reason that
February 4th was cited was because there
was a specific piece of information that
they would be there until at least
February 4th but it does not preclude
the long-standing significant event that
we said that would occur
until the demands were met which they
wouldn't be
um and finally
um my final point is I understand that
the opp provided some assistance to
Toronto when they had the uh protest
occurring in Toronto the following week
correct
yes I there were two I'm sorry is the
one on February 12th which was the more
the Saturday February 12th yes uh and
there was another one as well there was
one on February 5th as well right and so
when I looked at your notes I saw that
you in fact uh attended meetings with
Toronto prior to the protest arriving in
Toronto do you recall that yeah virtual
meetings with the people in intelligence
to set up our collection and our
information and intelligence routing to
assist them in their plans right and you
referenced what happened in Ottawa as a
learning experience yes thank you very
much those are my questions
thank you next is the uh or the Convoy
organizers
oh sir
um my name is Brandon Miller I'm counsel
for the Convoy or Freedom Corp which is
an entity that represents the protesters
that were in Ottawa on January and
February of 2022 I just have a few
questions for you first again thank you
for your service and thank you very much
for your forthright testimony earlier uh
just on something you spoke about in
your evidence in Chief you spoke about
the demand of protesters and those
demands would simply not be met I take
it uh that by that you mean the demand
for the removal of vaccine or covid
mandates is that correct
in the main yes there were multitude of
Demands but those were some significant
ones and for the federal government to
drop some of their regulations and
mandates and and we didn't feel that
would be met yes yes right and these
questions are going to be I'm you're
going to be able to know exactly where
I'm going so I'm just going to be blunt
um you didn't see any evidence in the
intelligence of Espionage or in support
of Espionage is that correct
that's correct
you didn't see any evidence in the
intelligence of sabotage or anything in
support of sabotage that's correct
you didn't see anything in the evidence
in any evidence in the intelligence of
any form of foreign influenced
activities within or relating to Canada
that involved the threat to any person
I saw media accounts yes I saw no
information collected or intelligence
produced in that regard no to support
that no now for my following question
when I say serious violence against a
person you'll understand I mean violence
that would result in serious personal
injury okay
you didn't see any evidence in the
intelligence of activities within or
relating to Canada directed toward or in
support of the threat of a use of Acts
of serious violence against persons for
the purpose of achieving a political
religious or ideological objective
within Canada or a foreign state
so yes I know where you're going and I
want it to be fair to my colleagues in
planning
um I saw online rhetoric I saw
information on social media I saw
assertions of that type of activity
information
I'm aware of no intelligence that was
produced that would support
concern in that regard thank you and now
for my next question when I say serious
violence against property you'll
understand I mean violence against
property of the nature such as arson or
destruction a bomb that sort of thing
okay
you didn't see any evidence in the
intelligence of activities within or
relating to Canada directed toward or in
support of a threat of use of Acts of
serious violence against property for
the purpose of achieving a political
religious or ideological objective
within Canada or a foreign state
so again
not to be contradictory because I'm just
trying to be fulsome
our role is crime prevention law
enforcement assistance of victims public
order and Emergency Management
therefore in relation to the things
you're discussing we collected all the
information which some information
asserted attempts at that
so we did see that and had to consider
that
did we have any credible intelligence
that that would occur no
thank you and you touched on in your
oral evidence about the labeling of
someone as being an extremist you said
that that term uh you have a lot of
problems with and I'm wondering if you
can elaborate on that for me
I can sorry where did I say I have
problems with that you said just in your
evidence okay
um
so the word extremism does not have a
description in law
section 83 of the criminal code speaks
to terrorist offenses which
possibly could be synonymous with
extremism sections 3 18 319 and 320 of
the criminal code speak to hate
motivated crimes advocation of genocide
Etc other sections of the criminal codes
to section 430 speak to
acts against religious property that
could be deemed to be extremist
I have
problems with the term
because everyone has a subjective belief
as to what extremism means at the low
end and banal end it means someone I
disagree with and I find that
problematic
as a working as a working definition for
myself
I utilize extremism and I try to premise
it in law
by somebody who would Advocate and
utilize violence to achieve their goals
and they could be motivated politically
ideologically religiously Etc right and
I take it that in in practice if the
federal government's intelligence
apparatus or law enforcement sees a
legitimate credible threat as we just
discussed they would let you know about
it correct
I work we work with the Canadian
Security intelligence service on a daily
basis we have a provincial
anti-terrorism section that is
integrated with the Canadian Security
intelligence service we are integrated
with the integrated National Security
enforcement team and have members on
that that is their threshold and as
you've cited section part two of the
prosthesis act in terms of the threats
to Canada
um I communicated with my colleagues in
inset and Ottawa inside in Toronto csis
in Toronto CSUS and Ottawa they
participated in the Hendon calls
um
I believe that I would have been
informed and in terms of those
delineations I guess I'll know more at
the end of these hearings but I received
no information in relation to those uh
the probability of that activity right
and of course the intelligence apparatus
in Canada they're not technically law
enforcement they provide information and
it is the opp and the RCMP and the
Ottawa Police Service who would carry
out any law enforcement aspects with
respect to any threat domestically
correct yeah the O'Connor commission
spoke to that in the IR inquiry yes
cesus collects advises retains for
government security intelligence we act
on criminal intelligence and translate
that into evidence for law enforcement
action right and the federal government
would always tell you about these things
because they don't want to have any
Canadians and individuals harmed right
it they want you to protect them
we have a great relationship I'm not
trying to skirt your question we have a
great relationship with intelligence
entities
um I know that cesus will present as
well the RCMP
um we have a good relationship and I
believe that I would be informed but I
also believe that there would be
instances where activity is occurring
within that sphere
um that I may not be advised of because
it may not be within my purview of the
police services act and criminal
intelligence International and scope
perhaps uh to your knowledge have you
been advised by any of those actors that
you have not been informed of everything
have I been advised by those actors that
I have not been informed of something
yes no thank you
now dealing with the issue of Lone Wolf
attackers
um
can you agree that the last lone wolf
attack in the capital was on October
22nd 2005 or 2014 when Michael zaf bibu
attacked Parliament with a firearm is
that correct
I remember the events and I would
attribute that to what I refer to as an
independent asymmetric threat
um I don't want to say that that's the
last event just because I I don't want
to misspeak I am aware of other events
but they weren't that I'm aware of in
the in in the national capital region
now can you agree that following that
attack lessons were learned on how law
enforcement intelligence agencies would
gather intelligence with respect to Lone
Wolf attackers
yes I believe that lessons were learned
I believe that resources were increased
I believe that cooperation and
collaboration was enhanced I will say
this as a caveat
um
an independent asymmetric threat a lone
wolf
is
the largest concern for somebody in a
position such as mine or other people
who are appear before you because we
rely upon the collection of information
to produce intelligence and in the
instance of an independent asymmetric
threat the circle of trust may be one
and that is a very difficult environment
in which to succeed right and those
lessons that were learned from that
attack they were Incorporated within the
intelligence gathering apparatus both at
the opp and federally correct yes
certainly I mean I can
that's an area where the age of social
media can assist us because in many
examples of Lone wolfs as you refer to
those are preceded by indicators of
activity so that is of assistance and
that is something that
the provincial operations intelligence
Bureau engages in right and a lone wolf
attack does not need a protest in order
to be carried out does it
it does not require one no thank you
those are my questions
thank you next is uh for uh former Chief
slowly
superintendent I'm Tom Curry
um I want to start at the end
recommendations the commissioner has the
task of considering whether there are
recommendations that he can make
um concerning the issues that we're here
about emergencies act demonstrations of
the kind
one of the things
um
that Chief slowly I anticipate will say
to the commissioner is that there in his
experience is our what he would describe
as structural deficits in in gathering
intelligence between agencies you've
mentioned them ceases RCMP
uh OPP other other law enforcement and
security agencies
um just stopping there uh do you agree
that that the commissioner should
consider a recommendation that will
enhance a national security framework
for intelligence now
can I give you my answer in two parts
yes okay
um
I would always agree with any
recommendation such as that to review
what transpired and to review how we can
improve I myself have done that already
with in relation to these events I will
say that I
I honestly believe that we do have a
high degree of collaboration in this
province and in this country and we do
have trusted Partnerships and we do
produce credible intelligence it is not
perfect and it can always be improved
and I would gladly participate in any
entity of that sort all right thank you
one of the things uh as well I
expect you'll you'll also be able to
help the commissioner with is this
am I correct that that Hendon and the
work that your intelligence Bureau does
a rose
in order to fill a gap
that you saw in in the way that you
described and I don't have time to go
back through that history am I correct
that's how it arose to fill a gap I I
think that's a correct assessment right
and I just want to give you like two
there are issues we face as a law
enforcement community proactively that
are broader than our jurisdictions and
galvanizing and collaborating can assist
us in that regard
and in that respect
um I haven't met a someone from an
agency that doesn't want more funding
but am I correct that that a
recommendation from the commissioner to
consider
the funding question to support those
initiatives as the issues have Arisen
that you have identified would be
helpful
that's difficult ground for me I can't
speak for the Ottawa Police Service I I
can say that um
Ontario Provincial Police okay
um that would be for other people to
consider I I I do believe that we had
the resources that were required I'm
speaking of intelligence to engage
proactively and strategically to
ascertain what would transpire
um the the coalescing back to these
events now please the coalescing
of these disparate groups that you
described
and the financing that you described
that you had seen for the first time
um
you describe those as unprecedented in
your experience correct
aspects of it the fundraising yes
um the the the issues the Grievances
um were different so there are certainly
unprecedented components of it fair and
in that respect just focusing on the
funding alone
um do you accept that that represents a
paradigm shift in
in protest and Descent of the kind that
you're experienced
it resents sorry it resents uh apologies
it presents a logistical change in the
capacity of entities to fundraise and
but I will say that we had already
experienced that in Mackenzie Meadows
occupation and had approached entities
such as GoFundMe
um to take steps in relation to that in
lines with their terms of agreement
right Mackenzie Meadows if I understand
that that uh protest or occupation was a
a single development parcel that's a
first Nations or indigenous dispute land
dispute is that is that correct it's
roughly yeah it's complex but that's a
complex and this the the the coalescing
of a Nationals on a national scale
people coming from across the country to
one destination that's a first yeah it's
different for sure 100 I agree now the
uh my my colleague for the Ottawa Police
Service has already reviewed some
details of the hinden reports I don't
have the time to go back through them
but suffice it to say
it was not your purpose in describing
the Hendon reports to provide
operational planning
it is an input into operational planning
correct
yeah sorry I think I understand our
purpose in the Strategic intelligence
reports of Hendon was to inform decision
making part of that decision making is
police operational planning to prepare
understood but I will I just have to say
that there were other components once
the event becomes a reality then the
Tactical intelligence collection through
a different investigative techniques and
the information acquired by that
activity lends itself to more
operational and enhanced operational
plan so for example we won't see in a
Hendon report or any of those other
documents to which you've referred any
um advice to the Ottawa Police Service
in the days ahead of the Convoy that it
should close specific roads
correct that's correct that it should
divert traffic in a particular fashion
that's correct and the opp itself so far
as you know uh intelligence Bureau
didn't direct
OPP operations
um in any part of the province to
intercept Convoy protesters at the
border of Manitoba or or Quebec correct
the opp intelligence Bureau did not
advise entities to do that that's
correct I just want to say that in the
Ontario Provincial Police like within a
police service
intelligence is part of a major Incident
Management Group where when things
impact our jurisdiction we have
discussions of that but no we certainly
as an intelligence Bureau as a Hendon
did not act to advise Ottawa what they
should do nor nor its own nor your own
um
you know your own team why why was the
Convoy not intercepted at the Manitoba
border many people have asked that
question in hindsight of course
why not I think the answer there where
there was no reasonable grounds to
believe that they were committing a
criminal offense at the time they were
in transit
and and we were collecting information
for that purpose they were in transit in
transit I'm sorry and they were engaging
in a lawful way in fact we were that was
impressed Upon Us by the information
collection right and that remained true
um as that as a convoy protester
individually or collectively came into
the border of the city of Ottawa correct
I would agree with that assessment and
also the intelligence said that there
would not be an event a public order
event until they entered the city of
Ottawa right but most of the most my
colleague has already dealt with this
but many of the Hendon reports the 25th
my my friends for the commission took
you to one uh document on the 25th and
and showed you a line or two but in that
report it refers to what is likely to be
a three-day event there are a number of
references that pointed that way correct
I don't accept that I don't recall any
information which would lead to the
induction that this will only be a
three-day event we believed and our our
belief only became more enhanced as time
went on that it would be a longer event
I do know that February 4th that came
from a piece of information but in all
of our discussions and my read of the
intelligence is this will be a
significant event and it will be an
event of long-standing and there were
also convoys arriving leaving Etc with a
great deal of alteration I don't have
time to take you to it but later look at
the 25th okay
um can I show the witness please OPP
five zeros or four zeros four three four
eight
[Applause]
uh you see see this now 27th of January
do you recognize this situational report
sorry I actually don't I don't know if
it's the color scheme
um is there something at the top it's an
opp yeah well it's an opp document and
uh maybe
I think this is a provincial liaison
team document but do you recognize this
as a situational report from your your
Police Service
I'm sorry it's the first document that
I've seen that
I don't recognize as such it may be I've
never seen this before and it may be a
provincial lead oh once I'm just going
to read so I recognize it as an opp
doctor there you go just stop okay so
it's an east region document okay okay
you got it can you scroll back up now
please thank you
um I I want to draw your attention
please to the
um it's got to be about the eighth
bullet point begins Ottawa Police
Service yep has developed a robust plan
that would allow for capacity to
accommodate up to 3 000 commercial
vehicles
there are a number of other things there
but that colleagues of yours in the opp
different different group no doubt had
access clearly to to the to the plans
that the Ottawa Police Service had
described correct yeah and I'm sorry if
I uh spoken correctly Scott Semple
inspector sample who's referenced here
and superintendent Abrams who I believe
will be here tomorrow
um they would be aware of this and I not
trying to say there wasn't a plan my
engagement as an intelligence
professional wouldn't lead me to be
engaged in that I understood so that it
so to put it this way if OPP had a had
an issue with the plan that the Ottawa
Police Service was pursuing to allow the
protesters to protest
um then then it would have spoken up you
would expect
I can speak to this document if Scott
Semple felt the plan was robust that's
what he articulated here yeah he's a
good experience he's a critical incident
commander and inspector in the opp and
Detachment Commander got it well uh
could I show the witness please OPP uh
four zeros 1007.
uh just while this is coming up you have
an ass you have a Deputy Commissioner
Cox c-o-x that's correct
um and you work with him that's correct
is your is your Bureau report up through
his his command he is the commander of
the investigations organized crime
command and I am one of the bureaus that
reports to him thank you look at this
please scroll down if you would
um Madam register or clerk 28th did you
see it uh 28 January yep so here we are
on the
is that the Friday
um to you from him Pat
Convoy protest is the subject there's
been great collaboration amongst our
intelligence bureaus and units as well
as with our policing Partners along the
route to Ottawa
established integration cooperation
all those Police Services yep including
Ottawa along with the planning
undertaken by the Ops have positioned us
well to maintain Safety and Security
throughout the weekend
please extend my gratitude
Etc
um and you responded to that please just
scroll up show the witness I won't read
it all but you express your gratitude
and you share the thanks with your team
correct
yes
um clearly the Deputy Commissioner
thought this was going to be a weekend
event didn't he
I can't speak to that exactly I think I
that may be the case
um I think that he had a discussion I'm
going from an independent recollection
with other police services including
Ottawa and he got a lot of positive
feedback and he sent that email I think
that that's what happened no great I I
accept that that the hidden reports
provide very important intelligence and
chief slowly will confirm that but in
terms of what
your your risk put it this way that at
that time superintendent you didn't say
to him
um it the plan is great for the weekend
but after that we're in a lot of trouble
yeah I'm just sorry I'm just gonna have
quick
you can scroll down is it my comments
further our analytical yes I mean him to
you you to him
okay sorry I'm just looking I didn't
mention weekend I didn't mention any
timing in my email no sorry can you vote
that's what I was checking for
um
and I see I see that Deputy Cox mentions
that it should maintain Safety and
Security throughout the weekend yes and
that's what he said I accept that I
didn't make any comment in relation to
time sensitivity thank you just the last
thing then if I can you had you
you received a request from Chief slowly
for Hendon information you told the
commissioner about yep
um and at the same time or just ahead of
that actually you received another
communication this time from someone who
reports to to Chief slowly named
Patterson you've described him already
Matt Mark Patterson I think he's an
inspector he's a superintendent
superintendent and
he told you you are about to get a
response are you about to get a request
from Chief slowly
or a bunch of questions from Chief
slowly don't respond to them
do you recall that I can show you your
notes if I do helps you
yeah I remember
sorry I just want to be clear so the
requests from Chief slowly and I'm
speaking to the four locations the five
questions that came on the 11th
um I I believe that the comments you're
referring to and I do remember them came
on the 13th and that had to do with the
request to appear before the Ottawa
Police Services Board thank you so
they're two different fair enough so so
it's no thank you for that you were
asked by Chief slowly to come and brief
the Police Services Board on the 15th
correct that's correct and of course he
resigned before that presentation and it
was adjourned yep okay prior to thank
you for orienting me to that
what was unusual you agree with me was
it a superintendent of the Ottawa Police
Service
told you that you were about to be
invited to that Police Services Board
meeting to give a briefing with the
chief and that you should not attend
correct
it was unusual I mean to be blunt the
entire circumstance was unusual it's
it's unusual to be
asked as the head of intelligence for
the opp to brief the Ottawa Police
Services Board that's point one and then
to be followed up with the next day I
think I'm sorry I don't recall our name
Christiane I think it was the lawyer for
the Ottawa Police Services Board that
provided the email
and I know that superintendent Patterson
felt that we should not we the opp
should not be doing that because that
should be the responsibility of the
Ottawa Police Service intelligence
directorate
and that is on the entire situation is
unusual yes so I mean in in did you I
take it you didn't decline the
invitation to go to the Police Services
Board when Chief slowly asked you
um so Chief slowly asked verbally in the
meeting uh he asked me together when I
was with my commissioner and Deputy
Commissioner
um the formal invitation came the next
day on the Sunday morning
when I received the invitation I didn't
respond at first I discussed it with
Deputy Commissioner Cox and commissioner
Creek and we agreed
to a time we agreed to attend yes so as
unusual as that might have been you
agreed to attend yep and then you get an
a call
from
superintendent Patterson saying Chief
slowly is and I'm I'm reading you from
your notes I'll show you them if you if
you need to be refreshed I'm just in the
interest of time she slowly is possibly
trying to pin this on the opp and the
lack of intelligence that's what
superintendent Patterson told you right
that's correct
and did you did you
um
report that to I know you reported that
to your own command
do you know whether that information was
ever shared with anybody at the Ottawa
Police Service about what superintendent
Patterson was suggesting
I spoke about that with Deputy Cox and
commissioner Creek that too was unusual
not that I spoke with it but it occurred
um I do not know if that was discussed
by them with Chief slowly right I mean
you've a significant undermining of a of
a command officer to have a
superintendent
speak about that isn't it
I found it unusual I will say I will say
that I understand the desire
to have the Ops intelligence brief the
Ops Police Services Board I found it
unusual to be honest from the 11th 12th
and 13th 14th and 15th there was a lot
that transpired that was unusual in
relation to our integration and
relationship
inappropriate can I have that at least
what superintendent Patterson did was
inappropriate
and perhaps it's unusual for certain
I'll I'll leave it there
okay next to uh call on the Ottawa
coalition
good evening Mr commissioner Emily
tamman for the Ottawa Coalition of
residents and businesses and our
questions of an Aston answered thank you
uh next uh the city of Ottawa
good evening super superintendent we
also have no additional questions to
those that have been put to you so far
thank you
pressures on the government of Canada
good evening superintendent good evening
my name is donnery Nygaard I'm Council
for the government of Canada I just have
a couple of uh brief questions for you
uh when my friend from the commission
was discussing with you your January
29th Hendon report you talked about and
this is right at the beginning obviously
of the protest and you you talked about
the fact that there had been no criminal
activity as the Convoy moved across the
country but and I'm not going to quote
you directly because I'm not that good a
note taker but something to the effect
of
um but when a plan meets a counter plan
you don't know what to expect and that
these kinds of events attract others
with other agendas including lone wolves
is that roughly Accord with your
recollection of what you said that's
roughly and can I just comment on that
absolutely it's just an intelligence
tradecraft I find
it's a bit like Financial advice you
always want exactly what's going to
happen in the future and
we like to say that a plan never
survives contact with the Enemy so
it's impossible to expect that it will
be exactly like that so
I just say that as context for what you
said but I agree with what you said yes
and
I wanted to ask you up because one of my
other friends said that I asked you the
question that a protest is not necessary
for a lone wolf attack but I take it
from those comments you made about what
can happen when these groups come
together that an event such as as this
that brings all these groups together
can increase the likelihood or provide
more opportunity for a lone wolf attack
would that be I agree with that
assessment
uh can we have a document OPP four
zeros1837 please
one of my friends took you to this
document earlier it was you said you
hadn't seen it before it was the notes
from the integrated planning cell on
February 11th that you attended and just
so I'm understanding correctly this was
a briefing that you were giving on the
intelligence that you had collected in
relation to these events sorry can you
just go up to the very top I I just want
to make sure
so
I'm a little bit yeah I'm a little bit
uncertain because it isn't my document
but I do recognize the names and I do
know what the integrated planning cell
is and I was contacted by Chief party
and others who are participating and
they had said
what their purpose was and what their
integration was and what they were
trying to achieve and we arranged to
have an intelligence briefing I'm I'm
thrown off slightly because it says
start time 0700
um and I'll be I'll
I got an invitation to a meeting that
ran the entire day I remember being
confused by that because I didn't know
when I was required to provide my
briefing which I believe I provided at
either 0 900 or 0930. so that's
so that is why I'm saying what I'm
saying and we provided a briefing on
everything and I had all of the managers
there to provide the different aspects
provincial
Ottawa all the different areas that were
ongoing so if we scroll if you down just
a little bit so you can see them where
it says minutes and then it says that
you're speaking
correct yep and if we scroll on to the
next page
just a couple few lines up from that
redaction
it says in terms of Ottawa Convoy since
they started on 24th of January there
have been very few criminal acts
yesterday there was an increase in
hostility antagonism anti-police
anti-establishment sediment and then if
we go down to the next uh two bullet
points this situation is incredibly
volatile which may have National
Security implications and then the next
bullet point I'm sorry I oh you know all
I'm just trying to no no I'm just trying
to find where we are
um so this situation
and then two lines down there are
extremist groups diagonalon involved and
farfata is a QC based group
so just a couple of questions for you on
this I assume that you were telling this
group all of this information because
this was based on the intelligence you
had gathered
okay so the difficulty with this for me
is these aren't my notes
um and it's consistent with what we told
told Chief slowly in relation to his
questions
everybody was asking about extremism
we weren't seeing much evidence of it
um the group diagonalon I in my
experience they are an extremist entity
they hold extremist views
farfata is a group that until this event
I was not familiar with and I was
informed by the suretage Quebec that
they were not a violent group although
they were opposed to the pandemic
mandates etc etc so I reference that
diagonalon and farfata were two entities
and that farfata was geographically
situated in a specific area I believe
Rito and Sussex and that we had people
on ground ascertaining intent motivation
individuals mood sentiment Etc
that that is my recollection of what I
was providing so so maybe I'll just back
up for a moment is
is from your recollection is what's here
or at least the parts that I took you to
is that
from your recollection an accurate
um recording of what you would have told
this group amongst other things I think
the mo generally yes
um I may have is synonymous with
potential National Security implications
um and that spoke to issues Beyond
Ottawa I was talking about the situation
um at a global level yes and the the
increasing volatility was there were
points in Ottawa Police Service I
remember Ken Bryden the inspector
talking about this there were points
when information came back from people
on the ground speaking to joviality and
Congeniality and there were points when
it became more aggressive and egregious
and this specific location was a
location where things were more
egregious and it was the collection of
our officers on scene that volatility
was escalating and I remember very
specifically it had to do with the
issuance of a parental offense sorry a
provincial offense notice where people
became aggrieved and there was um
a verbal Exchange
and I don't think well this is February
11th so you uh you would not have been
aware of it yet but uh in addition
um if there was at one point uh
some arrests made in Coots Alberta which
you asked about yes and and that was
also informing what was going on in
Ottawa yeah
um so to be fair on that when the
arrests occurred
um we took multiple steps to acquire the
information specifically as I discussed
with the former Council to see what is
the impact what is the connection Etc we
determined we got the information from
the RCMP
um I spoke with the assistant
commissioner I I believe assistant
commissioner or Deputy Commissioner Mark
Flynn and then with the person leading
the investigation and we determined that
there was very little
um connection to Ottawa and that
therefore our assessment was there would
be very little impact and there was not
foreign
and then lastly I want to take you to
opp401783
this is the timeline document
that you refer to in your statement oh
okay yep and I understand from your
statement that although this was mostly
written by an analyst it was something
that you approved the entire document
that's correct
and I just want to take you to page
three can I just say that this document
was produced I can't be entirely
specific it was produced for our
commissioner karik
um for his presentation or testimony I'm
not sure which to a parliamentary
Committee in March of 2022 and we were
asked by superintendent mcdonell to
comment on certain elements and I
personally believe that this document to
a reader might seem unusual because the
last component in relation to sexual
assault seems to be out of context that
was a specific request due to a specific
incident and I wasn't going to go to
that part okay
but just uh so I take it given the fact
that you reviewed and approved that the
information in this document you
consider to be accurate
yes
so uh just before the title towards the
bottom of page three that says with
respect to intelligence failure
uh you're discussing in the paragraph
above that the the Freedom Movement uh
or this document is discussing the free
Freedom Movement and the freedom Convoy
and that paragraph concludes saying
these potentially unintended
consequences that stretched
International Security realm could not
be left unaddressed and the political
climate along with the growing civil
unrest of the movement as a whole where
threats of violence were omnipresent and
particular to the Ottawa occupation
appeared to necessitate enhance policing
powers to resolve the conflict so the
the reference to the threats of violence
were omnipresent is that is that in
particular to relation to the Ottawa
occupation or was that the movement as a
whole there was a movement
as a whole and they were threats of
violence the threats were omnipresent
and we tried to address them as we went
along
um in terms of producing intelligence we
found no credible intelligence of
threats
when you say you found no credible
intelligence of of threats
were you involved in the investigations
into particular threats that were made
to various politicians and other public
figures in Ottawa or is that something
like that the Ops
dealt with
primarily that would be activity that
the sorry that the Ops engaged in okay
and also
um I'm talking about yeah threats
generally that would be premised and
intelligence like I'll give you an
example on February 2nd at 18 30 hours
we're going to breach security to The
West Wing of parliament
Etc and I have been engaged in protests
before where things like that have
happened and we could find no credible
intelligence of threats those kinds of
threats so you say you're not talking
about a threat that may be made against
a particular individual for example but
we never that's true but we never had
intelligence of of that threats of those
and I mean I've reviewed the arrests and
the charges and stuff to try and
ascertain how accurate we were and there
was
I would say the lack of violent crime
was shocking
um the lack I mean even in the arrests
and charges considering the whole thing
in totality I think there were 10
charges for violent crime six of which
were against police officers
but where threats were made against
individuals precautions were taken to
protect those individuals right so yeah
those threats didn't actually
materialize but that doesn't mean that
the threats weren't originally credible
yeah and I can't speak to whether those
threats were I mean if they were I guess
charges would have been laid for
uttering threats death threats
potentially but if there was actually if
you weren't involved in any of those no
but if there was an actual threat
then there would have been an
investigation and if there was an actual
threat I assume the Ottawa Police
Service would have laid a charge for
uttering threats if the person who
uttered the threat could be identified
right right hard to lay a charge if you
can't identify an anonymous threat or
even ascertain if it's an actual threat
if you can't if you can't identify the
individual
no but
when security is provided right then
presumably the credit is the threat is
credible right thank you
okay next is uh the Democracy fund
um
a good evening everyone I just have um
I'm getting a message here that I cannot
start my video because the host has
stopped it
that Mr commissioner if it's fine by you
I will ask my questions without any
video
I think that's probably the best way to
proceed if we can't get video
if you're prepared to do that otherwise
we can
we can find another option but are you
prepared to proceed on that basis
I am prepared to proceed on that basis
uh good uh evening uh sir my name is
Alan honner and I'm a lawyer from the
Democracy fund I only have five minutes
um but most of my questions have been
answered
can somebody please pull up uh OPP
five zeros seven eight nine
sir do you recall this email dated
February 22nd 2022 it is an email from
you to Deputy Cox I do
sir is it fair to say that in your view
a policing should be apolitical it
should be objective and it should view
view events in their context
yes
in this letter you say that law
enforcement is at a critical stage in
terms of its ethics its operational
Independence and its decision making
right at the top sir you agree with me
oh
yes I agree
thank you very much that was an easy one
and I I I if we can scroll down to the
um the second last paragraph of the
second page I'm going to
um read uh I'm going to read something
to you but before I do that can you just
confirm for me that it's fair to say
that one of your concerns here is that
the public discourse has become
sensationalized and it's become
inaccurate
yeah so this is a large conversation I
mean I think it's evident that I was
concerned by a politicization and I was
concerned by Hyperbole and I was
concerned by the affixing of labels
without evidence to individuals
movements
Etc and if I can I don't want to waste
your time but this doesn't just speak to
this movement I can give you a very
specific example
um
many people law enforcement included
have an insatiable appetite I can give
you an example of Person of Interest
profiles Etc I've always been very hard
and fast no matter what the event is I
can use protests against Coastal gaslink
Etc that we don't do POI Person of
Interest profiles unless we have
reasonable grounds to suspect or
reasonable grounds to believe that those
individuals will be engaged in criminal
activity or illegal activity that will
present a public safety risk and I just
and I believe that the public expects
people like me in my position to
consider those things in the course of
my duties
your concerns aren't limited this
protest but they do apply to this
protest is that fair that's correct yep
and I'm just going to read you one
paragraph here and then I'm going to ask
you the question which I really want to
um which is what I really want to
explore and I'm almost finished here but
second last paragraph of the second page
but now the public discourse is
dominated by political figures and the
media and the commentary is providing a
very different picture from what law
enforcement collectively gathered
it is painting a different picture it
speaks to extremism it offers parallels
to terrorism it speaks of sedition
this is a reference to what is going on
in Ottawa is that right
it's a reference to what's going on in
relation to the protest writ large not
just Ottawa but Ottawa certainly
the largest component of it
thank you sir and here's my question to
you in your view
where politicians and the media are
responsible for a certain amount of
disinformation and misinformation with
respect to these protests
I'm just trying to articulate this
properly
I was concerned by comments made
publicly
by public figures
and in the media
that I believed were not premised in
fact
I would be just another person with a
subjective perspective in this case
except for the fact that from my
perspective
I was leading the criminal intelligence
collection of information and the
production of criminal intelligence in
relation to these events so I believed I
was in a unique situation to understand
what was transpiring
so when I read accounts that
the state of Russia had something to do
with it or that this was a result of
American influence either financially or
ideologically or that Donald Trump was
behind it or that it was
uncanadian or that the people
participating were uncanadian
and that they were not Canadian views
and they were extremists
I found it to be problematic because
what I ascertained from my role which is
not all-knowing and certainly there may
be information that is presented to this
committee that illustrates the error of
my ways
but I did not see validation
for those assertions
found it to be problematic and the media
was part of the problem is that right
I hesitate
to I don't want to say that necessarily
because the media has an important role
and I'm not trying to skirt the question
the media can provide editorials and
editorial boards can have stances
um I believe
that a lot of people were making
assertions that weren't accurate and if
they were based in investigation and in
fact then
there was information that I was not
privy to and I wondered why and I accept
that I might not be privy to it if the
communication security establishment of
Canada or the Canadian Security
intelligence service or the integrated
National Security enforcement team has
received information at a classification
above my level I accept that and and
that's fine I'm just saying that from my
perspective as operational command of
Hendon and That Joint Force operation I
did not see information
that substantiated what was being said
publicly and via the media and I found
that the subjective assertions
sensationalized yes and exacerbated
conflict
again and you and just one last question
for you when you when you speak of the
media there
um and when I read to you from your
letter you said the public discourse is
dominated by the media you're speaking
about the mainstream media is that right
again that's highly subjective uh I I
mean
in my line of work I mean you can tell
me what you meant well a lot of media
that I read
um
I I can't say that they were slanted and
I mean on both sides I can't say that
because I'd have to know
subjectively what they were hoping to
achieve the person who was writing it
could have objectively believed that
they were speaking the truth and I'm not
in a position to know that but I do know
that there are multiple media outlets
and even the definition of media has
altered substantially and
there are multiple perspectives and some
of those perspectives seem to be based
in
confirming a world view as opposed to
and I'm not talking about editorials
because that's different I'm talking
about news reporting that's what's
important to me because
people including law enforcement offers
officers are informed by that
information and I saw that information
those assertions foreign influenced
monies Etc being played out
by any number of people and talked about
and I would challenge I would challenge
that and my point in this email was to
make this point which I believe is an
ethical and moral point and a point
premised in law
you know things like men's Raya and
actus Reyes are incredibly important in
this in terming and determining what we
see and what we base it on so the
labeling
was problematic to me
thank you sir I believe I'm out of time
um
okay so thank you for your answers to my
questions
okay thank you next is the ccla
good after or good evening uh
superintendent Morris can you hear me
okay I can good evening
my name is Kara zweebel I am a lawyer
for the Canadian civil liberties
Association I have also just five
minutes with you and I know I'm the only
person now keeping everyone from their
dinner so I will try to be as brief as
possible
um if I could get the document actually
that we just had up on the screen the
opp
um 40789 please
sorry I just wanted was that number
again sorry
sorry it's OPP uh four zeros789
sorry go ahead
I don't yeah I don't think that was it
um it was the email we were just looking
at
um
five zeros oh five zeros I'm sorry thank
you
um so I just want to uh take you to if
you can just scroll
um okay that's that's great thank you
um
and here you're sort of explaining why
why you're writing this email that you
have a somewhat unique view into the uh
the intelligence that was gathered
leading up to these events
um
and in the middle of the paragraph that
begins further
um
you say by way of example I see a marked
increase in the conversation of
extremists participating these events
and Canadians with extreme ideologies
leading the charge although there are
exceptions I have not seen evidence of
this in fact hendin received and
reported very little of this activity it
was not an evidence that the Ambassador
Bridge nor events related to the Blue
Water Bridge
further the events in Toronto did not
illustrate this by way of example the
Canadian Security intelligence service
had very little to report on and noted
that their targets were not engaged in
set and sorry can you just tell us what
inset is yeah inset is a federal Joint
Force operation led by the RCMP it
stands for integrated National Security
enforcement team and they have the
responsibility to engage in
investigations that meet the threshold
of section 83 of the criminal code
okay and so inset reported that the
activity did not meet their threshold in
National Security
um so I do not know where the political
figures are acquiring information or
Intelligence on the extent of extremist
involvement so so here just to you're
expressing the concern that this um
narrative around extremism is
um not consistent with the intelligence
that you gather collected reviewed over
the course of uh you know the weeks
leading up to these events that's
correct
okay
um
and is it fair to say I think uh
commission Council took you to uh I
think it was the February 7th
um one of the February 7th documents uh
where the you had a discussion about
sort of the the use of the term a threat
to National Security
um and why you were careful about that
term and how you explained that to some
of your some of your colleagues within
the opp
um
is it fair to say that at no point
during the Convoy protest did you
receive reliable intelligence that would
lead you to conclude that there was a
risk to National Security that would
rise above the the Potential Threat to
National Security that you identified in
that report that's correct
thank you
um can I get documents
OPP
four zeros850 gets four zeros maybe it's
five
and this is going to be an email that
you sent to
um is it is it Deputy Commissioner Cox
that's correct okay Deputy Commissioner
Cox
um and you're expressing you're
expressing your this is dated February
2nd so we're in the the midst of these
events
and you're saying that you're off poib
is increasingly receiving requests for
information intelligence open source
scrapes background checks Etc on a wide
array of societal actors many of these
entities are social movements that have
perspectives that diverge from the
mainstream they may not be engaged in
criminal activity nor do we have grounds
to believe or suspect that they are
these requests are emanating for many
clients internal and external to the OPP
at an escalating rate at the great
urgency and you're expressing some
concerns here maybe we can scroll down
can you explain the nature of your
concerns about these requests for
intelligence about various entities I
think this gets a little bit to to the
point that you were making in the
questions you were just being posed a
moment ago
yeah there seems to be a um a causal
linkage in somebody's in some people's
minds between certain things that are
not illegal or criminal
um
they just may not be in aligned with and
a Nexus to somehow an intelligence
threat I can give you an example I have
had instances where people have
approached me uh professionally because
there were bumper stickers
um that had to do with
um entities that they disagreed with so
therefore those people shouldn't be
police officers they shouldn't be parked
in policing sorry parking lots and I
heard terminology
that person is right wing so and then
therefore an assumption I used to hear
all that all the time about left wing
and I was very concerned about it
because I worked in anti-terrorism at
the time of
the 911 attacks and I saw what these
knee-jerk reactions do where we get
information from the public on any
number of issues related to what they
perceive to be threats from wahhabism or
salafism or Sunni extremism and there
always seems to be an overreach that
comes with this politicization and I've
had many instances where I've been asked
to go through these intelligence checks
without the reasonable grounds to
suspect or believe that there is a
threat posed there is merely
the presence of something or someone
that someone doesn't like
okay thank you
um and on the ethical front you noted
you were concerned that the the targets
of these requests were not engaged in in
criminal activity or there was no
reasonable and probable grounds to
believe that they were is that right
yeah can I give you an example just to
make an example of this if um somebody
engages in criminal activity violent
activity Etc uh that impacts people such
as it occurred in London Ontario such as
occurred in Nova Scotia these terrible
things I I like or people who are
engaged in weapons stockpiling etc etc
or illegal activity or we even have
grounds to suspect that then certainly
ideological affiliations religious
motivation political motivations mental
health issues all become issues to
assess and look at but because somebody
has I'm just going to use an example
um
a trump sticker on their bumper does not
a requirement to put the powers of the
state against that individual it
illustrates to me that somebody who
owned that car previously or currently
supported or wanted to be seen as
supporting
um
a former president or candidate Trump
and
it's as simple as that
it's indicative of politicization
thank you that was my my timer I'm just
if I can get the commission's Indulgence
for just one one more question
um
uh you distinguished earlier between uh
unlawful activity
um Civil Disobedience or Civil
Disobedience and and criminal activity
um and am I right in saying that the
um you don't view all access physical
Disobedience as as rising to the level
of of threats to to National Security or
rising to the level of threats of acts
of violence or even criminal activity
I'm sorry I'm I'm not sure I'm not sure
I entirely got that but you're asking me
you're you're saying asking me to agree
with that I don't agree that all acts of
Civil Disobedience rise to the level of
criminal activity is that the question
no that sorry that this was in relation
to a question you were opposed by
commission counsel
um I think in one of your reports you
noted that there was a serious risk of
sort of a a mass amount of Civil
Disobedience and you distinguish between
um those acts and acts that might amount
to Serious criminal activity
um or that could pose threats to
National Security there's a distinction
between those things is that right
yes there is a distinction uh
100 yes I agree with that there's a
distinction between and I also promised
that within where we as an intelligence
entity Focus we don't focus on smaller
acts of Civil Disobedience I.E a small
business owner opening their business in
contravention to the reopening Ontario
act that's a matter for Education from a
Detachment or a police service in a
possible Lane of a provincial offense
notice etc etc but more broad issues and
more significant issues of Civil
Disobedience that present as public
safety issues require our assessment and
collection to determine the nature of
the threat and the gravity of the threat
does that answer your question yes it
does there's a proportionality to these
things
exactly yes thank you thank you very
much those are my questions
okay uh next uh the Ontario Provincial
Police uh any uh
superintendent my name is Christopher
Diana as you know I'm counsel to the opp
just a couple of questions you'll recall
my friends from the commission brought
you to a document that showed the
various Hendon reports and their
distribution do you remember seeing that
document yes and there were quite a
large number of recipients correct yes
correct you mentioned some names of
people you know within the Ottawa Police
Service that received those reports and
you name them I'm not going to but you
remember naming those individuals yes I
do
if a recipient organization or person
wants to ask questions about a hand in
report how do they go about doing that
well one we're open anytime to any
questions I myself am secondly we had
teleconferences regularly in in relation
to these events daily and there was a
lot of give and take questions back and
forth and three I communicated directly
I did so today to the entire
intelligence distribution list and
actually created a different
distribution list of intelligence
managers to articulate goals and
tensions Etc and soliciting any feedback
so before the arrival of the Convoy in
Ottawa did you receive any requests
directly from Ottawa Police Service for
more information about intelligence or
to clarify any of the information that
had been provided
we received no requests for extra
activity that we request received a
great deal of gratitude for the activity
that was ongoing
did you do you recall whether you
received gratitude from Ottawa Police
Service
yes yes we did from the people involved
in intelligence Etc and do you recall
any of the specific individuals they
gave you that gratitude
yeah I remember superintendent Mark
Patterson saying thank you you know for
the collection efforts and the
intelligence products I believe
inspector Bryden as well and I remember
um
interim Chief
um Bell uh saying you know thank you in
terms of the Big 12 uh meetings etc for
for the information
before the arrival of the Convoy did
anyone from any of your recipient
organizations expressed any concerns
about the quality of your intelligence
product
no absolutely not
thank you superintendent those are my
questions
any uh re-examination non-commissioner
okay I I just have maybe a general
question you talked about and we heard a
lot about
project tendon
is there a federal equivalent to that
type of uh updated informay or
information circular almost like you
provide
sorry sir um there there I'm not aware
of any federal project that is
equivalent to Hendon I can say that my
RCMP colleagues are very engaged in
Hendon and
this can't be comprehensive but the
divisional Intelligence Officers are
engaged inset is engaged Federal
policing National Security is engaged
protective security is engaged there's
an entity and it's an acronym uh in
relation to ideologically motivated
extremists that are engaged and at
various times other divisions such as
Alberta and British Columbia Etc
participated
it do you know of any reason why it's
Ontario that's in the Ontario Provincial
Police that's quarterbacking this rather
than a federal agency
that's a good question I do know the
reason I know the reason is because we
started it um that that is the reason
and and that question has been asked to
me several times
um but uh
yeah we start at the project Hendon so
if that's that's the reason why we are
uh and then just another thing and I'm
I'm not sure I have my node is not clear
but I thought you distinguished between
a potential national security threat or
a risk to of National Security to
National Security is there a difference
between the two and could you explain
that for me I think it's lexicon or
semantics
um the highest level we got to was a
potential for the National Security
threats I would like to place that in
context just to be fair to all parties
um so ottawa's transpiring Coots is
transpiring the events in the Ambassador
Bridge occur and then there was
posturing on the 402 not of the Blue
Water Bridge in Sarnia Port Huron but
close and we had other information in
relation to the Nipigon Bridge not a
border but an incredibly important
logistical Link in Northwestern Ontario
and Pigeon River between Minnesota and
Ontario so when we talk about potential
National Security that's what we were
concerned with if those events transpire
and if they're successful then
that's very problematic in terms of our
our national borders now you didn't
mention the Manitoba uh
border crossing or the Surrey border
crossing is there a reason for that no I
didn't mention them you know I heard
about them at the time I honestly sure I
haven't been
there are were others the Peace Bridge
Fort Erie and buffalo was a significant
one uh the bridge at Cornwall was very
short-lived a threat it was going to be
and it ended very quickly the Landsdowne
Crossing east of gananakwe Watertown was
also the the organic mobilization once
the example was set with these were all
possibilities and so we tried to posture
to try to prevent
okay uh well thank you very much for
your uh your testimony and uh with very
interesting and forthright we thank you
very much you're free to go thank you
sir
so we're now going to break until
tomorrow morning 9 30 and uh tomorrow
should be a little bit shorter day but
uh don't count on it
we have always some uncertainties which
makes it uh always a challenge but also
interesting
the commission is a journal commissioner